THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER. AS YOU CAN
SEE, WE ARE STILL MISSING A FEW
OF OUR COLLEAGUES. SO WE'RE
GOING TO START THIS MORNING'S
PROCEEDINGS AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
THERE ARE 18 BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. HOWEVER AT LEAST ONE SO
FAR. ITEM NUMBER ONE, SB 895,
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON CONSENT.
THOSE BILLS ARE. ITEM THREE, SB
1391, ITEM NUMBER NINE, SB 1277,
ITEM NUMBER 18, SB 1138.
WITNESSES MAY BE ASKED TO LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THREE MINUTES
TO ENSURE THE COMMITTEE IS ABLE
TO COMPLETE TODAY'S AGENDA IN A
TIMELY FASHION. AGAIN, WE HAVE
NO QUORUM AS OF YET. LET'S BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WITH SENATOR
WILK'S FIRST BILL. HE'S BRINGING
IT DOWN RIGHT NOW. I'LL GO GET
IN PLACE. OKAY. YOU'LL OKAY?
YOU'LL BE IN THE STARTING
POSITION. I HAVE AN EXPERT
WITNESS WHO IS NOT HERE BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T EXPECT TO BE HERE FOR
A GOOD HOUR. OKAY AND IF ANOTHER
AUTHOR SURPRISES US BY
APPEARING, WE MAY GO THAT ROUTE.
WHILE WE ARE GETTING STARTED,
LET ME WELCOME OUR, INTERNET
VIEWERS FROM FAR AND WIDE,
INCLUDING JULIE FROM MISSOURI,
WHO WATCHES HER DAUGHTER AMANDA
DO HER WORK. I JUST GO BY
MEMORY. I DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
BILL NUMBER. SO NO. WHEN YOUR
STAFF, YOU KNOW THE BILL
NUMBERS, WHEN YOU'RE A MEMBER,
YOU DON'T KNOW ANY BILL NUMBERS.
BECAUSE I USED TO GET MAD AT MY
MEMBERS. WELL YOU DON'T KNOW THE
BILL NUMBER. SENATOR, IS THAT
TRUE, I DON'T KNOW MY BILL
NUMBERS. IF I GAVE IF YOU IF I
GAVE YOU A HINT, WOULD IT HELP?
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF WHEN YOU
THINK OF A LETTER? JUST GIVE ME,
WHICH ONE DO YOU WANT TO DO
FIRST, WE CAN WAIT. GOOD
MORNING, MR. JOHNSON, YOU'RE A
LITTLE LATE, BUT YOUR HAIR'S
PERFECT, SO IT'S OKAY. I'M
SORRY. DID NOT MEAN TO CALL YOU
OUT. ALL RIGHT. FOR THOSE OF US
WHO JUST JOINED SPECIFICALLY,
MR. JOHNSON, WE'RE WAITING, FOR
SENATOR WILK STAFF TO BRING HIM
SOME MATERIALS THAT WOULD ALLOW.
WILL ALLOW HIM TO BE ELOQUENT. I
DIDN'T SAY THAT. YOU DID. I DID
.
MY OFFICE ISN'T IN THE LOBBY, SO
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE'S NOT
HERE.
SENATOR WILK, WHY DON'T YOU COME
BACK TO THE DAIS AND WE'LL DO
THIS? I SAID GIVE ME A BILL
NUMBER. WE CAN GO NOW, BUT WE'LL
LET WE'LL LET'S. YEAH, LET'S
LET'S DO THAT. SO, SENATOR
GROVE, WELCOME, WE ARE GOING TO
WELCOME EVERYBODY AGAIN TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
AND WE ARE GOING TO AS OUR FIRST
BILL, WE'RE GOING TO HEAR ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ON THE AGENDA, SB
1063 FROM SENATOR GROVE. AND
WELCOME. SO YOU ARE WITNESS.
PLEASE TAKE ANY SEAT THAT FEELS
COMFORTABLE TO YOU, AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. FIRST OF ALL, MR.
CHAIR, I WANT TO DEEPLY THANK
YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART
FOR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL. IT
WAS EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT TO
ME AND SOME OF MY CONSTITUENTS,
AND SPECIFICALLY ISHMEET SINGH.
I ALSO WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE
ON THIS BILL AND WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS, WHICH CLARIFY AND
STRENGTHEN THE RESOURCE
INFORMATION ON STUDENT ID CARDS.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO
PRINT TELEPHONE NUMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE AND THE TELEPHONE
NUMBER FOR THE NATIONAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOTLINE ONTO STUDENT ID
CARDS. GRADES SEVEN THROUGH 12.
AS HELPFUL AS THESE NUMBERS ARE,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GIVE STUDENTS
A GREATER VARIETY OF RESOURCES
TO COMBAT MENTAL HEALTH
STRUGGLES THAT THAT ARE
PREVALENT AMONG MOST OF OUR
YOUTH. THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
REPORTED THAT IN 2022 THAT ONE
OF THE 1 IN 3 HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORT FEELING
CHRONICALLY, SAD OR HOPELESS,
AND 1 IN 6 HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
REPORT HAVING CONSIDERED SUICIDE
IN THE PAST YEAR AND HALF OF
THREE QUARTERS OF THE STUDENTS
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS THAT
DID NOT RECEIVE THE NEEDED CARE
THAT THEY DESIRED. SB 1063,
INSPIRED BY THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL, ISHMEET SINGH, WOULD
REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO PUT A LINK ON
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCE WEBSITE OF THE
COUNTY IN WHICH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS LOCATED, SO THAT THE
ID CARDS FOR SEVEN THROUGH 12
COULD BE MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
STUDENTS. IT ALSO MAKES MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCES MORE ACCESSIBLE
AND COMPREHENSIVE FOR STUDENTS
BY AUTHORIZING, AUTHORIZING, BUT
NOT REQUIRING HIGH SCHOOLS TO
PLACE A QR CODE ON THE STUDENT
ID CARD THAT LINKS THOSE
STUDENTS TO THOSE RESOURCES.
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO FIND
THE RESOURCES IN JUST THE RIGHT,
JUST RIGHT FOR THEIR NEEDS
WITHOUT NEEDING TO COLD CALL A
PHONE NUMBER ON THE STUDENT ID
CARDS AND MAKING IT SIMPLER AND
SUPER ACCESSIBLE. THINK ABOUT
THAT, COLLEAGUES. WE HAVE THE QR
CODE. THE STUDENTS CAN JUST TAKE
THEIR PHONE OUT. THEY CAN CLICK
THE QR CODE AND GO LINK TO A
WEBSITE AND DECIDE WHAT SERVICES
THAT THEY CAN USE, OR THAT THEY
FELT LIKE THEY NEEDED. THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND IS A
MUCH IMPORTANT, NEEDED STEP
TOWARDS IMPROVING THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF OUR STUDENTS. NOW, I
WOULD LIKE TO DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO MY SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND OUR LEAD WITNESS,
ISHMEET SINGH. AS A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT IN THE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT, MR. SINGH, WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING. YOU AND I HAVE MET
BEFORE, BUT I WELCOME YOU AS A
WITNESS. THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. SO, FIRST OF ALL,
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, I'M HONORED HERE TO
BE TESTIFYING BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AND A SPECIAL THANKS TO SENATOR
GROVE AND SENATOR NEWMAN FOR
EMPOWERING ME TO TESTIFY FOR A
BILL THAT I'M VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT. SO COMING OUT OF THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC AS A MIDDLE
SCHOOLER GOING INTO HIGH SCHOOL,
I STRUGGLED WITH SEVERE VIDEO
GAME ADDICTION, AND IT TURNS OUT
I WASN'T ALONE AS 20% OF
STUDENTS MY AGE STRUGGLED WITH
MENTAL ILLNESSES. AND TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS, I REACHED
OUT TO MY LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT, BUT IT TURNED
OUT THAT THEY ALREADY HAD 3 TO 4
HOTLINES ON THE BACK OF STUDENT
IDS. HOWEVER, THERE WAS STILL A
BIG GAP AS 66% OF CALIFORNIA VÀ
STUDENTS WHO NEED MENTAL HEALTH
CARE DON'T RECEIVE IT. SO TO
BRIDGE THE GAP, I ASKED MY HIGH
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND THE
CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE MISSING
PIECE? AND THEY SAID THAT
STUDENTS ARE HESITANT TO REACH
OUT TO THE COUNSELORS BECAUSE
THEY'RE FEELING SHY OR
EMBARRASSED. AND FURTHERMORE, IN
THE AGE OF TECHNOLOGY, WE WANT
EASY ACCESS TO THINGS. SO WITH
THIS BILL, I HOPE TO GIVE HIGH
SCHOOLS AND GRADE 7 TO 8 AS
WELL. THE OPTION TO IMPLEMENT A
QR CODE OR LINK THAT GOES TO A
BEHAVIORAL WEBSITE IN THIS
WEBSITE SHOULD GIVE INSTRUCTIONS
ON ON HOW TO HANDLE THEIR
DISTRESS. BUT ALSO GUIDES THEM
THROUGH WHAT EXACTLY THESE
DIGITS ARE. AS NOBODY'S FIRST,
INTUITION IS TO MEMORIZE OR DIAL
A BUNCH OF NUMBERS TO HANDLE
THEIR DISTRESS. THEY WANT
EVIDENT ANSWERS IN A SPAN OF A
COUPLE SECONDS. SO THAT'S MY
MISSION WITH THIS BILL. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. IF YOU GUYS HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS, I WOULD BE
HONORED TO ANSWER THEM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NO LEAD WITNESSES
THERE. ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION FOR
THE BILL? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION. SEEING NONE, ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE? IS THEIR LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE, ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION LIKE TO
EXPRESS POSITION? SEEING NONE,
LET US COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
GOT THE THUMBS UP FROM SENATOR
WILK, FOR MY PART, I WILL SAY,
SIR, WE SPOKE. I GIVE YOU CREDIT
NOT ONLY FOR, HAVING A GOOD
IDEA, BUT BEING AGGRESSIVE AND
RESOURCEFUL IN PETITIONING YOUR
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE TO
BRING THIS IDEA TO US, IT MAKES
EMINENT GOOD SENSE TO ME. I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT IT, WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM. WILL I HAVE?
CAN I COUNT ON YOU FOR A MOTION
WHEN WE. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
WILK, BUT, SENATOR GROVE, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND THANK YOU,
MEMBERS, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL TO YOU. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, BECAUSE THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
STUDENTS, AND IT WILL BRIDGE A
GAP IN THE TECHNOLOGY AGE THAT
THEY USE. I APPRECIATE THAT, MR.
SINGH. AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. I WANT TO TELL YOU
AND EVERYBODY ELSE HERE JUST
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ON THE BILL DOESN'T
MEAN THAT IT IS NOT A GOOD IDEA.
THAT'S PROOF, IN FACT, THAT IT
IS A GOOD IDEA. AND WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE UP A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU. I SEE
SENATOR PADILLA HERE. WELL, HE
WAS READY. WHERE IS HE WHEN YOU
NEED HIM? HERE. OH, THERE IT IS.
OH, THERE IT IS. YEAH, I
APPRECIATE THAT, VERY GOOD.
SENATOR PERDUE, WELCOME YOU ARE.
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING SB 1241,
AND DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
WITNESSES. DO YOU HAVE A
WITNESS? I DO NOT, DO NOT. WELL,
PROCEED WHEN READY, PLEASE.
THANK YOU. SIR. MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1241. I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF AND WILL BE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STRUGGLING TO
ADDRESS, AS WE KNOW, THE CRISIS
OF SCHOOL VIOLENCE AND YOUTH
SUICIDE. LAST THREE YEARS HAVE
SEEN THE HIGHEST INCIDENCE OF
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IN OVER A
DECADE. ADDITIONALLY, IN 2020,
SUICIDE WAS THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE. MAKING OUR SCHOOLS SAFE
AND NURTURING ENVIRONMENTS IS
VITAL TO ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CAN LEARN
AND GROW. SB 1241 THE SAFE
STUDENTS ACT, UPLIFTS EXISTING
TOOLS, STANDARDIZES IMPORTANT
PROTOCOLS AND APPROACHES,
INCLUDING APPROPRIATE ANONYMOUS
REPORTING SYSTEMS AND PREVENTION
AND TRAININGS TO HELP STUDENTS
LEARN ABOUT VIOLENCE PREVENTION
AND SUICIDE AWARENESS. IN
ADDITION TO PROFESSIONAL
CREDENTIALED STAFF, SB 1241
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO MAINTAIN A LIST OF
APPROVED, EVIDENCE BASED
TRAINING WITH INSTRUCTION IN
BOTH SUICIDE AWARENESS AND
VIOLENCE PREVENTION. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
COUNTY OFFICES OF ED, CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH AN ANONYMOUS
REPORTING SYSTEM TO GIVE
STUDENTS THE ABILITY TO REPORT
WHEN A PEER IS STRUGGLING.
ANONYMOUS REPORTING SYSTEMS AND
EVIDENCE BASED TRAINING PROGRAMS
ARE AVAILABLE TO OUR AVAILABLE
TOOLS THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY A
GROWING BODY OF RESEARCH. A
STUDY BY THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS ANALYZED THE USE OF
ONE ANONYMOUS REPORTING SYSTEM
AND FOUND THAT IN JUST ONE
STATE, THE SYSTEM LED TO OVER
1000 CONFIRMED MENTAL HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS, PREVENTED 100
IMMINENT SUICIDE CRISES, AND
STOPPED ALMOST 40 SCHOOL RELATED
VIOLENT INCIDENTS. EVIDENCE
BASED TRAINING PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE KNOW THE SIGNS PROGRAM
PROVIDED BY SANDY HOOK PROMISE,
HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO INCREASE
THE WILLINGNESS OF STUDENTS TO
REPORT WARNING SIGNS THAT THEY
OBSERVE AND TO AGAIN PREVENT
VIOLENCE. THIS BILL DIRECTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO TEACH YOUNG
PEOPLE ABOUT IDENTIFYING THE
SIGNS THAT SOMEONE MAY BE IN
CRISIS, AND GIVE STUDENTS THE
ABILITY TO REPORT WHEN A PEER
MAY BE STRUGGLING. WHEN WE
EMPHASIZE AND PROMOTE THESE
PROGRAMS, WE CREATE SAFER
SCHOOLS AND AFFIRM OUR MOST
SACRED OF DUTIES TO KEEP OUR
CHILDREN SAFE AND TO PROVIDE
THEM AN APPROPRIATE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE, ANY
ONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WELCOME. AND YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU. I WON'T TAKE
THEM. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS RACHEL
BOGERT, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE AT
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION, ACLU AND
OUR TWO OF OUR PARTNERS, THE
COLLECTIVE FOR LIBERATORY
LAWYERING, AS WELL AS YOUTH
JUSTICE EDUCATION CLINIC AT
LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL, DID SUBMIT AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
FOR THIS BILL. I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE AUTHORS OFFICE
FOR ACCEPTING SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, OR
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, SOME OF WHICH WERE
VERY IN LINE WITH WHAT WE HAD
ASKED, PARTICULARLY REMOVING THE
SECTION OF THE BILL RELATED TO
THREAT ASSESSMENT, WHICH IS A
MODEL THAT ISN'T SHOWN TO BE
EFFECTIVE AND CAN ADD ADDITIONAL
CRIMINALIZATION AND HARM FOR OUR
STUDENTS, WE AT THIS TIME, WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, BUT WE DO NOT THINK
OUR OPPOSITION IS FULLY REMOVED
AT THIS TIME, JUST BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE THERE ARE STILL PARTS
OF THE BILL THAT NEED A LITTLE
BIT OF WORK AROUND CLARIFYING,
AND REMOVING SOME OF THE OVER
INVOLVEMENT OF DOJ AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND PIECES
OF THE BILL. THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A CONFLATION OF THE
IDENTIFICATION AND RESPONSE TO
SUICIDALITY VERSUS POTENTIAL
MASS THREATS IN THE BILL THAT
COULD LEAD TO OVER INVOLVEMENT
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
DOJ IN, FOR EXAMPLE, DEVELOPING
MENTAL HEALTH INTERVENTIONS FOR
STUDENTS IN TRAININGS IN THAT
WHICH HAS THE RISK OF TAKING
CALIFORNIA IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION OF WHERE WE WANT TO GO
IN TERMS OF WHO SHOULD BE
RESPONDING TO A YOUNG PERSON'S
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS, WE ALSO
SEE SOME PLACES WHERE THIS BILL
COULD ENCOURAGE OVER SHARING OF
STUDENT DATA WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT COULD LEAD TO
INFORMATION ABOUT A STUDENT'S
DEMOGRAPHICS, DISABILITY STATUS,
AND OTHER INFORMATION SHARED
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
POTENTIALLY CHALLENGING WAYS.
THAT SAID, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON STRENGTHENING
THIS BILL. WE DO THINK THERE ARE
PARTS OF THIS THAT COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS,
WHICH IS WHY WE DIDN'T TAKE A
FULL OPPOSE POSITION. AND, YOU
KNOW, IF THE BILL DOES MOVE OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE, DO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO BE IN
THE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE,
SEEING NONE. LET'S COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES HERE, SENATOR
PADILLA, LET ME LET YOU ADDRESS
THE TWO CONCERNS, IDENTIFIED BY
THE OPPOSITION. ONE IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, THIS A QUESTION ABOUT
PROSPECTIVE OVER INVOLVEMENT OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, WE HAVE DONE A
BUNCH OF BILLS IN PAST YEARS
THAT HAVE EMPHASIZED
DE-ESCALATION, PARTICULARLY IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISES. SO IF
YOU WOULDN'T MIND SPEAKING TO
THAT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. I
APPRECIATE THAT. FIRST, WITH
RESPECT TO CONTINUING THE DIALOG
WITH THE ACLU, I'M GOING TO JUST
PUT ON THE RECORD THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND VERY WILLING TO
WORK WITH WITH ALL PARTIES WHO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT REFINING
THIS LANGUAGE AND MAKING IT
STRONGER AND MORE EFFECTIVE AND
IMPACTFUL. I THINK IT'S NATURAL
THAT WE WOULD SORT OF
PSYCHOLOGICALLY DEFAULT TO THE
WORST CASE SCENARIOS OF GUN
VIOLENCE AND MASS SHOOTINGS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE INCIDENCE
OF VIOLENCE IN THE SCHOOL AND IN
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT, IN
REALITY, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE NOT THAT. AND WE HAVE
BEEN WELL AWARE IN SOME OF THE
BEST STUDIES AND ANALYSIS HAVE
SHOWED THAT HAVING BOTH STUDENT
BODIES AGE APPROPRIATE,
APPROPRIATELY CONSTRUCTED AS
WELL AS THE PROFESSIONAL STAFF
THAT ARE ON THE SCHOOL SITE FROM
SUPPORTIVE STAFF ALL THE WAY UP
TO CREDENTIALED ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF TO UNDERSTAND THE PROPER
WAYS TO INTERVENE IN POTENTIAL
VIOLENCE THAT HAS THE THREAT OF
PROGRESSING, TO BEYOND JUST A
CONFLICT BETWEEN STUDENTS,
CONFLICT RESOLUTION, ALL THE WAY
UP TO ACTUAL BODILY HARM, IN A
MANY, MANY OF ITS FORMS IS VERY
APPROPRIATE. SO I DON'T THINK
THAT THE INTENT HERE IS AT ALL
TO CREATE A SYSTEM OF, AUTOMATIC
AND IMMINENT IMMEDIATE REPORTING
TO A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
UNLESS THAT PARTICULAR IMMEDIATE
CIRCUMSTANCE IS CRITICAL AND
IMMEDIATE AND ACUTE AND CALLS
FOR SUCH AN INTERVENTION
APPROPRIATELY. THAT IS NOT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE WHAT THE SYSTEMS THAT
ARE SOUGHT IN TERMS OF
BROADENING THE CURRICULUM AROUND
TRAINING, TEACHER TRAINING AND
STAFF TRAINING AND PUPIL
AWARENESS ARE NOT DESIGNED
AROUND A CRIMINAL, CRIMINAL OR
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE. AND I
WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR, COOL. I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, THAT'S GOOD TO
HEAR, BUT YOU'D ALLOW THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME ADDITIONAL SORT OF
CLARIFICATION. ABSOLUTELY. OKAY,
GOOD. AND YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT. SECONDLY I GUESS
YOU'VE TOUCHED ON IT OVER
SHARING OF DATA, FALLS INTO THE
SAME. YEAH. MY ONLY RESPONSE TO
THAT. MR. CHAIRMAN, I APPRECIATE
THAT BEING FLAGGED IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, DATA HAS TO BE TIMELY AND
RELEVANT, YOU KNOW, THAT THAT
DATA GENERALLY GOES TO THE
DISPOSITION AND THE BEHAVIOR OF
A, OF A STUDENT WHO MAY BE IN
CRISIS, I THINK, IN MUCH LESS TO
THEIR DEMOGRAPHIC
REPRESENTATION, AND I THINK WE
DO WANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO A
SYSTEM OF REPORTING OR A SYSTEM
OF AWARENESS, WHETHER THAT'S
INTERNAL CONVERSATIONS AMONG
STUDENTS AND THEIR TEACHERS, OR
WHETHER THAT'S INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS ON A SCHOOL SITE
OR BEYOND, OR ENTERED INTO A
SYSTEM OF REPORTING, MOST OF
THAT, I THINK ALL OF US WOULD
AGREE, NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED ON
THE OBJECTIVE OBSERVATIONS OF
SOMEONE WHO IS CLEARLY
STRUGGLING, IS IN CRISIS, AND
MAY BECOME A PROBLEM FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR OWN WELL-BEING, BUT THEN
THE WELL-BEING OF THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU. SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY, BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OUR POSITION TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS. MOVING
FORWARD, WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM, SO WHEN WE DO, WE'LL
TAKE A MOTION AND PUT THAT TO A
VOTE. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. WOULD YOU, I GUESS,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WHEN
APPROPRIATE? I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. AND I THANK THE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS. CERTAINLY. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD, I SEE SENATOR
DODD Ó. SENATOR LIMON. THAT'S
SORRY ABOUT THAT. WELCOME YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER
FIVE ON THE AGENDA, SB 1094.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES,
SB 1094 PROMOTES CIVIC LEARNING
IN GRADES ONE THROUGH EIGHT BY
REQUIRING INSTRUCTION IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT OR EXPERIENCE WITH A
GOVERNMENTAL INSTITUTION AT THE
LOCAL, STATE OR NATIONAL LEVEL
AT LEAST ONCE BETWEEN BETWEEN
GRADES ONE AND SIX AND ONCE
BETWEEN GRADES SEVEN AND EIGHT.
A 2016 SURVEY REVEALED THAT ONLY
A QUARTER OF AMERICANS CAN NAME
ALL THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT, HIGHLIGHTING THE
NEED FOR IMPROVED CIVIC
EDUCATION. EXISTING LAWS
ESTABLISH IN THE STATE SEAL OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT TO ENCOURAGE
THE CREATION OF PATHWAYS FOR
STUDENTS TO BECOME CIVICALLY
ENGAGED IN DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNMENTAL INSTITUTIONS AT THE
LOCAL, STATE AND NATIONAL LEVELS
. CURRENTLY, STUDENTS IN GRADES
11 AND 12 CAN EARN A STATE SEAL
OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT THROUGH A
VARIETY OF ACTIVITIES. TO DATE,
OVER 28,000 SEALS OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT HAVE BEEN AWARDED TO
11TH AND 12TH GRADERS IN OUR
STATE. SB 1094 FURTHER FURTHERS
EXISTING LAW BY CREATING
PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS IN
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
TO LEARN ABOUT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT,
CIVIC EDUCATION NOT ONLY EQUIPS
STUDENTS WITH CRITICAL THINKING
AND COLLABORATION SKILLS, BUT
ALSO ENHANCES SCHOOL ATTENDANCE
AND ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. WHILE
REDUCING SUSPENSION RATES. TODAY
WITH ME, WE HAVE DOCTOR MICHELLE
HERZOG FROM THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
DAVE GORDON, SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. WELCOME TO BOTH OF
YOU. DOCTOR HERZOG,
SUPERINTENDENT GORDON, WELCOME.
AWESOME. GREAT YOU CAN FLIP A
COIN, SEE WHO GETS TO GO FIRST,
OR YOU FLIP THE COIN EARLIER.
PLEASE PROCEED. YOU'LL HAVE THE
BIG FINISH. OKAY. YOU HAVE HIM
AS A CLOSER. YEAH, EXACTLY. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
K¾T. MY NAME IS DOCTOR MICHELLE
HERZOG. I'M THE COORDINATOR.
THREE FOR HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
AT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION. I'VE BEEN IN THIS
ROLE FOR OVER 20 YEARS. I WANT
TO SPEAK BRIEFLY, OF COURSE, IN
SUPPORT OF OUR BILL. WE KNOW THE
GOAL OF PUBLIC EDUCATION IS TO
CREATE GOOD CITIZENS, INFORMED
CITIZENS. BUT WE NEED
UNFORTUNATELY, CIVIC EDUCATION
ISN'T INTRODUCED TO STUDENTS AS
A REQUIREMENT. UNTIL THAT 12TH
GRADE, ONE SEMESTER, ONE FOOT
OUT THE DOOR GOVERNMENT COURSE,
RIGHT? AND SO YES, YOUNGER
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING THEIR
HISTORY. AMERICA'S HISTORY IN
THE YOUNGER GRADES. BUT CIVIC
EDUCATION IS HUGELY MARGINALIZED
OR IGNORED. IT'S NOT PART OF OUR
STATE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
IT'S NOT TESTED. IT'S NOT ON THE
DASHBOARD. SO SADLY, IT'S
MARGINALIZED GREATLY. THERE'S
GREAT EXAMPLES OUT THERE, BUT
THEY ARE THE EXCEPTION AND NOT
THE NORM. IF WE WANT YOUNG
PEOPLE TO EMBRACE OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES,
ENGAGE IN GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTIONS IN RESPONSIBLE
WAYS, AND GROW UP TO BE INFORMED
AND RESPONSIBLE VOTERS, WE NEED
TO START MUCH EARLIER. WE CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL HIGH SCHOOL TO HAVE
THAT HAPPEN. WE KNOW THE
BENEFITS OF CIVIC EDUCATION ARE
HUGE. ENGAGING IN THESE
INSTITUTIONS. WE KNOW THAT IT
BUILDS THEIR UNDERSTANDING,
THEIR SKILLS, THEIR ATTITUDES,
AS WE MENTIONED, INCREASES
ATTENDANCE RATES, GRADUATION
RATES. IT MAKES LEARNING
RELEVANT AND IT MAKES IT COME
ALIVE. WE KNOW THAT IT DOES NOT
CANNOT BEGIN IN 12TH GRADE. IT
NEEDS TO START WITH OUR YOUNGEST
CITIZENS, AND THE PRIORITY NEEDS
TO BE RAISED TO THE IMPORTANCE
OF OTHER SUBJECTS. THERE'S GREAT
EXAMPLES OUT THERE. THERE'S LOTS
OF POWER BEHIND THIS. WE NEED TO
START WITH OUR YOUNGEST STUDENTS
STARTING IN THE ELEMENTARY
GRADES. SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR HAD
ONCE SAID, KNOWLEDGE ABOUT OUR
GOVERNMENT IS NOT HANDED DOWN
THROUGH THE GENE POOL. EVERY
GENERATION HAS TO LEARN IT AND
WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO. SO WE
SUPPORT SENATE BILL 109 FOR
HOPING THAT IT WILL HELP KEEP
OUR REPUBLIC AND STRENGTHEN OUR
DEMOCRACY FOR DECADES TO COME.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK,
MR. GORDON. GOOD MORNING. AND
FIRST, I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
LIMÓN FOR TAKING UP THIS SO
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
ASSISTANCE IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS, EVERY BIT OF DATA THAT WE
HAVE NATIONALLY SHOWS US THAT
THE CIVIC UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE IS DECLINING. THE
NATION'S REPORT CARD SHOWS A
STEADY DECLINE IN CIVIC
UNDERSTANDING AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
AND OVERALL, MOST YOUNG PEOPLE,
BASED ON SURVEYS, DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THEIR SCHOOL CAREERS ENDED
UP PREPARING THEM FOR EVEN THE
MOST BASIC FUNCTIONS OF A
DEMOCRACY. LIKE HOW DO WE
REGISTER? HOW DO WE VOTE? AND AS
MOST OF OUR YOUTH OFTEN DEPEND
ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA FOR ALL OF
THEIR NEWS, OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM
BECOMES MORE AND MORE FRAUGHT
WITH AN INABILITY TO WORK
TOGETHER OR OFTEN EVEN TALK
TOGETHER. AND I'M OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER I'VE BEEN A
SUPERINTENDENT FOR 28 YEARS, AND
I WORKED FOR THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR 17
YEARS. I'M OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER PRESIDENT REAGAN AND
SPEAKER TIP O'NEILL. THERE
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN TWO MORE
POLAR OPPOSITE PERSONALITIES OR
SETS OF POLITICAL BELIEFS, YET
THEY UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE
OF SITTING DOWN TOGETHER AND
WORKING THROUGH THEIR
DISAGREEMENTS SO THAT OUR NATION
COULD MOVE ON IN A POSITIVE WAY.
SO OUR HOPE WITH THIS VERY, VERY
SIMPLE BILL IS TO BEGIN GIVING
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN ELEMENTARY
AND MIDDLE SCHOOL A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW OUR
GOVERNMENT IS SET UP FOR US TO
LIVE AND WORK TOGETHER AS ONE
NATION, AND TO CONTINUE TO WORK
HARD AND TOGETHER TOWARDS
CREATING THAT MORE PERFECT
UNION. AND I I'M I'M SO GRATEFUL
TO ALL OF YOU FOR CONSIDERING
THIS MEASURE. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT, BUT IT'S MOST
IMPORTANT FOR THE FOLKS HERE
ABOUT TO HEAR FROM NOW. THAT'S
OUR FUTURE. AND CONSIDER THIS
SORT OF, SORT OF OUR GIFT, OUR
GIFT TO THEM FOR, FOR THE
FUTURE. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. STATE
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION. THE FUTURE COMES
UP. THE PRESIDENT WILL JUST ET
ME Tê. FRED JONES, YOU'RE OVER
THERE. THEY'RE COMING UP. FRED
JONES, ON BEHALF OF THE TEACHERS
OF THESE PROGRAMS, CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR THE SOCIAL STUDIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. JONES.
WELCOME, LEADERS OF THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY NAME IS
ANUSHKA KALYAN. I'M A STUDENT AT
THE ROSEVILLE JOINT UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT, AND I GO TO
GRANITE BAY HIGH SCHOOL, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. HI, MY NAME IS
CASH MARQUARDT AND I GO TO WEST
CAMPUS HIGH SCHOOL AND I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR US HIGH SCHOOLERS
TO LEARN CIVICS SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO GET STARTED AS LATE AS I
DID, WHICH WAS IN SOPHOMORE YEAR
LAST YEAR, EVEN BEFORE I TOOK A
GOVERNMENT COURSE AND I HAD TO
FOSTER THIS INTEREST WITH
DIFFERENT. OKAY, THANK YOU. BUT
YOU DID GET STARTED WAY SOONER
THAN MANY OF US. SO PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO, MY NAME IS HALEY
AND I'M A STUDENT AT FOWLER HIGH
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY
NAME IS ASA CHESTER, AND I AM A
STUDENT IN THE SANGER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS HARRINGTON
WILLIAMS. I'M A JUNIOR AT WEST
CAMPUS HIGH SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU, HELLO. MY NAME IS
BRYCE MERRILL. I'M A STUDENT AT
WEST CAMPUS AS WELL IN THE PSUSD
SCHOOL DISTRICT, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HI. MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
MORELAND. I'M A HOMESCHOOL
PARENT. I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. WE STARTED EDUCATING
STARTING IN FIFTH GRADE, FOURTH
GRADE. AND I THINK IT'S GREAT.
AND MY DAUGHTER'S ACTUALLY HERE
TO PRESENT SOMETHING LATER.
EXCELLENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE, IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE WHO HAS THE NERVE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL, SEEING NONE. LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES.
ANY COMMENTS? QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. SENATOR CHOBOQ, I, I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR,
JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY, THOUGH,
BECAUSE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS CAN ALREADY BE DONE
IN, IN OUR SCHOOLS. SO THIS
WOULD ACTUALLY, ALLOW IT'S
ALREADY DONE IN THE HIGH SCHOOL.
SO WHAT WE'RE ENCOURAGING THIS
TO DO IS DO IT ONCE IT'S IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. WELL, DO IT
AT SOME POINT IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND DO IT AT SOME POINT
IN JUNIOR HIGH. THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE. NOT ALREADY DO THAT
IN, SOME DO BUT SOME DON'T. AND
SO THIS WOULD BE ACTUALLY A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN CAN. SO
THIS IS THIS IS MORE OF A
MANDATE FOR THE REST OF THE
SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE TO DO IT.
OKAY YOU KNOW, IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE I COMPLETELY, CONCUR
WITH THE COMMENTS FROM OUR
WITNESS, THIS MORNING WITH
REGARDS TO THE INABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO FACILITATE CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN OPPOSING OR OPPOSING
VIEWS, BASICALLY, BUT IT'S
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO NOTE,
SINCE COMING INTO THE SPACE,
BECAUSE I DID NOT HAVE POLITICAL
ASPIRATIONS, IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING HOW I ENDED UP HERE,
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
HAVE LEARNED SINCE BEING IN
OFFICE IS THAT EVEN WITHIN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM, OUR TEACHER,
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS,
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS DON'T
NECESSARILY UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE POLITICAL
SIDE AND THE GOVERNMENT SIDE.
YEAH AND IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE EVEN WHEN I HAVE REACHED
OUT TO SCHOOLS TO COME AND SPEAK
IN GOVERNMENT CLASSES PER SE, TO
TALK ABOUT GOVERNANCE AND TALK
ABOUT CALIFORNIA GOVERNANCE,
THERE'S A LOT OF HESITATION IN
COMING IN BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO SEEM POLITICAL. AND I
THOUGHT THAT THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING THAT EVEN WITHIN A
SCHOOL DISTRICT, ADULTS WHO ARE
IN THE TEACHING PROFESSION DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN GOVERNANCE AND THE
POLITICAL IN THE POLITICAL SIDE
OF IT, SO I ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE
THE DISCUSSION ON, ON, YOU KNOW,
GETTING INVOLVED WITH THE LOCAL
ELECTEDS AND UNDERSTANDING THE
DIFFERENCES AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
, HOW MUCH WE AS ADULTS NEED TO
START MODELING WHAT
COLLABORATION, OPEN DISCUSSION
OF IDEAS RATHER THAN WORKING IN
SILOS AND ECHO CHAMBERS, WHICH
HAS BEEN DETRIMENTAL TO, I
THINK, TO A LOT OF OUR OUR
SYSTEMS CURRENTLY WITHIN OUR
STATE OR WITHIN THE NATION. SO
I'M GRATEFUL TO HAVE THIS
FORWARD AND I'M I'M LOOKING THE
ONLY CONCERN I DO HAVE IS, WILL
THIS HAVE A COST TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND HOW DO WE HOW DO
YOU ENVISION THIS, BEING
FACILITATED WITHIN OUR SCHOOL?
BECAUSE WITH THE BUDGET DEFICITS
THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY AND AS WE
ASK OUR SCHOOLS TO DO MORE, HOW
ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO BE
ABLE TO, HAVE THE FUNDS TO BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE EVERYTHING THAT
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IS
REQUIRING THEM TO DO, ALREADY.
AND WHAT WE PLAN ON HAVING THEM
DO MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND. WELL I
THINK THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'LL HAVE. WE'LL
CERTAINLY HAVE IT IF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD, YOU KNOW, IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE, IS IT A LATER
IMPLEMENTATION DATE? IS IT, YOU
KNOW, SOME OTHER TYPES OF
FLEXIBILITY. BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
OPEN TO THAT. I MEAN, IT'S A
REAL ISSUE. SO AND I AND
ACTUALLY HERE'S THE FOLKS WHO
ARE IMPLEMENTING IT. SO GREAT
QUESTION. IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU, JUST
THIS WEEK ON MONDAY, I VISITED
TWO ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS IN EL
SEGUNDO THAT ALL THE FIFTH
GRADERS THERE ARE DOING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT WORK. THE KIDS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WATER, WATER
POLLUTION. THEY'RE IN EL
SEGUNDO. THEY'RE RIGHT THERE BY
THE HYPERION STATION. THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THE PLASTICS AND
THE OCEAN AND WHAT THEY LEARNED,
TO YOUR POINT EXACTLY, IS THEY
JUST CAN'T HAVE A PROTEST AND
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. THERE ARE
CITY ORDINANCES. THERE ARE
COUNTY ORDINANCES. THE STUDENTS
LEARN THESE ARE TEN YEAR OLDS,
THAT IT'S COMPLICATED. THERE'S
DIFFERENT ENTITIES THAT DEAL
WITH DIFFERENT THINGS, AND THEY
LEARN THE SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT
AS YOUNG AS TEN YEARS OLD. THE
TEACHERS LOVED IT BECAUSE THEY
INTEGRATED IT INTO THEIR
SCIENCE, THEIR ENGLISH CLASSES,
THEIR SOCIAL STUDIES. IN FACT,
THEY SAID, THIS IS NOT AN ADD ON
FOR US. THIS IS WHAT MAKES OUR
LEARNING COME ALIVE AND MAKE IT
RELEVANT. IT DIDN'T COST US ANY
MONEY TO DO THIS. IT MADE IT
EXCITING. IT MADE IT ENGAGING
AND THE TAKEAWAYS THAT THESE
KIDS EXPRESSED WERE HUGE. THEY
WERE HUGE. I JUST NOW I DIDN'T
REALIZE IT'S SO DIFFICULT TO
SOLVE SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS
NOW. I KNOW WHAT I THINK I CAN
DO, THAT I CAN HAVE SOME VOICE
AND MAYBE I CAN PAY ATTENTION TO
OTHER ISSUES AND KNOW WHERE TO
GO TO TRY TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS. SO THAT'S PART OF THE
GOAL OF GOOD QUALITY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT, TEACHING THEM THE
SYSTEM HOW TO WORK THROUGH THEM
IN RESPONSIBLE, THOUGHTFUL,
EFFECTIVE WAYS. NOT GO CRAZY ON
US, RIGHT? BUT JUST REALLY TO
LEARN THE SYSTEM. EMBRACE THE
PRINCIPLES, TRY TO MAKE OUR
DEMOCRACY STRONGER. WE CAN'T
WAIT TILL 12TH GRADE. THESE
LITTLE TEN YEAR OLDS, THEY'RE
READY TO ROLL. THEY KNOW THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS. THEY'RE
READY TO MOVE ON WHEN THEY GET
OLDER, AND THEY LOOK AT LIFE IN
THE BIG PICTURE. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR THE
TEACHING OF THESE SKILLS IS
ALREADY IN THE ELEMENTARY
CURRICULUM AS ADOPTED BY THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION AND THE
STATE. SO IT'S A MATTER OF
EMPHASIS AND LETTING YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE EXACTLY WHAT
MICHELLE TALKED ABOUT. THIS IS
INTERESTING. IT'S INTERESTING
STUFF TO GET ENGAGED IN WHEN I
WAS A SUPERINTENDENT IN THE ELK
GROVE DISTRICT, WE HAD THE CASE
OF TAKE UNDER GOD OUT OF THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. AND YOU
HAVE TO HANDLE THIS STUFF
CAREFULLY. SO WE SET UP A
CONTEST, AN ESSAY CONTEST WHERE
OUR KIDS IN THE IN THE DISTRICT
WERE ASKED TO WRITE ON EITHER
SIDE OF THE QUESTION, AND WE, WE
HAD THE ESSAYS READ AND WE
RAISED MONEY AND WE TOOK THE
KIDS THE TWO WINNERS BACK TO
WASHINGTON TO HEAR THE SUPREME
COURT, THE SUPREME COURT DEBATE.
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY GOT INVOLVED
. AND IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR
EVERYBODY. AND JUST TO BE CLEAR,
THIS DOES NOT REQUIRE A NEW
CURRICULUM THAT ALREADY EXISTS
BECAUSE OF PRIOR LAW. SO THIS IS
JUST THE EMPHASIS, AS WAS SAID.
SO NEW CURRICULUM WOULDN'T HAVE
TO BE CREATED FOR THIS. IT'S
JUST THAT THERE WOULD BE AN
EMPHASIS, A COORDINATED EMPHASIS
THROUGH THE DISTRICT AND SCHOOL.
SO VERY GOOD. SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. SO MADAM, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
NEWMAN HERE, NEWMAN HERE.
OKOBOJI HERE. OKOBOJI HERE.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ HERE. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. PRESENT. WILK. PRESENT.
SO, COLLEAGUES. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? SENATOR
WILK A COMMENT. I HAVE A
COMMENT. I THINK THIS IS LONG,
LONG, LONG OVERDUE BECAUSE I
TALKED TO FIFTH GRADERS, EIGHTH
GRADERS AND 12TH GRADERS AND
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT I THINK
IS LACKING. AND I THINK HAVING
IT EMBEDDED IN THE REGULAR
CURRICULUM CURRICULUM IS SMART,
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD, AN
AMENDMENT, I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
I'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER TAKING
IS ACTUALLY HAVING, THIS KIND OF
TRAINING FOR LEGISLATORS BECAUSE
I FEEL LIKE THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND. NO, NO, BECAUSE THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND. THEY'RE A
CO-EQUAL BRANCH OF THE
GOVERNMENT. AND THEY DON'T HAVE
TO GET ON BENDED KNEE TO THE
GOVERNOR NOTED. AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE PUBLIC POLICY FOR ALL.
SO I HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER THAT
MOVING FORWARD. DULY NOTED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
INPUT. I KNOW YOU'RE WELL. OKAY,
SO FROM MY PART, I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. I ARGUE
PROBABLY THIS DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH, AND THAT CIVICS IS A
THREAD THAT SHOULD RUN THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE YEAR OF SCHOOL. AND
I THINK WITH RESPECT TO COST,
THIS IS MORE A MATTER OF
PRIORITIZATION THAN IT IS OF
COST. AND EVEN IF THERE IS A
COST, THAT COST IS MORE THAN
JUSTIFIED BY THE ULTIMATE
BENEFITS. AND I THINK IT'S FAIR
TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IS A MUSCLE THAT
NEEDS TO BE EXERCISED, DEVELOPED
AND THEN EXERCISE CONSTANTLY.
AND WE'RE DOING IT ON AN AD HOC
BASIS AND CLEARLY NOT DOING IT
WELL ENOUGH. SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. I'D BE
GRATEFUL TO BE ADDED AS A
COAUTHOR MOVING FORWARD. I LOVE
THAT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. AND DO I HAVE A
MOTION? WILK MOVES. SENATOR MILK
WILK MOVES. SENATOR WATT MOVES.
GOT WILK. SENATOR. SENATOR WILK.
HE SAID MILK, DIDN'T HE? I DID.
YOU'RE LOOKING UNUSUALLY PALE
TODAY. SO OH, MY GOD, MADAM,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR ITEM
FIVE. SB 1084 LIMÓN MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. I OKOBOJI. I
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ. CORTEZ I.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK I WILK I. ALL RIGHT.
THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES.
WE'LL HOLD IT OPEN. BUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES.
AND THANK YOU TO THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO CAME HERE TO TESTIFY.
AND I FULLY EXPECT TO SEE YOU
HERE EVERY WEDNESDAY MOVING
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP, WE
HAVE SENATOR RUBIO. WELCOME.
THE SENATOR GODSWILL, TO BE
NEXT. NOW, SENATOR RUBIO IS THE
FIRST TWO BILLS. I'M LOOKING AT
MY WRONG. OH YES. YES, YES. ALL
RIGHT. SO WELCOME, TO SENATOR
RUBIO. AND YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING SB 1056. YOUR OTHER
BILL IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU. PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. WELL,
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU, CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING THIS BILL, AND THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR HOW
GREAT SB 1056 IS FOR OUR
CHILDREN. THIS IS LEGISLATION
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
RECEIVE CRITICAL INSTRUCTION IN
THEIR CRITICAL EARLY YEARS OF
LEARNING. SPECIFICALLY, SB 1056
WILL REQUIRE STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE ONE YEAR OF
KINDERGARTEN BEFORE ENTERING
FIRST GRADE BY THE YEAR 20 2627.
THIS YEAR, I HAVE COLLABORATED
WITH THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
CHAIR, THIS IS JUST TO HIGHLIGHT
HOW IMPORTANT THIS TOPIC IS. AND
SO HE HAS A COMPANION BILL, AND
WE HAVE ONE IN BOTH HOUSES AS AN
EDUCATOR FOR 20 YEARS, I HAVE
PERSONALLY WITNESSED HOW EARLY
EDUCATION CAN HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON STUDENT ACADEMIC
SUCCESS. AND NOT JUST ACADEMIC,
BUT THE OVERALL HEALTH. AND, YOU
CAN INSTANTLY SEE WHEN A CHILD
IS MISSING KINDERGARTEN, FOR
EXAMPLE, AS A FIRST GRADE
TEACHER, OUR CHILDREN WALK IN
NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT SCHOOL
IS. THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO HOLD
A PENCIL. THEY'RE PLAYING WITH
EVERY MATERIAL THAT YOU GIVE
THEM. BUT EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THEY THEY LACK SELF CONFIDENCE,
SELF ESTEEM, AND THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO HOW TO INTERACT AND THEY
WITHDRAW. AND SO YOU SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE THAT
HAVE GONE TO KINDER. THEY'RE
USUALLY TWO YEARS AHEAD OF THOSE
THAT DID NOT ATTEND KINDER. AND
THEY'RE ALREADY TALKING ABOUT
PROJECTS THAT THEY WORKED ON,
SUMMER PROJECTS, YOU KNOW,
SCIENCE, THINGS THAT THEY DID
OVER IN THE SUMMER. SO YOU START
SEEING THE DISPARITY, AND THE
GAP ONLY GROWS EXPONENTIALLY.
AND IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
CATCH STUDENTS UP AT THAT POINT,
AGAIN, STUDENTS WHO DO NOT
ATTEND KINDERGARTENS HAVE
DIFFICULTY. AND FIRST GRADE, MY
ISSUE WITH NOT MANDATING,
KINDERGARTEN IS THAT WE DO HAVE
SKILLS THAT WE REQUIRE CHILDREN
TO KNOW AS THEY COME INTO FIRST
GRADE BY WAY, OF EXAMPLE, WE
EXPECT CHILDREN TO KNOW THE
LETTERS THEY HAVE TO KNOW HOW TO
WRITE A SENTENCE. SO THEN IN
FIRST GRADE, WE CAN ADVANCE
THOSE SKILLS AND SHOW THEM HOW
TO WRITE A PARAGRAPH. BUT YET WE
EXPECT THEM TO COME WITH BASIC
SKILLS, AND YET WE DON'T MANDATE
THAT THEY ATTEND KINDER SO THEY
CAN HAVE THOSE SKILLS. NOT ONLY
DOES IT HARM THE CHILDREN, BUT
AS A TEACHER, I CAN TELL YOU
TEACHERS CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE.
THEY'RE USING A LOT OF THEIR
TIME FOR REMEDIATION VERSUS
ADVANCING SKILLS. AND SO
TEACHERS ARE EXHAUSTED. IT'S
GETTING HARDER AND HARDER ON
THEM. THE WORKLOAD CONTINUES TO
INCREASE. AND ON TOP OF THAT,
THE LEARNING LOSS THAT WAS
CREATED DURING THE PANDEMIC HAS
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT. AND SO
THIS IS THE BEST WAY TO SUPPORT
NOT ONLY OUR STUDENTS, BUT OUR
TEACHERS AND PARENTS WHO DON'T
HAVE THE SKILLS TO HELP THEIR
CHILD BACK AT HOME AND TO
PROVIDE A SCREENSHOT IN 2020
2021 ACADEMIC YEAR, KINDERGARTEN
ENROLLMENT HAD DROPPED BY 14% IN
LAUSD. THAT'S A DECLINE OF 6000
STUDENTS OVERALL. AND SO THAT'S
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE'RE
LOSING STUDENTS, NOT GAINING
STUDENTS. AND SO ESPECIALLY IN
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM'S LOWEST
NEIGHBORHOODS, THE CHILDREN THAT
OFTEN STAY HOME ARE THE ONES
THAT NEED IT MOST. THOSE THAT
COME FROM DISADVANTAGED HOMES,
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. AND SO THAT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
GRID ALREADY EXISTS.
KINDERGARTEN IS ALREADY A GREAT
THAT THAT WE ACCEPT. BUT WE'RE
NOT ENCOURAGING THAT SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS THAT DROP
OFF TO JOIN. AND AGAIN, THESE
ARE THE CHILDREN THAT THE KIDS
THAT REALLY NEED IT. BUT I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT SOMETHING THAT FOR
ME, IT'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT,
AND COMPELLING, I WOULD SAY, AS
A TEACHER AND VICTIMS ADVOCATE,
WE NEED ALL OUR STUDENTS IN OUR
CLASSROOMS. THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY THE KIDS
THAT ARE ALREADY BEING
NEGLECTED, THE KIDS THAT ARE
BEING ABUSED, MISTREATED. AND
IT'S THE OPPORTUNITY TO CAPTURE
THOSE CHILDREN AND PROVIDE
SERVICES EARLY ON. AGAIN THOSE
ARE CRITICAL YEARS FOR OUR
STUDENTS. AND WE CAN HAVE THEM
IN CLASS. THEY'RE ALSO ARE BEING
FED THREE TIMES A DAY, WHICH IS
IMPORTANT. A LOT OF THE TIME.
THESE ARE THE KIDS THAT ARE LEFT
HOME WITHOUT FOOD. I KNOW THAT
AS A TEACHER IN MY CLASSROOM, I
ALWAYS HAD FOOD FOR EVERY SINGLE
GRADE LEVEL, AND YOU ALWAYS HAVE
A HANDFUL THAT WILL TELL YOU
THEY CANNOT THINK OR WORK
BECAUSE THEIR TUMMY HURTS. AND
AS TEACHERS, YOU ALWAYS HAVE A
LOT OF FOOD IN THE CLASSROOM AND
YOU FEED THEM BEFORE YOU CAN
TEACH. I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THOSE
THAT ARE FIVE YEARS OLD AT HOME,
SIX MAYBE, AND NOT HAVING ANY
FOOD. SO THERE'S OTHER BENEFITS,
NOT JUST ACADEMIC BENEFITS, BUT
ALSO JUST SOCIALLY. EMOTIONALLY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE EVERY OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT CHILD TO SUCCEED. ALONG
WITH THEIR PEERS. AND SO WE JUST
NEED TO CLOSE THE GAP. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AND MANY OF
US I COME FROM HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE EITHER FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
OR PERHAPS, YOU KNOW, WE DEFER
IT TO THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM TO
TELL US WHAT'S IMPORTANT. SO WE
TELL PARENTS THAT KINDERGARTEN
IS NOT MANDATORY. THEY TAKE THAT
AS TO MEAN IT'S NOT IMPORTANT.
AND THEY CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT
THE EDUCATION OF THEIR CHILDREN,
BUT THEY'LL KEEP THEM HOME
BECAUSE WE'RE SAYING IT'S NOT AN
IMPORTANT GRADE. SO WITH THAT, I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
WITNESSES. IF I MAY, JOINING ME
TODAY IS CTA REP AND LAUSD REP.
SO I'M GOING TO START WITH, GO
AHEAD. WHETHER A TEACHER HERE
FROM ELK GROVE, YOU CAN TESTIFY
FROM THERE. YEAH. WELCOME, MISS
LOU. THE RED BUTTON AND IT'LL
TURN GREEN. AND YOU EACH YOU
EACH HAVE THREE MINUTES. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS TERRY LOWE. AND I'M A TEACHER
IN ELK GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I AM IN MY 30TH YEAR
OF TEACHING AND 12TH YEAR OF
TEACHING KINDERGARTEN. YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD THE SAYING, ALL I
REALLY KNOW, ALL I NEED TO
LEARN, OR ALL I REALLY KNOW. I
LEARNED IN KINDERGARTEN BY
ROBERT FULGHUM AND I WAS A
KINDERGARTEN STUDENT IN THE
1970S, AND KINDERGARTEN HAS
CHANGED A LOT SINCE THEN,
THERE'S A CONCEPTION THAT
KINDERGARTEN IS PLAYTIME TIME
AND RECESS CRAFTS NAP FOR FIVE
AND SIX YEAR OLDS, BUT A THESE
DAYS IT'S FAR FROM THE CASE. BY
THIRD GRADE, THE GOAL IS FOR
EVERY CHILD TO BE READING ON
GRADE LEVEL. KINDERGARTEN IS
WHEN A CHILD GAINS ESSENTIAL
FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS THAT ARE
BUILT ON BUILDING BLOCKS OF
SUCCESS. NOT ONLY DO CHILDREN
NEED TO KNOW ALL OF THEIR LETTER
NAMES AND SOUNDS BY THE END OF
KINDERGARTEN, BUT THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO READ CONSONANT VOWEL
CONSONANT WORDS. READ 30 SIGHT
WORDS. READ A COMPLETE BASIC
SENTENCE RIGHT TO COMPLETE
SENTENCES WITH PHONETIC
SPELLING, CAPITALS, SPACES, AND
CORRECT PUNCTUATION. IN MATH, A
STUDENT NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE NUMBERS TO 20 AND BE
ABLE TO ADD AND SUBTRACT NUMBERS
TO TEN, ALONG WITH MANY OTHER
STANDARDS RELATED TO OTHER
SUBJECT AREAS. WITHOUT THIS
FOUNDATION OF LEARNING TO READ
AND WRITE IN KINDERGARTEN, THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO READ AND
WRITE TO LEARN IN FIRST GRADE.
IN KINDERGARTEN, THEY ALSO LEARN
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL TOOLS TO
HELP WITH SELF-REGULATION IN
ORDER TO COPE WITH STRESS,
ANXIETY AND IN MANY CASES,
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA. THEY LEARN HOW
TO COMMUNICATE AND SOCIALIZE AND
GAIN UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY ARE
PART OF A SCHOOL COMMUNITY. THEY
LEARN WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
STUDENT IN A SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT.
THEY LEARN ESSENTIAL
EXPECTATIONS THAT WILL FOLLOW
THEM THROUGH THEIR ENTIRE SCHOOL
HISTORY. NOW, WITH THIS
PERSPECTIVE, IMAGINE BEING A
FIRST GRADE STUDENT WHO DID NOT
GO TO KINDERGARTEN AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE BASICS WITHOUT
THE GROUNDWORK, THE CHANCES OF
SUCCESS HAVE DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY. IN ORDER FOR
KINDERGARTEN KIDS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND HAVE A SOLID
FOUNDATION, PLEASE CONSIDER
MAKING KINDERGARTEN A MANDATORY
START TO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
CAREER. WHAT HAPPENS IN
KINDERGARTEN WILL LAST A
LIFETIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MISS ESTRADA, WELCOME. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS DOCTOR KARLA
ESTRADA. I AM THE DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF INSTRUCTION
FOR LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. IT IS WITH GREAT
OPTIMISM THAT I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY. ACTUALLY SIT BEFORE YOU
TODAY REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AS A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF SENATE BILL
1056, WHICH IS AN EQUITY DRIVEN
STEP TOWARDS MAKING KINDERGARTEN
MANDATORY IN OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
GREAT INVESTMENTS IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD, AND UT K, WHICH HAS
SUPPORTED OUR STUDENTS ACADEMIC
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
FOUNDATIONS. WHEN YOU WALK INTO
A UT K CLASSROOM, IT'S BEAUTIFUL
TO SEE OUR STUDENTS SITTING WITH
THEIR TEACHERS, WITH THEIR
EDUCATORS, AND LEARNING ABOUT
LETTERS, LEARNING ABOUT BOOKS,
LEARNING ABOUT STORIES AND
JOURNEYS THAT THEY THEMSELVES
ONE DAY WILL EXPERIENCE AS THEY
SIT ACROSS THEIR TEACHERS AND
KIDNEY TABLES WITH THEIR FELLOW
PEERS, ENGAGING IN SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS THAT ARE BEAUTIFUL,
COOPERATIVE LEARNING SKILLS THAT
THEY'LL USE AS THEY ENGAGE IN
MORE RIGOROUS LEARNING
EXPERIENCES. THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A CORNERSTONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROMISE THAT EVERY
CHILD STARTS THEIR EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY. EQUIPPED WITH THE EARLY
LEARNING EXPERIENCES ESSENTIAL
FOR FUTURE SUCCESS, IT IS A BOLD
STEP TOWARDS EQUITABLE
EDUCATIONAL POLICY, AIMING TO
BRIDGE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT
TOO OFTEN DIVIDES OUR STUDENTS
FROM UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES,
SUCH AS IN LA USD, WHERE 86% OF
OUR STUDENTS LIVE IN POVERTY OR
SOCIOECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES UNIFIED,
WE CONTINUE TO SEE EVIDENCE OF
STUDENTS BENEFITING FROM
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH THEIR
PERFORMANCE DATA AT THE END OF
THE YEAR, WITH DIBELS ASSESSMENT
AND FIRST SECOND INTO THIRD
GRADE. WE ALSO SEE STUDENTS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED HIGHER ACHIEVEMENT
LEVELS AS LATE AS INTO FIFTH
GRADE, JUST BECAUSE OF THE
EXPERIENCES THEY HAD IN
KINDERGARTEN. THÀNH THE POSITIVE
IMPACT OF MANDATORY KINDERGARTEN
IS NOT CONFINED TO THE
BOUNDARIES OF LA GRANDE.
BREAKING RESEARCH BY RESEARCHERS
AT UC IRVINE HAS SHOWN THAT
STUDENTS FROM STATES THAT
EMBRACE THIS POLICY NOT ONLY
HAVE A HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION, THEY
ALSO HAVE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AS ADULTS.
DATA SHOWS THAT THIS IS MOST
SIGNIFICANT OF AN IMPACT ON OUR
LATINO AND BLACK STUDENTS,
UNDERSCORING THE URGENCY OF
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR EVERY
CHILD, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
BACKGROUND. THE CONVERSATION
AROUND THIS POLICY AND ITS
BENEFITS ALSO BRING TO LIGHT
CONCERNS REGARDING POTENTIAL
COST IMPLICATIONS FOR THE STATE
AND AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE,
ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR. HOWEVER A
CLOSER LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
REVEALS AN OPPORTUNITY RATHER
THAN A BURDEN. WE HAVE SEEN HOW
ENROLLMENT STARTING EARLY ON
ENSURES THAT OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR STUDENTS CONTINUE TO VOTE
WITH THEIR FEET AND STAY IN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM. IT CREATES A PATH
FOR THEM FROM AN ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL PERSPECTIVE,
BUT ALSO HELPS FAMILIES BE WELL
INFORMED OF THE JOURNEY THEY'RE
EMBARKING ON IN SCHOOLS. WE'RE
SEEING THE RECENT DECLINE IN
TOTAL K TO 12 ENROLLMENT. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE RESOURCES TO
WELCOME THESE YOUNG LEARNERS ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE, SAFEGUARDED
FROM PROP 98 FUNDS WITHOUT
NECESSITATING CUTS TO OTHER
VALUABLE PROGRAMS. OUR HOPE IS
TO SEE CALIFORNIA JOIN THE 18
STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THIS TRANSFORMATIVE
POWER OF EARLY CHILDHOOD BY
EMBRACING KINDERGARTEN AS A
MANDATORY STEP IN EVERY CHILD'S
ACADEMIC AND PERSONAL
DEVELOPMENT. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, ARE THERE OTHERS IN
THE COMMITTEE HEARING WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD, YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION.
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SALLY UPTON, CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION, FIFTH
GRADE TEACHER, ELK GROVE
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION. I STAND
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. KATIE HARDIMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION,
A CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL. AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SARAH
LILLIS WITH TEACH PLUS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, CHRISTINA SALAZAR. WITH
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU. MORNING. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRISTAN BROWN WITH CFT,
UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LARA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SIERRA COOK WITH THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING DOMINIQUE DANNY WITH
EDVOICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MARTHA ALVARADO.
THE L.A. UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PRACTICAL SPONSOR. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION? THE BILL
REGISTERED AND TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO VOTE. SEEING NONE,
LET'S COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, COLLEAGUES, PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. SO WE SPOKE
ON THIS BILL LAST YEAR, AND, YOU
KNOW, I WAS NOT IN SUPPORT OF IT
, WITHOUT A QUESTION OF A DOUBT,
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THE
BENEFITS OF KINDERGARTEN. MY
KIDS WENT TO KINDERGARTEN, BUT
THERE WERE SOME CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE HAD WITH REGARDS TO IF
THEY DIDN'T HAVE, THE FORMALITY
OR THE MANDATE OF COMING TO, TO,
TO KINDERGARTEN, HOW WOULD THEY
BE ASSESSED TO BE ABLE TO ENTER
FIRST GRADE? RIGHT. IF THEY IF,
IF KINDERGARTEN, IF YOU HAVE AN
OPTION. TO DEPENDING ON THE
PARENT, WHETHER THE PARENT IS
DOING SCHOOLING AT HOME
ORGANICALLY OR NOT, THERE ARE
MANY PARENTS WHO WANT TO TEACH
THEIR CHILDREN IN AN IN A MORE,
ONLY WAY I CAN THINK OF
DESCRIBING AS IN AN ORGANIC WAY,
NOT IN A, IN AN ESTABLISHED WAY,
BECAUSE WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH REGARDS TO
ASSESSMENTS. YOU KNOW, HOW EARLY
IS IT TOO EARLY TO ASSESS A
CHILD, YOU KNOW, IS IT
KINDERGARTEN TOO EARLY? FIRST
GRADE. I REMEMBER WHEN I TAUGHT
FIRST GRADE. SECOND GRADE AND
THIRD GRADE. I TAUGHT ALL THREE
THIRD GRADES ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. SO ALSO, FROM A
TEACHER'S PERSPECTIVE AND FROM A
PERSONAL PARENTS PERSPECTIVE,
YOU KNOW, I ACTUALLY TAUGHT MY
KIDS HOW TO READ AT HOME, AT
HOME BEFORE THEY ENTERED SCHOOL,
ALONG WITH PRESCHOOL. SO, YOU
KNOW, VERY ENGAGED ON THAT PART.
BUT THERE ARE FAMILIES OUT THERE
THAT WANT TO DO IT ORGANICALLY.
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR KIDS IN A
SYSTEM. VERSUS, SAY, WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SUCCUMBED TO
THE PRESSURES OF ASSESSMENTS, TO
THE PRESSURES OF, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER THEY FIT IN OR DO NOT
FIT IN, ALTHOUGH WE KNOW THAT
KINDERGARTEN IS GREAT AND SOME
CLASSROOMS ARE PHENOMENAL, IN
SCHOOLS CAN PROVIDE AN OPTIMAL
ENVIRONMENT. BUT THERE ARE
PARENTS WHO CHOOSE TO IT, YOU
KNOW, IN A NONTRADITIONAL BEALL,
WAY. AND I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE DATA, WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT 95% OF STUDENTS
ACTUALLY ATTEND SOME SORT OF
KINDERGARTEN OR A FORMAL
KINDERGARTEN, WHETHER PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE SCHOOL, THAT ONLY LEAVES
A VERY, VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
KIDS WHO ACTUALLY DO NOT. SO THE
IDEA OF MANDATING OR JUST PUTS
IN NOW THE FACT THAT THE STATE
CAN NOW DICTATE TO THAT PARENT
HOW WHAT THE CHILD IS GOING TO
LEARN, WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO GO
TO SCHOOL AND IT PUTS A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON THOSE FAMILIES.
INSTEAD OF GIVING THEM THE
FREEDOM TO CHOOSE HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THEIR KIDS TO
TEACH BEFORE THEY COME INTO THE
SYSTEM WHERE THEY HAVE TO BE
FORMALLY ASSESSED, AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I DON'T
SUPPORT THE BILL, NOT THE
PREMISE OF IT. AS FAR AS THE
BENEFITS OF IT, YES, ABSOLUTELY
WONDERFUL BENEFITS. BUT WE DO
HAVE TO ALLOW FOR PARENTS TO
HAVE THOSE CHOICES. AND ALSO
HAVE THOSE CHILDREN BE CHILDREN.
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE JUST THE,
THE, THE FREEDOM TO HAVE NOT THE
PRESSURES OF THE WORLD PER SE OR
OF THE SYSTEM PER SE, BUT, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE CHILDREN WHO ARE
LEARNING VERY ORGANICALLY IN
OTHER MEANS. SO, I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE NOT TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AS A MANDATE, NOT TO NOT TO SAY
THAT I DON'T SUPPORT THE
PRINCIPLE OF ENCOURAGING OUR
KIDS. AND ONE OF THE FOCUSES FOR
THOSE KIDS THAT DO NOT HAVE,
PARENTS WHO KNOW HOW TO TEACH
THEIR KIDS AT HOME OR BE
INVOLVED WITH THEIR EDUCATION. I
ACTUALLY AM A HUGE SUPPORTER OF
PROGRAMS THAT ACTUALLY EMPHASIZE
A CULTURE AND A REACH OUT TO
PARENTS AND FAMILIES TO TEACH
THEM, LIKE, THIS IS WHAT WE WANT
TO SUPPORT. THIS IS HOW YOU CAN
HELP YOUR KID TO LEARN AT HOME.
THIS IS WHAT YOU CAN DO. TO
IMPLEMENT, YOU KNOW, SUCH AND
SUCH PROGRAMS AT HOME. THAT'S
WHAT I DID. YOU KNOW, EVEN AS A
TEACHER, ONCE I HAD MY KIDS, I
HAD MY FELLOW MENTOR, TEACHER
COME TO ME BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN A
PARENT JUST NINE MONTHS PRIOR
TO, TO ME, COME AND SAY, HEY, I
LEARNED OF THIS, OF THIS AUTHOR
OF THIS RESEARCH. I WANT TO
SHARE IT WITH YOU SO THAT YOU
CAN DO THIS AT HOME. I DID
THINGS AT HOME WITH MY INFANT
CHILD UP UNTIL, YOU KNOW, THEY
ENTERED SCHOOL AT THE AGE OF
FIVE. WHAT WE DID PARENT
EFFECTIVE PARENTING CLASSES,
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDED
THE PARENT IN THAT CLASSROOM
WITH THE CHILD AS THEY DID THE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. SO THERE ARE
SO MANY OTHER OPTIONS TO PREPARE
THE CHILD WITHOUT HAVING TO HAVE
THIS INTEL, EACH PARENT, THIS IS
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT. SO
CHILDREN, YOU KNOW, THE
INNOCENCE, THE MAGIC OF WHAT IT
IS TO BE A CHILD FREE FROM ANY
EXPECTATION IS VERY, VERY SHORT,
INCREDIBLY SHORT BEFORE WE PUT
THEM INTO THE SYSTEM, I THINK WE
SHOULD ALLOW OUR PARENTS TO HAVE
THAT FREEDOM, SUPPORT FAMILIES,
SUPPORT A CULTURE IN WHICH WE'RE
REACHING OUT OUR PARENTS, AND
HOW DO THEY CAN DO THIS ON THEIR
OWN? ALLOW PARENTS TO HAVE THE
CHOICE OF CHOOSING HOW THEY
WOULD LIKE TO ORGANICALLY TEACH
THEIR CHILDREN AND CHILDREN ARE
SPONGES. THEY LEARN INCREDIBLY
FAST. THERE IS NOTHING THAT A
CHILD CANNOT LEARN IN THAT YEAR,
IN KINDERGARTEN OR IN IN FIRST
GRADE THAT THEY CANNOT, THAT
THEY THEY HAVE TO HAVE EXTENUATE
MORE TIME TO BE ABLE TO LEARN.
KIDS WILL LEARN IF YOU TEACH
THEM, THEY WILL LEARN QUICKLY.
UNLESS THERE'S SOMETHING
PHYSIOLOGICALLY,
PHYSIOLOGICALLY, DEVELOPMENTALLY
, AND HE GOES AND IF THAT IS THE
CASE, THEN WE DO WE DO
INTERVENE, ONCE WE LEARN OF THAT
CHILD. RIGHT. BUT LET'S ALLOW
THE KIDS TO HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
BE KIDS BEFORE WE HAVE
EXPECTATIONS AND ASSESSMENTS,
PLACED ON THEM. CHILDHOOD IS
VERY, VERY SHORT AND VERY, VERY
PRECIOUS. THANK MANY OF THE
COMMENTS. SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU
I'VE GOT A MOTION FOR SENATOR
CORTEZ. MAY I ADDRESS SOME OF
THE OTHER COMMENTS? YEAH. WELL,
LET ME LET ME ASK YOU A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS. I'M SURE. AND THEN
YOU CAN ADDRESS THIS. SO EVEN
WITH MANDATORY KINDERGARTEN, WE
WOULD STILL HAVE PROVISIONS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR HOME SCHOOLING,
CORRECT? YES. I WANT TO ADDRESS
THE OPTION PORTION PIECE, OF
COURSE. HAVE PARENTS VOICES WERE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US. SO WE
SPENT THREE YEARS SPEAKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND TRYING TO GET
INPUT. THERE'S A LOT OF PARENTS
THAT FELT VERY STRONGLY AS
SENATOR OR TROUBLE FEELS. AND SO
WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED OPTIONS FOR
PARENTS. YOU TALKED ABOUT
TEACHING YOUR CHILDREN AT HOME,
SOME OF THE OPTIONS THAT WE DO
HAVE IS HOME SCHOOLING. A PARENT
HAS THE OPTION TO KEEP THEIR
CHILD AT HOME, IN HOME SCHOOL,
AND THEN TEST THEIR CHILDREN AS
THEY'RE COMING INTO FIRST GRADE.
WE ALSO ALLOW THE OPTION FOR
PRIVATE SCHOOL CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND ALSO DELAYING ENROLLMENT
UNTIL SIX YEARS. IT'S NOT A
MANDATE TO PUT YOUR CHILD IN
SCHOOL BEFORE YOU'RE FIVE, AND
SO THESE ARE OPTIONS. THEY CAME
THROUGH DISCUSSIONS WITH PARENTS
THAT FELT REALLY STRONGLY ABOUT
OPTIONS FOR PARENTS, BUT I ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT, YOU
KNOW, AS YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
ALL THE ACTIVITIES THAT YOU DID
WITH YOUR CHILDREN, THIS BILL
REALLY TARGETS THOSE PARENTS
THAT DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
MEANS TO GO SEEK OUT
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM SETTING,
AND ALSO LACK OF TIME. A LOT OF
PARENTS ARE LOW INCOME. THEY
HAVE TO WORK TWO JOBS AND SO
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GO OUT AND NOT ONLY SEEK
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES, BUT
IT COSTS MONEY SOMETIMES. AND
THESE PARENTS DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY FOR IT, SO I GET
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING, BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO LOST AS I LOOK AROUND
THE ROOM. I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US ATTENDED SCHOOLS AS WE'VE
TRANSITIONED INTO COMMON CORE
STANDARDS, THAT THEY'VE BECOME
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AS YOU
KNOW, THEIR BUILDING BLOCKS AND
SO BEFORE, I THINK SOMEONE
MENTIONED IT WAS, YOU KNOW, A
LOT OF COLORING AND A LOT OF
THAT KIND OF LEARNING. NOW WE
HAVE VERY STRICT GUIDELINES AND
CURRICULUM THAT THAT WE HAVE TO
TEACH. AND WHAT YOU TEACH IN
KINDER BUILDS ON FIRST GRADE AND
SO ON. SO ONCE YOU COME INTO
FIRST GRADE, YOU ARE ALREADY
HAVE A BIG GAP. AND IT'S NOT AS
EASY AS ONE WOULD THINK. WE'RE
NOT DOING MATH. AND, DIVISION
AND ALL THE SKILLS THAT WE
LEARN, PARENTS CAN NO LONGER
TEACH AT HOME, WHICH IS ANOTHER
CHALLENGE, YOU KNOW, I USED TO
HAVE PARENTS CALLING ME AND
CRYING BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO TEACH THEIR CHILD. AND I
DON'T DISAGREE. THE WAY WE TEACH
CHILDREN HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY, YOU KNOW, IN TERMS
OF DIVISION, THE WAY WE DID IT,
THEY'RE DOING A VERY
DIFFERENTLY. SO THESE SKILLS ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO THEIR SUCCESS IN
FUTURE YEARS. SO AGAIN, IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO EXPECT A
PARENT TO TEACH AT HOME BECAUSE
WE'RE NO LONGER TEACHING THE WAY
WE USED TO TEACH. WE'VE GONE
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE STANDARDS
TO COMMON CORE STANDARDS. AND
AGAIN, IT'S ABOUT 5% OF KIDS
THAT STAY AT HOME. THESE ARE LOW
INCOME CHILDREN THAT PARENTS
USUALLY DON'T HAVE THE MEANS TO,
TO PROVIDE, YOU KNOW, EXTRA
SERVICES, TUTORING AND
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES. SO
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE CAPTURE
THAT SMALL PERCENTAGE. THANK
YOU. BRIEFLY, BRIEFLY GO AHEAD.
SEN AND I AND WITHOUT A QUESTION
YOU KNOW PEOPLE PEOPLE WILL BE
OF LOW SOCIOECONOMIC MEANS BY BY
FAR. YOU KNOW I WON'T ARGUE THAT
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T LOOKED INTO
THE DATA AS TO WHO DOESN'T
CHOOSE TO GO IN THERE. BUT ONCE
AGAIN, THOSE FAMILIES ARE
USUALLY THE ONES THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO SCHOOL. SO MAYBE THAT
THE CHALLENGE IS NOT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE TO MANDATE AND
FORCE THEM TO OR COMPEL THEM TO
PUT THEM IN KINDERGARTEN, BUT
ALLOW THEM TO KNOW THAT IT IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM, THAT
KINDERGARTEN IS AVAILABLE TO
THEM, AS LOW INCOME, PERHAPS
GIVING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO TO WORK, IF THEY WANT A PLACE
FOR THEIR KIDS TO BE PLACED. SO
IT'S MORE ABOUT REACHING OUT TO
THEM AND LETTING THEM KNOW THAT
THIS IS AVAILABLE TO THEM AND
THAT IT WILL BE A BENEFIT. AND I
CAN'T IMAGINE A, YOU KNOW, A
PERSON OR A FAMILY MEMBER THAT
KNOWS THAT THE RESOURCES ARE
THERE NOT TO WANT TO CHOOSE
THEM, ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE LOW
INCOME. PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR RESOURCES. AND ONCE
AGAIN, I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
FACT THAT THIS WOULD REQUIRE AN
ASSESSMENT OF A CHILD, TO ENTER
INTO FIRST GRADE IF WE DON'T
MANDATE IT. SO ONCE AGAIN, WE
ALREADY CURRENTLY HAVE, CONCERNS
WITH ASSESSMENTS AS EARLY AS
FIRST GRADE. AND SECOND GRADE,
WITH REGARDS TO FORMAL
ASSESSMENTS IN, IN IN ASSESSING
OUR CHILDREN. SO SO, THIS JUST
MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT EARLIER,
FOR, FOR OUR STUDENTS. SO. OKAY,
ANYWAY, I APPRECIATE IT. SO, SO
YOU TOUCHED ON ASSESSMENTS,
DOCTOR START, IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND SPEAKING TO THAT, SO TO
CLARIFY, SO ON THE ASSESSMENTS
THAT WE TALK ABOUT ARE ACTUALLY
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENTS OR THEY'RE
CLASSROOM BASED ASSESSMENTS,
IT'S REALLY TO INFORM THE
INSTRUCTION NEXT DECISIONS. HOW
DO STUDENTS LEARN BEST. SO
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE EARLY GRADES
YOU'RE REALLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE STUDENT'S
INTERESTS. YOU'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT SKILL SETS THEY
DO. HAVE YOU BROUGHT? I THINK
THE TEACHER BROUGHT UP USING
SCISSORS HOW TO HOLD THEM. YOU
KNOW, FINE MOTOR SKILLS, THINGS
LIKE THAT. SO WE DON'T GET INTO
ANY KIND OF FORMAL ASSESSMENT OR
THIRD GRADE. SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THAT IT'S THE ASSESSMENTS THAT
INFORM INSTRUCTION HELP THE
TEACHER KNOW WHAT DECISIONS I
NEED TO HOW TO GROUP KIDS. IT'S
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT IT'S MORE
INFORMATIVE RATHER THAN AN
ACTUAL FORMAL ASSESSMENT LIKE
THE STATE ASSESSMENT. YOU STILL
PERFORM THE STATE ASSESSMENTS IN
THIRD GRADE. IN THIRD GRADE, IN
THIRD GRADE. SO I THINK WE'VE
COVERED A LOT OF THIS. LET ME
SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS. SO IT'S
REALLY STRIKING. AND I THINK
SENATOR RUBIO WILL TESTIFY TO
THIS, THAT MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES, IN FACT, DID NOT
KNOW UNTIL SHE INTRODUCED THE
BILL THAT KINDERGARTEN WAS NOT
MANDATORY IN CALIFORNIA. MANY OF
THE A VAST NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
ARE NOT AWARE. AND TO MISS LAW'S
POINT, THERE'S KIND OF THE ADAGE
THAT FROM KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
SECOND GRADE, YOU'RE LEARNING TO
READ. AND THEN FROM THIRD GRADE
ON, YOU'RE READING TO LEARN. IF
YOU LOSE ONE OF THOSE YEARS,
THAT IS A MASSIVE DEFICIT FOR
THE STUDENT WHO FINDS HIMSELF
BEHIND, OFTEN HARD TO MAKE UP.
AND THERE'S SORT OF A
STRANGENESS TO MY MIND IN SORT
OF THE CURRENT MOMENT IN
CALIFORNIA, WHERE WE HAVE PROP
98 HAS, YOU KNOW, ESTABLISHED,
AS YOU KNOW, CERTAIN CORE
PARAMETERS AROUND EDUCATIONAL
SPENDING. WE HAVE INTRODUCED TK
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS,
RIGHT? FOUR YEAR OLDS AND THEN
WE'VE MADE REALLY IMPRESSIVE
INVESTMENTS. HOPEFULLY WE CAN
SUSTAIN THEM IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION TO HAVE A GAP IN
KINDERGARTEN IS REALLY BIZARRE
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, AND
IT'S ACTUALLY UNUSUAL ACROSS
MOST OTHER STATES. SO THERE IS A
COST TO THIS. AND I GENERALLY
ASK THE SAME QUESTION TO AUTHORS
LIKE DID A BILL LAST YEAR. IT'S
THE SAME BILL EFFECTIVELY THIS
YEAR. YOU KNOW WHY? WHY SHOULD
WE DO THIS AGAIN? WHAT ARE YOUR
YOU KNOW, WHAT ASSURANCES CAN
YOU GIVE US THAT THAT YOU CAN
FIND THE MONEY. THE GOVERNMENT
WILL SIGN IT. I THINK TO ME,
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT NEXT STEP IN
ENSURING ACCESS AND EQUITY IN
EDUCATION. THESE DEFICITS
COMPOUND THEMSELVES OVER TIME.
DOCTOR ESTRADA, YOU KNOW WELL,
SORT OF WHAT WHAT THOSE COSTS
ARE OVER THE COURSE OF A CHILD'S
EDUCATION. I AM GLAD TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A COAUTHOR, AND I'M HOPEFUL
THAT AS WE MOVE THIS FORWARD
THIS YEAR, WE GET THIS DONE,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION. AND
IT YOU KNOW, I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT I WE'RE LOSING
STUDENTS AT RECORD NUMBERS. YOU
KNOW, PARENTS ARE CHOOSING
PRIVATE SCHOOL AND OTHER MODES
OF EDUCATION. SO WE'RE LOSING
THE ADA AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A MANDATED
GRADE, WE'RE NOT ABLE TO HELP
STUDENTS BY WAY OF EXAMPLE, IF
THEY SHOW UP THE FIRST MONTH AND
THEY STOP SHOWING UP, WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REACH OUT
AND, AND, YOU KNOW, REACH OUT TO
THE PARENT AND SEE IF WE CAN GET
THEM BACK TO SCHOOL, WHERE IN
FIRST GRADE, IT'S A MANDATED
GRADE SO THAT THEY HAVE SEVERAL
ABSENCES IN A ROW. THEN WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BRING THEM IN AND
FIND OUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
HOME, WHICH IS NOT HEALTHY. IF
THEY DISAPPEAR FROM SCHOOL.
RIGHT. AND SO THAT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE HOME. ARE THEY
BEING MISTREATED? IS THERE
NEGLECT? AGAIN? TO ME, THERE'S
AN ASPECT THAT PERHAPS DOESN'T
HAVE A DOLLAR AMOUNT AND A
VALUE, BUT IT'S VALUABLE TO KNOW
IF WE CAN HELP A CHILD THAT'S
HAVING TROUBLE AT HOME. BUT IF
IT'S MANDATED, THEN WE HAVE ALL
THE RESOURCES AT OUR DISPOSAL
WHERE WE COULD OFFER PARENTS. WE
CANNOT DO THAT IN KINDER BECAUSE
IT'S NOT MANDATED. SO WITH THAT,
THANK YOU. AND I YOU KNOW, AND I
ALLOW YOU AS A COAUTHOR AND I
HOPE THAT I APPRECIATE THAT. AND
WE ARE WE ARE DONE WITH
QUESTIONS. SO WE WILL PUT THAT
TO VOTE. THANK YOU. THE
WITNESSES MADAM, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WELL, WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTION. I'M SORRY. WILK WILL
MOVE IT. OKAY. SENATOR WILK HAS
MOVED THE BILL, AND PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CALL. ITEM TWO, SB
1056. RUBIO. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED A SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN, A NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. NO. OKOBOJI. NO.
CORTESE GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. HI. WILK
I CURRENT VOTE COUNT IS 2 TO 1.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN, NEXT UP.
WE ARE LOOKING. SENATOR DODD.
IT'S HAPPENING. YOU ALMOST
WEREN'T READY FOR IT WHEN IT
FINALLY CAME AROUND. GOOD.
WELCOME. SHE HAD. SHE HAD
ANOTHER ONE ON CONSENT, SO,
SENATOR DODD, YOU ARE PRESENTING
SB 1166, PLEASE PROCEED. NO, NO.
SO JUST AS A POINT. POINT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. SB 1166
BUILDS UPON THE LEGISLATION.
THIS COMMITTEE APPROVED LAST
YEAR TO PUT IN PLACE IMPORTANT
DATA COLLECTION RELATIVE TO
DISCRIMINATION AND TITLE NINE
VIOLATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. CSU.
WHILE DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT ARE UNFORTUNATELY
NOTHING NEW TO COLLEGE CAMPUSES
IN INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM,
INDEPENDENT REPORTS AND A RECENT
STATE AUDIT REVEALED SYSTEMIC
MISHANDLING OF THESE CASES
ACROSS THE CSU SYSTEM. THE
CURRENT GAP AND DATA ON HOW
COLLEGES HANDLE DISCRIMINATION
AND TITLE NINE CASES MEANS LESS
TRANSPARENCY, ACCOUNTABILITY OR
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
DEFICIENCIES IN HOW THESE
COLLEGES CARRY OUT THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES. SB 1166
ADVANCES OUR ADVANCES. AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE 12 BILL
LEGISLATE PACKAGE IMPLEMENTING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR REFORM
CONTAINED IN THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE'S A CALL TO
ACTION REPORT. THE BILL EXPANDS
ON THE SCOPE OF THE CURRENT DATA
COLLECTED BY CSU'S TO ALSO
INCLUDE DATA THAT WILL EVALUATE
HOW SEX DISCRIMINATION IS
ADDRESSED ON EACH CAMPUS.
IMPORTANTLY, THE BILL ALSO
EXTENDS THESE REQUIREMENTS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND REQUESTS
THAT UC SUBMIT THE SAME REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE. STUDENTS,
FACULTY, AND STAFF ON THESE
CAMPUSES ARE NO LESS DESERVING
OF PROTECTION AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION. I HAVE TERRY
WILSON ON BEHALF OF THE CSU
EMPLOYEES UNION, CSU, AND
ESPERANZA BAUR, A STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE REPRESENTING
CHEN, UP WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU SIR, WHICH OF THE WITNESSES
WILL PROCEED, MISS BREWER?
WELCOME CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS ESPERANZA BREWER. I'M
A CURRENT STUDENT AT AMERICAN
RIVER COLLEGE, AND I SERVE AS
DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZING FOR
GENERATION UP. GEN-UP IS AN
ENTIRELY STUDENT LED ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSING ON
ADVANCING EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
I AM HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
REPRESENT CHEN UP AND TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF SB 1166 AS A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF SB 1166, CHEN UP
SEEKS YOUR SUPPORT IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES,
AS DEMONSTRATED BY THE CALL TO
ACTION AUDIT REPORT OF THE CSU.
THE EXISTING TITLE NINE SYSTEMS
AT CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS ARE UNTENABLE.
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES
HAVE FAILED TO PROTECT THEIR
STUDENTS, AND THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE PROFOUND. 1 IN 4 WOMEN WILL
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT DURING
THEIR UNDERGRADUATE EXPERIENCE,
DESPITE THIS ASTRONOMICAL
NUMBER, ONLY A SMALL FRACTION OF
SURVIVORS FILE A REPORT FACED
WITH ARDUOUS AND OFTEN DELAYED
TITLE NINE PROCESSES, MANY
STUDENTS CHOSE TO STAY SILENT
AND CONTINUE TO. THE REALITY IS
THAT WHEN STUDENTS DON'T FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN REACH OUT, THEY
DON'T GET THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED. NOT ONLY IS JUSTICE DENIED
, BUT THE SURVIVORS ARE ALSO AT
GREAT RISK FOR LONG TIME MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES, INCLUDING
DEPRESSION, ANXIETY, EATING
DISORDERS AND SUICIDE. HIGH
INSTANCES OF CAMPUS SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT AND LOW
REPORTING PROVE THAT COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ARE UNABLE TO KEEP
THEIR STUDENTS SAFE AND WE HAVE
HAD ENOUGH. IT IS CLEAR THAT WE
NEED LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS, AND
SB 1166 IS THE VITAL FIRST
TOWARDS CHANGE. BY EXTENDING THE
CSU REPORTING REQUIREMENT TO THE
UC AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEMS. THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT LEGISLATORS AND ADVOCATES
ALIKE HAVE THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO MAKE INFORMED POLICY
DECISIONS THAT WILL PROTECT
STUDENTS. WE CANNOT MOVE FORWARD
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST SEXUAL
VIOLENCE ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
WITHOUT FIRST LIFTING THE VEIL.
ON THE TITLE NINE PROCESS, SB
1166 WILL EMPOWER LAWMAKERS SUCH
AS YOURSELVES TO HOLD
INSTITUTIONS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PUTTING THEIR STUDENTS AT RISK
ON BEHALF OF THE 4000 ASSOCIATED
MEMBERS OF CHEN, UP, I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO STAND WITH
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND VOTE YES
ON SB 1166 TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. WILSON.
WELCOME. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB 1166
TODAY. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR
AUTHORIZING THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
MY NAME IS TERRY WILSON. I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR FINANCE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNION
EMPLOYEES UNION, WHICH
REPRESENTS 36,000 NON-FACULTY
STAFF AND STUDENTS AT THE CSU.
IN ADDITION TO MY ROLE WITH CSU,
I'VE WORKED AT FRESNO STATE
SINCE 2007 AND HAVE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THE TITLE NINE
SYSTEM. THERE I WAS A STUDENT
AFFAIRS ANALYST AT FRESNO STATE
AND HAD A SUPERVISOR WHO BEGAN
HARASSING ME. IN MY VERY FIRST
WEEK ON THE JOB. HE MADE
INAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS TOWARDS
ME, BULLIED ME, THREATENED ME
BOTH PHYSICALLY AND VERBALLY
DESPITE MY CONTINUOUS REPORTS OF
HIS BEHAVIOR, HE WAS NEVER
FORMALLY INVESTIGATED. I
EVENTUALLY HAD TO ACCEPT ACCEPT
A DEMOTION TO ESCAPE HIS ABUSE.
THE CSU'S FAILURE TO ADDRESS MY
SUPERVISOR'S BEHAVIOR DERAILED
MY CAREER AT FRESNO STATE, AND I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED IF STRONG
POLICIES HAD BEEN IN PLACE BACK
THEN. LAST YEAR, CSU WAS THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF SB 808, WITH
SENATOR DODD, WHICH ESTABLISHED
DESPERATELY NEEDED TITLE NINE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN THE
CSU. WHILE RECENT MEDIA HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE FAILINGS OF
TITLE NINE SYSTEMS, SPECIFICALLY
AT THE CSU, SB 1166 NOW PROVIDES
US WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE ROBUST TITLE NINE
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATIONAL SEGMENTS. THE
EXPANSION OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THROUGH SB 1166
SERVES TO CREATE MUCH NEEDED
ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR TITLE NINE
SYSTEMS, AND WILL ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS, FACULTY AND STAFF
ACROSS ALL OUR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ARE SAFER
AND BETTER SUPPORTED WHEN IT
COMES TO HANDLING CASES OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT. EVERYONE WHO
STEPS FOOT ONTO A CAMPUS
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO LIVE, WORK
AND LEARN IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT,
AND WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS ACHIEVING
THAT. FOR THIS REASON, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
, AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. OTHERS IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. HANNAH
DEVINE WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION, WHICH
REPRESENTS THE NEARLY HALF A
MILLION STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
CSU SYSTEM, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE? I'M A
STUDENT ACTIVIST WITH THE RUTH
PROJECT AND WORKING ON SB 1378.
I STRONGLY AGREE THAT WE SHOULD
MAKE TITLE NINE SAFER. YOUR NAME
PLEASE. PENELOPE OLIVER. THANK
YOU, MISS OLIVER, ANYBODY ELSE
HAVE THERE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? IS THERE ANYBODY ON
THE COMMITTEE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE. LET'S COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL. I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. I'VE GOT A MOTION
FROM SENATOR JOE BORG. SENATOR
DODD, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE,
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SIX, SB
1166. DODD MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO SENATE. APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A, NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI. CORTEZ.
GLASER GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK I WILK I THAT BILL
CURRENTLY HAS THREE VOTES AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN. AND NOW
SENATOR WILK AND I BOTH HAVE TO
GO VOTE IN BUDGET. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU KNOW THAT. NO, THEY
DIDN'T. DID THEY KNOW YOU KNOW
THAT. YEAH. THEY'RE DONE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS BRIEFLY
AND I WILL RUN DOWN TO 2100 AND
RUN BACK UP 1200. SORRY. AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK IN 2100.
THANKS THANKS FOR THANK YOU
PATIENTS, AS FOLKS MAY BE AWARE,
WE HAD A BUDGET HEARING GOING ON
IN THEIR CONCURRENT HEARINGS.
AND WE HAVE THE SORT OF
STRANGEST OF TWO MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE CHAIR OTHER COMMITTEES
SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE, WHICH I THINK MOST OF
US WOULD AGREE MAKES NO SENSE,
BUT I'M NOT IN CHARGE OF
ANYTHING BUT THIS COMMITTEE. SO
SO WHEN SENATOR WILK COMES BACK,
HE'LL BE BACK SHORTLY. WE WILL
TAKE UP HIS MEASURES. I DON'T
SEE ANOTHER AUTHOR HERE. OKAY
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. YEAH.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SNACKS OF ANY
SNACKS? WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
MY MOM WOULD ASK ME, THERE'S
SNACKS IN THAT GREEN ROOM NEXT
DOOR. YEAH. OR THEY'RE, YOU
KNOW, THEY. SNACKS ALWAYS MAKE
THE TIME GO FASTER. I WOULD
SLEEP, I ALWAYS THINK A LONG CAR
RIDES HOME. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
WILK IS BACK. AND SO NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT YOUR
BILLS.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR WILK, YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING SB 1194.
UNLESS YOU WANT TO SWITCH THE
ORDER 1194. IT IS. HOPEFULLY MY,
WITNESS FOR MY OTHER BILL IS OUT
IN THE LOBBY, SO. FAIR ENOUGH.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. ALL
RIGHT, WELL, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBER, SB WRONG ONE
1194. OKAY, TAKE TWO. ALL RIGHT.
SB 1194 IS A SIMPLE MEASURE THAT
REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO PUBLISH
INFORMATION ON THEIR WEBSITE
ABOUT THE MEMBERS WHO WERE
SELECTED FOR THE PARENT ADVISORY
COUNCIL. THIS ADVISORY ADVISORY
COUNCIL WAS FORMED AT THE
DIRECTION OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF INSTRUCTION,
WHO INVITED ALL PARENTS TO APPLY
IN ORDER TO QUOTE, WORK DIRECTLY
WITH HIS OFFICE TO PROVIDE INPUT
AND FEEDBACK ON MATTERS
AFFECTING YOUTH THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. END QUOTE. IN JANUARY
2023, APPLICANTS BEGAN TO
RECEIVE REJECTION LETTERS, BUT
WERE NOT ABLE TO FIND
INFORMATION ON THOSE THAT WERE
SELECTED. STAFF. I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT. I HAVE TO GO PRESENT
ANOTHER BILL. SO THIS IS. YOU'RE
IN GOOD HANDS. I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE YOUR BILL. MY
APOLOGIES. RIGHT. SO WHEN I HAND
THE GAVEL, IT'S ONE OF THESE
DAYS, YOU CAN BRIEF ME LATER.
I'M KIND OF GOING TO BE LATER IN
PERSON. WHY DON'T WE DO DINNER
TONIGHT? LET'S DO THAT. OKAY
GOOD. HOW ABOUT MULVANEY'S?
OKAY. SOUNDS GOOD. ALL RIGHT.
PERFECT STAFF REACHED OUT TO SEE
Â TO REQUEST A TIMELINE FOR THE
PUBLICATION OF THE MEMBERS NAMES
, AND THEY SAID THEY WOULD
EXPECT TO RELEASE THIS
INFORMATION BY THE END OF 2023.
HOWEVER, THAT INFORMATION IS YET
TO BE PUBLISHED, AND INQUIRING
PARENTS STILL DON'T KNOW WHO WAS
CHOSEN, AND NO UPDATED TIMELINE
HAS BEEN POSTED. THIS BILL
SIMPLY REQUIRES THE CDE TO ABIDE
BY SPECIFIC TIMELINE, TO GIVE
THOSE PARENTS CERTAINTY THAT
THEY WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
FIND OUT WHO THEIR VOICE ON THE
K-12 EDUCATION POLICY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE IS. WILL
ADVISORY COUNCILS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE MEMBERS
NAMES. ALMOST ALL OF THEM DO. IN
ADDITION TO THE MEMBERS
OCCUPATION OR TITLE, WE ALSO FOR
THIS PURPOSE ADDED COUNTY SO WE
COULD SEE WHAT THE GEOGRAPHIC
COMPOSITION OF THE COMMITTEE IS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT
THE INFORMATION BE PUBLISHED AS
WELL AS THE MEMBERS NAMES,
COUNTY RESIDENTS DATA, DATA. WE
KNOW OF NO OPPOSITION TO BILL,
AND I DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
WITH ME TODAY BECAUSE IT'S A
PRETTY SIMPLE BILL. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW
WE'LL GO TO ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM 2100, IN SUPPORT OF SB
1194. AS CHRISTIANSEN, VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY CENTER, HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. WE BELIEVE IN
TRANSPARENCY, ESPECIALLY WHEN
DIFFERENT ADVISORY COUNCILS ARE
MADE AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
FOR COMING. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? SEEING NONE, WE'LL
NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1194. SEEING
NONE, WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE, THE DAIS. AND WOULD
YOU LIKE I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, SENATOR WILK. AND THEN
WE'LL PUT IT ON HOLD, UNTIL OUR,
MEMBERS COME BACK. SENATOR OH,
COME ON UP. SO HE HAS A SECOND
ONE. YES. OKAY, SO, SENATOR
WILK. NO, YOU CAN COME ALL THE
WAY UP. YOU'LL BE PRESENTING SB
1233. YES YOU READY? WHEN YOU'RE
READY. OKAY, HERE WE GO. SB 1233
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
OVERCROWDING IN CALIFORNIA'S
ANIMAL SHELTERS AND STOP
UNNECESSARY PET EUTHANIZATIONS.
SB 1233 ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK
FOR UC DAVIS IN WESTERN
UNIVERSITY TO OFFER NEW
CURRICULUM FOR VETERINARIAN
STUDENTS ON THE, QUOTE, HIGH
QUALITY, HIGH VOLUME SPRAY
NEUTER END QUOTE TECHNIQUE. THIS
TECHNIQUE ALLOWS VETERINARIANS
TO SPAY NEUTER MORE ANIMALS IN A
SHORTER SPAN OF TIME. WHILE SOME
VETS LEARN THIS TECHNIQUE LATER
IN THEIR CAREERS, THERE'S
CURRENTLY NO OFFICIAL COURSE
OFFERED BY VETERINARIAN SCHOOLS
TO TEACH THIS MORE EFFICIENT
METHOD. AS PART OF THE PROGRAM
COURSE APPLICANTS WILL PRACTICE
THE TECHNIQUE WHILE PERFORMING
OPERATIONS IN SHELTERS.
ADDITIONALLY, AS MORE VETS
BECOME CORPS CERTIFIED AND THE
NUMBER OF VETS WORKING IN
SHELTERS WHO ARE QUALIFIED TO
PERFORM THE PROCEDURE WILL
SUBSEQUENTLY INCREASE. SO THE
BENEFITS OF SB 1233 WILL EXTEND
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE. BY
EMPLOYING THESE MORE EFFICIENT
METHODS IN A GREATER NUMBER OF
SHELTERS, PET OWNERS ACCESS TO
LOW AND NO COST SPAY AND NEUTER
WILL EXPAND DRAMATICALLY. WE
KNOW OF NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL, AND WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH THE DEANS OF THE
TWO SCHOOLS FOR MONTHS TO
DEVELOP THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS DOCTOR GRANT MILLER,
THE REGULATORY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION, WHO IS THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WILK, AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR LONG STANDING EFFORTS
TO HELP ADDRESS PET PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA, ESPECIALLY PET
OVERPOPULATION, WHICH IS AN
ISSUE THAT ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE WORKING ON. AND
THANK YOU TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING THIS
BILL TODAY. WE'RE VERY PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
VIEW IT TO BE BOTH A SHORT TERME
AND LONG TERME. SOLUTION TO
CALIFORNIA'S PET OVERPOPULATION
PROBLEM. AS SENATOR WILK
MENTIONED, WE REACHED OUT TO THE
VETERINARY SCHOOLS VERY EARLY ON
AND SAID, YOU KNOW, WHAT CAN WE
DO TO TRY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE?
AND THEY WERE VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THE IDEA OF EXPANDING
THEIR HIGH QUALITY, HIGH VOLUME
SPAY NEUTER PROGRAMS AT BOTH OF
THEIR SCHOOLS. SO WESTERN
UNIVERSITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO OPEN A
SHELTER CALLED THE NORTH, THE
NORTH CENTRAL ANIMAL SHELTER IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES, WHICH IS A
VETERINARY DESERT WHERE THEY
REALLY NEED THIS KIND OF HELP,
THESE AND THEN UC DAVIS WANTS TO
EXPAND THEIR PROGRAM HERE WITH
THE YOLO COUNTY ANIMAL SHELTER,
AND THEY WANT TO OFFER THESE
HIGH QUALITY, HIGH VOLUME SPAY
NEUTER PROCEDURES TO THE PUBLIC,
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED, WHO
MIGHT NOT OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THESE SERVICES. AND SO WE
REALLY VIEW THIS AS A WIN WIN,
WE'RE HOPING THAT THE SHORT
TERME SOLUTION WILL CREATE THESE
TWO EPICENTERS IN BOTH PARTS OF
THE STATE TO EXPAND WHAT THE
SCHOOLS ARE DOING. THE LONG
TERME WILL BE THAT WE'RE
RETRAINING OUR VETERINARY
POPULATION SO THAT WE ARE ALL
SKILLED IN BEING ABLE TO PERFORM
THESE PROCEDURES. SO FOR
INSTANCE, THE STUDENTS THAT GET
OUT WILL KNOW HOW TO DO THESE
THINGS. THEY'LL HAVE MAYBE 50 OR
75 OF THESE DONE ALREADY BY THE
TIME THEY'RE OUT OF SCHOOL. AND
THEN FOR AN OLDER GUY LIKE ME
WHO'S BEEN OUT 20 YEARS AND WANT
TO REPURPOSE MYSELF, MAYBE I CAN
GO BACK TO THE PROGRAM, LEARN
HOW TO DO IT, GET CERTIFIED, AND
MAYBE TAKE A SHIFT AT A SHELTER
ON A WEEKEND TO BE ABLE TO HELP
JOIN IN THE FIGHT. SO WE REALLY
VIEW IT AS A WIN WIN. WE HOPE
THAT YOU ALSO WILL SEE IT AS ONE
OF THE POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS TO
COMBATING CALIFORNIA'S EPIC PET
OVERPOPULATION ISSUE, AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
MILLER, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB 1233?
DYLAN FINLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASPCA IN SUPPORT. BARBARA
SCHMITZ, ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA, SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS SACKETT ON BEHALF OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION
IN SUPPORT. THANKS, NICK. DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE. WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1233. SEEING NONE, I'LL JUST
HAVE TO SAY WE'LL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE DAIS. I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD,
SENATOR WILK, I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, AND I'M
NOT SURE IF I'M A COAUTHOR OR
NOT ON THIS. YOU SHOULD BE ADDED
TO SO HOW THIS ALL CAME ABOUT.
AND THIS REALLY ACTUALLY HELPS
YOU, THE TOWN OF APPLE VALLEY,
NOT ONLY THE TOWN OF APPLE
VALLEY THAT HAS A SHELTER, BUT
MY ANIMAL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS THAT
LIVE THERE ARE BOTH VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE, BECAUSE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT IN PLACE
TO HANDLE THIS. SO ACTUALLY,
THIS IS GREAT PUBLIC POLICY, BUT
IT'S ALSO TO HELP YOU BECAUSE
YOU INHERIT APPLE VALLEY ON
DECEMBER 5TH OR WHATEVER IT IS.
SO YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK, A LITTLE PLUG
THERE. I'M VERY GRATEFUL BECAUSE
I AM VERY KEENLY AWARE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WITH
OVERPOPULATION IN OUR STATE AND
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH SHELTERS WITHIN OUR
STATE. AND IT'S LITERALLY
HEARTBREAKING. I'M JUST
SURPRISED WE HAVEN'T DONE THIS
ALREADY. YOU KNOW, THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION, A GREAT COMMENT.
THE VETERINARY SCHOOLS DO TEACH
THIS. THE TROUBLE WITH THE
SCHOOLS IS THAT, ONLY 60% OF
THEIR STUDENTS MAKE IT INTO THE
ELECTIVE ROTATION WHERE THEY'RE
ABLE TO DO THIS, BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THE SCHOOLS ARE ARE WORKING
IN CONJUNCTION WITH SATELLITE
SHELTERS THAT TAKE STUDENTS
BASED ON THEIR ON THEIR
CAPACITY. THE SCHOOLS WOULD LIKE
TO EXPAND THOSE PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL THE STUDENTS
WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO PERFORM
THESE PROCEDURES AS A CORE PART
OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN THEIR
CURRICULUM. AND JUST FOR THE
RECORD, FOR CLARITY, I KNOW WHEN
I WAS READING THIS, ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD, BECAUSE I
DID NOT SEE IT AND MAYBE I
MISSED IT, BUT, AT WHAT YEAR?
FIRST OF ALL, HOW LONG IS
VETERINARY SCHOOL? JUST FOR THE
RECORD, FOR THE PUBLIC TO BE
AWARE. AND AT WHAT YEAR DO YOU
BEGIN PRACTICING THESE
PROCEDURES. SO VETERINARY
SCHOOL, THE STANDARD EDUCATION
IS FOUR YEARS. ABOUT 90% OF THE
VETERINARY STUDENTS WILL THEN DO
AN INTERNSHIP IN YEAR NUMBER
FIVE. YOU DON'T HAVE TO, BUT
MOST OF US DO, YOUR SURGICAL
SKILLS ARE TAUGHT IN YOUR THIRD
YEAR. AND YOU BEGIN DOING
SURGERY IN THE SCHOOL IN YEAR
NUMBER THREE, AND THEN YOU WOULD
START DOING SURGERIES ON THE
PUBLIC'S ANIMALS IN YEAR NUMBER
FOUR. OKAY, I WAS JUST ASKING
BECAUSE JOKINGLY OR NOT, WE'RE
JUST, YOU KNOW, COMMENTING IN
OUR IN OUR, WITHIN MY TEAM AS
TO, YOU KNOW, THESE ANIMALS
CAN'T COMPLAIN AS TO, OH, YOU
BOTCHED ME UP. YOU DIDN'T DO IT
RIGHT. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE SKILLED ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO DO THESE PRACTICES, BUT
IN GREAT SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GREAT IDEA AND GLAD TO COAUTHOR
IT. AND WE'LL PUT IT ON HOLD
WHILE UNTIL WE HAVE OUR FULL
MEMBERS HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
TODAY. THANK YOU. SULEIMAN NØ
ALVARADO. OH, WE HAVE SENATOR
ALVARADO GIL READY TO PRESENT.
WELCOME. AND YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING BILL SB 1222. YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR.
I'M HERE TODAY, READY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1222, WHICH WOULD
DECLARE AS LEGISLATIVE POLICY
THAT ALL STATE TERRITORY BE
INCLUDED IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
DISTRICT OR OTHERWISE GIVEN
EQUIVALENT POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY. I LIVE
IN AMADOR COUNTY REPRESENTING
SENATE DISTRICT FOUR AND 13
OTHER COUNTIES, AND THREE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT ARE
NOT INCLUDED AS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF OUR MOST RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE THE RECEIVING
THE IMPACT OF THAT DISPARITY AND
THE LEAST THAT WE CAN DO IS
ENSURE EQUITY AND INCLUSION IN
EVERY COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
CONDUCT A STUDY EVALUATING THE
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALPINE,
AMADOR, MARIPOSA, MODOC, AND
SIERRA COUNTIES. RESIDENTS
WITHIN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS BENEFIT FROM AN
INCREASED ATTAINMENT EFFORTS.
PARTNERSHIPS AND OUTREACH. THESE
DISTRICTS PROVIDE. HOWEVER, THE
FIVE COUNTIES MENTIONED ARE NOT
INCLUDED WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT, LEAVING THESE
RESIDENTS WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE
SAME AFFORDABLE POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
CURRENTLY AT HOME. I HAVE TWO
YOUNG ADULTS, OF THE COLLEGE
AGE, AND THEIR ONLY OPTION IS TO
DRIVE AN HOUR AND A HALF TO THE
NEXT COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
OUTSIDE OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUTSIDE OF OUR COUNTY.
ADDITIONALLY, RURAL RESIDENTS
FACE SIGNIFICANTLY UNIQUE
CHALLENGES DUE TO THEIR REMOTE
GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATIONS AND LOW
POPULATION DENSITY, WHICH
HINDERS THEIR ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION, WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT, AND VOCATIONAL
TRAINING. ALTHOUGH EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT HAS RISEN IN RURAL
AREAS OVER THE YEARS, THE RURAL
POPULATION STILL HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER EDUCATION
ATTAINMENT LEVELS THAN OUR URBAN
POPULATIONS. 40% OF PEOPLE
RESIDING IN URBAN AREAS HAVE AT
LEAST A BACHELOR'S DEGREE, WHILE
ONLY 25% OF RURAL POPULATION HAS
THAT EQUIVALENT. IN A TIME WHERE
WE ARE LOOKING AT SHORTAGES IN
FIRST RESPONDERS, HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONS, TEACHING, WE CAN NO
LONGER ACCEPT THAT FIVE COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT INCLUDED
IN THIS EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
SENATE BILL 1222 WOULD ATTEMPT
TO BRIDGE THAT GAP BY GATHERING
AND ANALYZING THE DATA THAT
THESE EDUCATIONAL LIMITATIONS
AROUND THESE EDUCATIONAL
LIMITATIONS AND ALLOW US AS
POLICY MAKERS, TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THE EFFECTIVE POLICY
TO MAKE THIS CHANGE. NOW FILLING
THE GAP HAS BEEN NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SEE THAT NEED
FOR EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT AND
HAVE, ON THEIR OWN, BUILT UP
THEIR BOARDS, SOUGHT OUT
PHILANTHROPIC OPTIONS TO BE ABLE
TO FILL THIS GAP. NO LONGER CAN
WE RELY ON THESE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO THE JOB THAT
THE STATE SHOULD BE DOING FOR
ALL OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. SO HERE
TO TESTIFY TODAY IS MARIPOSA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR MILES MENETREY
AND KAREN DICKERSON WITH AMADOR
COLLEGE. CONNECT THANK YOU.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ONE MORE TIME. FOR THE
RECORD AND THEN PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. SO I'M ACTUALLY
SPEAKING FOR KAREN TODAY. I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
AMATEUR COLLEGE CONNECT. AND MY
NAME IS RACHELLE JOSE DE MATOS.
HYPHEN. SALDATE. LONG NAME,
THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR ALLOWING
US TO COME AND SPEAK TODAY. AND
THANK YOU, COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
FOR ALLOWING US AS WELL, WE WANT
TO SHARE OUR IMPORTANT WORK IN
AMADOR COUNTY AND HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AMATEUR
COLLEGE CONNECT IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES FREE,
1 TO 1 SUPPORT SERVICES TO HELP
STUDENTS CONNECT TO ONLINE
COLLEGE CLASSES AND REGIONAL
APPRENTICESHIP COURSES. SINCE
2013, WE HAVE HELPED SERVE OVER
750 STUDENTS. MANY OF WHOM FACE
CHALLENGES THAT A LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WOULD HELP
ELIMINATE. THE MISSION OF AMADOR
COLLEGE, CONNECT IS TO PROVIDE
ACCESSIBLE EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES IN A SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR CAREER SUCCESS
IN AMADOR COUNTY, SB 1222 AND
ITS POTENTIAL FUNDING WOULD
GREATLY EXPAND OUR ABILITIES TO
FULFILL THIS VISION IN AMADOR
COUNTY. WITH A LOW,
SOCIOECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
DEMOGRAPHIC APPROACHING 50, OUR
SERVICES PROVIDE AMADOR COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES THE CHANCE FOR A
HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE AND
BETTER PAYING CAREERS. WE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO OFFER HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THE SUPPORT NEEDED TO
EARN COLLEGE AND HIGH SCHOOL
CREDITS CONCURRENTLY, WITHIN THE
BROADER CONTEXT OF ADDRESSING
CAREER EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE AMADOR COLLEGE CONNECT IS A
RECENT RECIPIENT OF THE EASTERN
SIERRA K THROUGH 16 EDUCATION
COLLABORATIVE GRANT. THIS GRANT
WILL ALLOW US TO STREAMLINE
EQUITABLE PATHWAYS FROM HIGH
SCHOOL TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND INTO THE WORKFORCE
. S AMADOR COLLEGE CONNECT
ALIGNS WITH THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
FIRST INITIATIVE, WHICH IS AN
INTEGRAL COMPONENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S BROADER STRATEGY TO
PREPARE STUDENTS AND WORKERS FOR
HIGH PAYING CAREERS. AMADOR
COLLEGE CONNECT ALSO ALIGNS WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S MASTER PLAN
FOR CAREER EDUCATION, WHICH WILL
ADDRESS THE PAIN POINTS THAT
HAVE MADE IT CHALLENGING FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO LEARN AND GET
CREDIT FOR THE SKILLS THEY NEED
FOR REWARDING LIVING WAGE
CAREERS. THE PASSAGE OF SB 1222
IS CRITICAL FOR THE CONTINUED
EFFORTS OF BRINGING
POST-SECONDARY PROGRAMS AND
COURSES TO AMADOR COUNTY AND ITS
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. OUR
ORGANIZATION'S ULTIMATE GOAL IS
TO ESTABLISH A LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN AMADOR COUNTY. WE
BELIEVE THAT ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND VOCATIONAL
TRAINING WILL LEAD TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPROVE
LONGEVITY FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL, AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
MISSION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, VICE CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING, VICE CHAIR OKUBO AND
SENATOR WILK, MY NAME IS MILES
MENETREY. I'M MARIPOSA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR TESTIFYING THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M CURRENTLY THE
SECOND VICE CHAIR OF OUR CRC,
WHICH IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS 40 RURAL COUNTIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING
MARIPOSA. AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED, THERE ARE FIVE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE ALPINE,
AMADOR, MARIPOSA, MODOC, AND
SIERRA THAT ARE PARTIALLY OR
WHOLLY OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE
ENTRYWAY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN
OUR STATE AND OFFER VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION. DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIGH
SCHOOLERS, THE FOUNDATION FOR
TRANSFER TO UNIVERSITY, AND IN
SOME CASES, BACHELOR'S DEGREE
PROGRAMS. AS SB 1222 WILL
REQUIRE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO CONDUCT A
STUDY ANALYZING POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO RESIDENTS OF
THE FIVE UNDERSERVED COUNTIES.
THE GOAL IS TO IDENTIFY THE GAPS
IN HIGHER EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY
IN THESE COUNTIES AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS IN THOSE COUNTIES
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN BOTH IN-PERSON
AND POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES, WHETHER IT BE
YOUTH ENTERING INTO THE ADULT
WORLD, EMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS
LOOKING FOR A NEW CAREER OR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LOOKING FOR
ENRICHMENT COURSES. SB 1222
GIVES YOU GUYS THE POLICYMAKERS,
A MECHANISM TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE GAPS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES IN THESE COUNTIES
AND POSSIBLE PATHWAYS TO
ENSURING ALL RESIDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE EDUCATIONAL TOOLS
THAT CAN BRING ECONOMIC GROWTH
TO FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. FOR
THESE REASONS, OUR CRC REQUESTS
THAT SB 1222 REQUIRE YOUR
SUPPORT AND. ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PERFECT,
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB 1222
HERE IN ROOM 2100. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1222. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS. ARE YOU
LOOKING AT ME? YOU WERE LOOKING
LIKE YOU WERE REACHING TO YOUR.
I WAS REACHING, SO I REPRESENT
ON PAPER TWO URBAN DISTRICT,
URBAN COUNTIES. BUT IN REALITY,
A LOT OF MINE IS RURAL AND
CERTAINLY ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION IS DEFINITELY A
CHALLENGE. AND NØ AND SOME OF
THESE ZIP CODE SHOULD NOT BE
PRECLUDE THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS EDUCATION. AND I'M A
FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE. BEFORE I GOT ELECTED TO
THE STATE ASSEMBLY. AND I KNOW
MIRACLES HAPPEN ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES EVERY DAY. HOW
DID YOU KNOW THAT? AND SO I'M
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORTING THE BILL.
BUT DO YOU HOW DID THESE
COUNTIES NOT GET INCLUDED INTO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT?
RIGHT, RIGHT. WHY IS SOMEBODY
NOT DONE THIS SOONER? EXACTLY.
RIGHT. SO THERE'S A COUPLE
COUPLE DIFFERENT SENATOR BAUCUS.
HEY, I DIDN'T SAY THAT. I SAID
BECAUSE HE'S IN GREECE, SO HE
CAN'T HEAR ME. OKAY, WELL, ONE
THING THAT I WANT TO JUST POINT
OUT IS THAT, SINCE THE DEFUNDING
OF THE CALIFORNIA POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION COMMISSION IN 2011,
THE THERE'S NO CENTRALIZED
COORDINATING BODY FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THE ABSENT THAT
ABSENCE HAS HINDERED THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO EVEN ASSESS IF HIGHER
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES EVEN
EXIST OR THERE'S A LACK OF. SO,
AS YOU KNOW, OUR URBAN
COMMUNITIES, WE'VE HAD MOVEMENT
FROM URBAN COMMUNITIES INTO
RURAL AREAS. OUR POPULATIONS ARE
DIFFERENT. EVEN EVERY TEN YEARS.
WE DO DIFFERENT CENSUS TRACKS.
SO OUR ASSESSMENTS ON EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH THAT. SO WE ARE ASKING THAT
THE LAW OFFICE TAKE THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION WITH STUDIES THAT
THEY ARE ALREADY DOING, AND
EXPAND IT TO GIVE US THE
ASSESSMENTS. THE OTHER ISSUE
HERE IS THIS IS A LOCAL CONTROL
CONVERSATION. SO WE NEED TO
BRING IN OUR LOCAL, OUR LOCAL
ELECTEDS IN THESE INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THAT ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE
THEIR THEIR TAX PERCENTAGE THAT
THEY WOULD BE PUTTING IN TO
THIS, THIS AGREEMENT, WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THE WILL, WE HAVE
THE WAY, WE'VE GOT THE COMMUNITY
COMING FORWARD WITH DONATIONS,
EVEN AROUND FACILITIES. BUT WE
NEED THE STATE TO MAKE THAT
BRIDGE, MAKE THAT CONNECTION
HAPPEN. SO I'M HOPING THAT BY
THIS TIME NEXT YEAR, WE WILL BE
WELL ON THE WAY TO APPROPRIATING
FUNDS OUTSIDE OF THIS COMMITTEE,
BUT ENSURING THAT WE CAN ALL, GO
TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GRADUATION IN ONE OF THESE FIVE
COUNTIES. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALVARADO. SO SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS, SENATOR ALVARADO, I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL, I, AS
SENATOR WILK MENTIONED, I'M
SURPRISED THAT WE HAD NOT DONE
THIS ALREADY. SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. AND
THEN WE'LL PUT IT. OH DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. SO MOVED OKAY. ALL
RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM SEVEN
SB 1222. ALVARADO GIL. MOTION IS
Dð PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN, OCHOA. BORG. AYE.
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ. GLASER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK. Ã WILK. AYE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I'LL PUT THIS ON HOLD FOR
THE REST OF THE MEMBERS WHEN
THEY COME BACK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. OH, SENATOR
MINH, WELCOME. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER 12, SB
1378, WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER MEMBERS. I SUPPOSE I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO START BY NOTING
THAT WE'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
SB 70 1378 WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOLS
SERVING GRADES SEVEN THROUGH 12,
AS WELL AS HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE TO
PRINT THE TITLE NINE HOTLINE ON
STUDENT ID CARDS, FACING
DISCRIMINATION, HARASSMENT OR
ASSAULT ON CAMPUS CAN LEAD TO
ISOLATION AMONG STUDENTS WITH
NOWHERE TO TURN FOR HELP,
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE A
READILY AVAILABLE PHONE NUMBER
ON THEIR ID CARDS CAN EMPOWER
THEM TO GET THE HELP THEY NEED.
AND ADDITIONALLY, IN ORDER TO
GUARANTEE A MORE STREAMLINED
PROCESS, STUDENTS WOULD BE
DIRECTED TO THEIR CAMPUSES. MOST
DIRECT TITLE NINE CONTACT. THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO SCHOOLS
THAT RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING AND
WHICH ARE THEREFORE SUBJECT TO
COMPLIANCE WITH TITLE NINE AND
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS THE PERSON THAT
ACTUALLY CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA.
SHE'S A SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL.
PENELOPE OLIVER, ORGANIZER WITH
THE RUTH PROJECT, AND I BELIEVE
A FUTURE MATRICULANT TO ONE OF
OUR UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS. SO PENELOPE, IF YOU
MIGHT. MADAM CHAIR, IF SHE MIGHT
TESTIFY, THAT'D BE GREAT.
ABSOLUTELY. AND WELCOME.
PENELOPE. I BELIEVE YOU'VE
TESTIFIED HERE BEFORE, HAVE YOU?
I HAVE, YEAH. AND I MET WITH
YOUR OFFICE, I SERVE ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS YOUTH
ADVISORY COUNCIL. YES, YES, I
THINK WE HAD I REMEMBER YOU,
BEING HERE. SO WELCOME. GLAD TO
HAVE YOU. WHEN YOU'RE READY,
STATE YOUR NAME ONE MORE TIME
AND WHERE YOU'RE REPRESENTING.
AND THEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY
NAME IS PENELOPE OLIVER. I'M A
YOUTH ACTIVIST WITH THE RUTH
PROJECT. I APPROACHED SENATOR
MINH WITH THIS BILL IDEA. IT'S
INSPIRED AFTER MY OWN EXPERIENCE
BEING SEXUALLY HARASSED ON
CAMPUS AT AGE 15. IT WAS AT
SIERRA COLLEGE, WHERE I DO DUAL
ENROLLMENT THANKS TO GOING TO A
CHARTER SCHOOL, SO ESSENTIALLY
DURING THE INCIDENT, MY PEERS
AND I WHO WERE INVOLVED LOOKED
ON THE BACK OF OUR STUDENT ID
CARDS. WE USE OUR CARDS FOR
RESOURCES, FOR MEALS, FOR
DISCOUNT. EVEN SO, IT WAS ALMOST
LIKE A NATURAL INSTINCT. AND WE
DIDN'T FIND ANYTHING THERE TO
HELP US, THIS WENT ON FOR A FEW
WEEKS BEFORE THIS FINALLY WAS
HANDLED BY TITLE NINE. ONCE WE
KNEW WHAT TITLE NINE WAS. SO
ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL AIMS TO
JUST INFORM STUDENTS OF THEIR
RIGHTS, TO TITLE NINE TO A SAFE
AND SUPPORTIVE PLACE IN MY CASE,
IT WAS HANDLED IN THESE THREE
WEEKS. THIS STUDENT WAS TAKEN
OFF OF CAMPUS, AND ONCE IT CAME
THROUGH, HE HAD MULTIPLE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCIDENTS. SO
HAD WE KNOWN EARLIER WHAT WAS
AVAILABLE AND WHAT RESOURCES
WERE THERE FOR US. THIS WOULD
HAVE BEEN HANDLED. SO MY HOPE
FOR THIS BILL IS THAT ALL
STUDENTS KNOW THAT TITLE NINE
AND FACING DISCRIMINATION HELP.
THEY CAN GET HELP. AND HELP IS
THERE. RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, PENELOPE, FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1378, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS PAMELA GIBBS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING, VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ANNA MATTHEWS WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI,
I'M CHRISTINE MORELAND. I'M THE
MOTHER OF HER. AND I JUST WANT
I'M IN SUPPORT. BUT ALSO IT GAVE
US A SENSE OF SECURITY AND
CLOSURE FOR THAT. THANK YOU. AND
MOM MUST BE SO PROUD. I KNOW I
WOULD BE, WE HAVE ONE MORE HIÆN.
TONY OLIVER, THE FATHER OF
PENELOPE, ALSO IN SUPPORT, AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE. BUT NOT JUST
FOR HER, BUT ALSO FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE ACROSS OUR STATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
WE'LL NOW CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1378 HERE IN ROOM 2100, SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. ANY QUESTIONS? COMMENTS,
SENATOR? NO, I JUST HAVE ONE.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I'M
JUST GOING TO QUESTION. I KNOW
THAT THERE IS ANOTHER, BILL,
ANOTHER MEMBER WHO IS COMING
FORWARD WITH A, A, WITH, I
BELIEVE, A QR CODE TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION ACCESSIBLE, THE ONLY
CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT, AS WE'VE
BEEN SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE, WE'VE
BEEN ADDING QUITE A BIT OF
NUMBERS, INCLUDING PREVIOUS ONES
THAT YOU SUBMITTED IN THERE TO A
CERTAIN POINT, WE'RE GOING TO
RUN OUT OF SPACE IN THOSE CARDS
AND THOSE ID CARDS. SO HAS THERE
BEEN ANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
REGARDS TO INCLUDING IT ALL IN A
QR CODE? SO I HAVE NOT, I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANOTHER MEMBER,
BRINGING A BILL, BUT IT HAS BEEN
SUGGESTED TO US A QR CODE AND A
CONCERN AROUND TOO MUCH
INFORMATION HAS ALSO BEEN
RAISED, WE ARE OPEN TO
CONSIDERING A QR CODE. THE
CHALLENGE THERE IS THAT, AS YOU
POINT OUT, THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH
REAL ESTATE ON A STUDENT CARD IN
A NUMBER, YOU KNOW, FITS A LOT
EASIER THAN A QR CODE, WHICH IS
BOXY AND TAKES UP SPACE, SO
THAT'S ONE CONCERN THAT'S BEEN
RAISED. ANOTHER CONCERN THAT'S
BEEN RAISED WITH QR CODES IS
THAT THEY MIGHT NOT LOAD IN AN
EMERGENCY TYPE SITUATION. THÀNH
IF YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
SUFFICIENT, YOUR SIGNALS. NOT
GOOD, SO THE THOUGHT WAS THAT
THIS MIGHT BE A BETTER FIX, BUT
AGAIN, WE'RE OPEN. THE IDEA HERE
IS JUST TO HAVE AN AVAILABLE
RESOURCE TO BE ABLE TO CALL IF
YOU'RE EXPERIENCING,
UNFORTUNATELY, SITUATIONS THAT
DO ARISE ON EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. YEAH, IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT. AND THE QR CODE WAS
NEW TO ME. I HAD NOT EVEN
THOUGHT OF THAT, BUT IT WAS MORE
OF A, YOU KNOW, THE COLLEGE
PUTTING ALL OF THIS INFORMATION
WITHIN A YEAR OR SO THAT IT, YOU
KNOW, AT SOME POINT YOU'RE GOING
TO RUN OUT OF SPACE. SO A QR
CODE WOULD ALLOW ALL OF THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO BE
INCLUDED INTO A CARD. BUT BUT
THAT POSES OTHER CHALLENGES,
RIGHT? WHAT IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
PHONE? WHAT IF THEY DON'T HAVE,
YOU KNOW, A SMARTPHONE OR. YEAH,
A SMARTPHONE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. SO THERE'S CHALLENGES TO
THAT AS WELL, BUT JUST THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO KIND OF BE
COGNIZANT. I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION, MADAM CHAIR. AND
CERTAINLY WE'RE OPEN TO IDEAS
AND, YOU KNOW, WHATNOT. BUT I
THINK FOR WE THINK ONE
ADDITIONAL PHONE NUMBER RIGHT
NOW, I BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE, THE PHONE
NUMBERS FOR, SUICIDE. I KNOW
SUICIDE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION. SO THIS WOULD JUST
BE A THIRD NUMBER. AND AGAIN,
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE SEEN THOSE
STUDENT ID CARDS. THERE'S PLENTY
OF ROOM FOR THAT. AND SO WE
THINK THIS IS A WORTHWHILE FIX.
AND THEN IF DOWN THE LINE, YOU
KNOW, WE DECIDE THAT WE WANT TO
JUST ACCUMULATE THIS ALL INTO A
QR CODE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
MAYBE THAT MAKES SENSE.
ABSOLUTELY, I, I'M SEEING AN
ANXIOUS SENATOR WILK READY TO
MOVE THE, THE BILL. I THINK THE
PARENTS MAY ALSO BE EXCITED TO
SEE THE BILL POTENTIALLY GET
MOVED. I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
PERFECT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, SENATOR, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND MADAM
SECRETARY, IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM 12, SB
1378 MIN MOTION. OOPS. SORRY.
I'M NOT EVEN. INSTINCT DO PASS,
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. OCHOA, BOGH I TOBAGI
CORTEZ. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. HI.
WILK I THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
MADAM CHAIR, CAN WE DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHILE WE'RE
WAITING? OF COURSE. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. NEWMAN OCHOA,
BOGH I TOBAGI CORTEZ. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. HI. WILK I WE'LL PLACE
THAT ON HOLD, I ALSO BELIEVE.
DID WE TAKE A VOTE ON THE GROVE
BILL OR SO I LIKE TO MOVE. WHY?
I SAID AT THE TIME I WOULD MOVE
THAT BILL. SO I'M GOING TO MOVE
THAT BILL RIGHT NOW. OKAY. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHILE ITEM FOUR SB 1060 1063
GROVE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED. NEWMAN. OKOBOJI I
TOBAGI CORTEZ. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK I WILK I
. IS THERE ANY OTHER BILLS THAT
WE DID? YOU DO IT? ALVARADO.
GILLS NO, I'M JUST SAYING YOU
WERE HERE FOR THAT, I MOVED IT.
OH, YEAH.
NUMBER EIGHT. SENATOR PADILLA.
SURE. HAPPY TO MOVE. FILE ITEM
EIGHT, SB 1241. WHILE ITEM
EIGHT, SB 1241. PADILLA MOTION
IS Dð. PASSES AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI. CORTEZ
BLAZER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK I WILK I I'LL PUT
THAT ON HOLD FOR THE REST OF THE
MEMBERS TO VOTE UPON ARRIVAL. I
COULD READ I COULD READ, PRESENT
MY BILL SO I CAN WORK ON MY
PRESENTATION. WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND RECESS. THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE UNTIL, WE
FIND, MORE AUTHORS
WE'RE GOING TO RECONVENE, THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
WE HAVE A MEMBER WHO HAS
ARRIVED. SENATOR STERN, WE
WELCOME YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT SB 1283 OR SB 1421? DO
YOU HAVE A PREFERENCE? LET'S GO.
LET'S GO. BILL, ORDER 1283.
PERFECT. THAT'S ALL RIGHT. MY
FOLKS ARE. YEAH. EVERYBODY'S
HERE. THAT'S GREAT. OKAY. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS, APOLOGIES TO, I
SLOWED DOWN PROCESS HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE AT ALL. THIS BILL HAS
TO DO WITH SOCIAL MEDIA IN
SCHOOL AND THE PERVASIVE USE,
AMONGST YOUNG PEOPLE
NECESSITATES AN UPDATE TO STATE
POLICY, THAT DATES BACK TO 2019,
WHEN WE AUTHORIZED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE TO
LOOK AT THEIR SMARTPHONE
POLICIES, WE DIDN'T TELL THEM
EXACTLY WHAT TO DO, BUT WE SAID
YOU HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ADOPT
STANDARDIZED POLICIES AROUND
SMARTPHONE USE ON CAMPUS. NOW WE
KNOW IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT WHAT'S
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE PHONE
ITSELF, BUT IT'S ABOUT HOW YOU
USE THE PHONE AND WHAT YOU DO ON
THE PHONE. 13 TO 17 YEAR OLDS
REPORT, 95% USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. THAT'S RECENT DATA.
AND A THIRD SAY THEY ALMOST
CONSTANTLY USE SOCIAL MEDIA, SO
CONSTANT IS THE IS BECOMING THE
NORM. YOU ARE SNAPCHATTING AT
SCHOOL, YOU'RE POSTING ON
INSTAGRAM AT SCHOOL, YOU'RE ARE
LOOKING AT CONTENT. YOU ARE
PUTTING OUT CONTENT. AND MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT, A IT'S NOT FOR
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES. IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO DO WITH WHAT YOU'RE
LEARNING IN MATH OR HISTORY, BUT
B IT CAN BE A REAL VECTOR FOR
SUPERCHARGING THE KINDS OF
BULLYING AND HATE THAT WE'RE
SEEING RISING EVERYWHERE. IT'S
INFILTRATING OUR LIVES,
LITERALLY. AND OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING AS A RESULT. AND
IT'S NO WONDER THE US SURGEON
GENERAL, HAS MADE REPEATED
REPORTS ABOUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS WE'RE FACING. SO WE THINK
IT'S HIGH TIME THAT AT LEAST AS
A STATE, WE MAKE CLEAR TO LEAS
THAT THEY THEY CAN ADOPT A
SOCIAL MEDIA POLICY THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO UNDER THIS BILL.
IT'S NOT A MANDATE TO SAY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A SOCIAL MEDIA
POLICY, OR THAT YOU NEED TO BAN
SOCIAL MEDIA AT SCHOOL, OR YOU
NEED TO BAR STUDENTS FROM DOING
SO. AND IN FACT, I WANT TO MAKE
A BRIEF RESPONSE JUST TO SOME OF
THE I THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A
FEW, PRINCIPLED PIECES OF
OPPOSITION, NOT MUCH, BUT, A
CONCERN THAT SOMEHOW THIS WOULD
NECESSITATE US TO GO TO, SURVEIL
OR LOOK AT STUDENTS FEEDS OR GET
INTO THEIR PHONES THEMSELVES.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL, VIOLATES
THOSE PRIVACY RIGHTS. AND IN
FACT, IT BY ADDING SOCIAL MEDIA
USE TO THIS MURATSUCHI FRAMEWORK
FROM 2019, WE ADD THOSE
GUARDRAILS ON THOSE RIGHTS
AROUND THE ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT THAT
REQUIRES THAT NO GOVERNMENT
ENTITY, INCLUDING A SCHOOL
DISTRICT, CAN COMPEL THE
PRODUCTION OR ACCESS TO
ELECTRONIC DEVICE INFORMATION
WITHOUT A WARRANT, WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS PARAMOUNT TO
PROTECTING STUDENT PRIVACY. SO I
WANT TO BE CLEAR, THIS IS NOT
ABOUT SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR
TEACHERS OR PRINCIPALS
MONITORING OR OR TRYING TO GET
INTO THE FEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS, BUT IT'S SIMPLY SAYING
THAT BETWEEN STUDENTS, PARENTS,
TEACHERS, ADMINISTRATORS, SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS, WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME POLICY. WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME HANDLE ON THIS, OR AT LEAST
YOU NEED TO CONSIDER HAVING ONE,
WE THINK THAT PERMISSIVE
STRUCTURES IS GOOD, ESPECIALLY
IN A TIGHT BUDGET. NO MANDATE IN
HERE. SO I HOPE HOPEFULLY THAT,
HAS HAS ABATED ANY ANY CONCERNS
OUT THERE. BUT WE AT LEAST WANT
TO PUT THIS OPTION VERY CLEARLY
ON THE TABLE. AND I, FOR ONE,
HOPE THAT MY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GET ON TOP OF THIS,
IT'S SCARY OUT THERE. SO,
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT FROM A
DIVERSE COALITION. WE'VE GOT
PAMELA GIBBS HERE WITH L.A.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION, AND
I BELIEVE DYLAN HOFFMAN IS HERE
WITH TECHNET. SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD JUST TURN IT OVER. THANKS.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ONE MORE TIME.
AND WHO YOU'RE REPRESENTING. AND
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. GOOD MORNING. AND
TO SENATORS AS WELL. MY NAME IS
PAMELA GIBBS, AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. EXISTING LAW GRANTS
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES THE
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE THE
POSSESSION AND USE OF ELECTRONIC
SIGNALING DEVICES, INCLUDING
SMARTPHONES, BY STUDENTS. WHILE
ON CAMPUS OR PARTICIPATING IN
SCHOOL SPONSORED ACTIVITIES.
MANY LEAS, INCLUDING LACOE, HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED POLICIES TO
LIMIT THE USE OR PROHIBIT THE
USE OF SMARTPHONES DURING SCHOOL
HOURS OR WHILE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF SCHOOL STAFF.
LACOE PROVIDES EDUCATION TO
STUDENTS IN A VARIETY OF
EDUCATIONAL SETTINGS, AND WE
ALSO HAVE POLICIES RELATING TO
THE USE OF SMARTPHONES AND
MOBILE COMMUNICATION DEVICES,
WHICH WE FIND BENEFICIAL TO
STUDENT LEARNING AND WELL-BEING
AND ARE CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING
LAW. IN EDUCATION, CODE FOUR,
890, 1.5 AND 48901.7. IN
ADDITION, OAN AE PROVIDES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO MORE
THAN 80 LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
ON WAYS TO KEEP STUDENTS AND
SCHOOLS SAFE, INCLUDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS. SB 1283 EXTENDS THIS
AUTHORITY TO INCLUDE THE
REGULATION OF SOCIAL MEDIA USE
BY STUDENTS DURING SCHOOL HOURS
OR WHILE UNDER SCHOOL
SUPERVISION. THIS EXPANSION IS
CRUCIAL IN ADDRESSING THE
GROWING CONCERNS SURROUNDING THE
MISUSE OF SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS, PARTICULAR EARLY IN A
SCHOOL SETTING. AE RECOGNIZED
THE IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING A
SAFE AND INCLUSIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS BY
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITING THE USE
OF SOCIAL MEDIA WHILE ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS OR UNDER SCHOOL
SUPERVISION. SB 1283 WILL HELP
PREVENT DISTRACTIONS,
CYBERBULLYING, AND OTHER FORMS
OF INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR THAT
CAN NEGATIVELY IMPACT STUDENTS
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE AND
WELL-BEING. MOREOVER, SB 1283
WOULD PROHIBIT MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY FOR LEAS IN ADDRESSING
INSTANCES OF HARASSMENT, THREATS
, OR OTHER MISCONDUCT OCCURRING
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNELS,
DURING SCHOOL HOURS OR WHILE
STUDENTS ARE UNDER SCHOOL
SUPERVISION. THIS CLARITY WILL
ENABLE LEAS TO TAKE PROMPT AND
APPROPRIATE ACTION TO ADDRESS
INCIDENTS SUCH AS THESE, AND
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND SECURITY
OF ALL STUDENTS AND STAFF. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB 1283. THANK YOU, MISS
GIBBS. NØ. IS IT WORKING? NOT
WORKING. OKAY, MAYBE WE NEED TO
SHARE. MAYBE YOU CAN PASS HERS
OVER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, DYLAN
HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF TECHNET,
AND PROUD SUPPORT OF SB 1283,
TECHNET IS A TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATION, ECONOMY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
NATION. AND, WANT TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS VERY SHORT AND VERY
SIMPLE. I THINK STUDENTS HAVE A
LOT OF DISTRACTIONS WHEN THEY'RE
AT SCHOOL. WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
SOCIAL MEDIA SHOULD NOT BE ONE
OF THEM. SO IF SCHOOLS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS NEED ANOTHER TOOL
IN ORDER TO TRY TO FOCUS
STUDENTS WHILE THEY'RE WHILE
THEY'RE ON CAMPUS AND WHILE
THEY'RE TRYING TO LEARN, WE'RE
HAPPY TO HELP PROVIDE THAT, FOR
US, WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF SOCIAL MEDIA, I
THINK THERE COULD BE A CONCERN
ABOUT IT BEING OVERLY BROAD OR
INCLUSIVE. WE HAVE SOME
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO
NARROWLY TAILOR THAT TO AVOID
SOME OF THE PRINCIPLED
OPPOSITION, BUT I'M HAPPY TO BE
A PARTNER IN THIS CONVERSATION
AND WANT TO BE HELPFUL WHERE WE
CAN. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HOPE YOU CAN SUPPORT THIS. BILL.
THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND BEING WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1283. NOW, WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
2100. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, TRISTAN BROWN OF CFD
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL NOW CONTINUE
WITH ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO 1283. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME
IS RACHEL BHAGWAT. I'M A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE AT ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, BUT
WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT WE
ARE COME FROM A PLACE OF DEEPEST
RESPECT TO THE SENATOR. HIS
INTENTION IN THIS BILL AND THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AS
WELL. WE DO SHARE THE SENATOR'S
INTEREST IN PROMOTING HEALTHY
AND INCLUSIVE SCHOOL CLIMATES
AND PROTECTING STUDENTS FROM
POTENTIAL HARMS OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE ARE STILL IN A PLACE WHERE WE
FEEL LIKE THE APPROACH TO THIS
BILL, WHILE TRYING TO BE VERY
SIMPLE. IT'S A FIVE WORD BILL,
IS OVERLY BROAD AND MAY INVITE
UNINTENDED HARMS AND INVITE
FURTHER VIOLATIONS OF FIRST
AMENDMENT AND PRIVACY LAWS. I
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR BRINGING
UP SOME OF THESE CONCERNS IN HIS
INITIAL INTRODUCTION, AND WANTED
TO CLARIFY THAT, WHILE IN OUR
OPPOSITION LETTER AND I CAN TALK
MORE ABOUT THIS, WE DID RAISE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THIS MAY
INVITE VIOLATIONS OF CAL, ACPA,
THE ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS
AND PRIVACY ACT. WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT THIS BILL IN ITSELF
VIOLATES THE FIRST AMENDMENT OR
VIOLATES CAL ACPA. THE ISSUE
HERE IS THAT SMARTPHONES AND
SOCIAL MEDIA ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT. SMARTPHONES ARE
PHYSICAL OBJECTS, SO LIMITING
AND PROHIBITING THEIR USE IS AS
SIMPLE AND NONINVASIVE AS
REQUIRING STUDENTS TO PUT THEM
AWAY DURING CLASS OR WHILE UNDER
THE SUPERVISION OF A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE, WHICH I TAKE AS BEING
MAYBE ON A SCHOOL FIELD TRIP.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY FINE. BUT HOW
DO YOU WRITE A DISTRICT POLICY
THAT ALLOWS STUDENTS TO LIMIT OR
PROHIBIT A STUDENT'S USE, OR,
I'M SORRY, ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
LIMIT OR PROHIBIT A STUDENT'S
USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA? HOW DOES AN
EDUCATOR KNOW THAT A STUDENT IS
USING SOCIAL MEDIA OR WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING, I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE INTENTION OF THIS BILL
IS TO BE OVERBROAD OR TO
INTERPRET IT IN THE WAYS THAT
THE SENATOR MENTIONED IN THE
INTRODUCTION, BUT PRESUMABLY A
PERMISSIVE BILL LIKE THIS THAT
COULD ALLOW DISTRICT TO WRITE A
CERTAIN KIND OF POLICY, COULD
INVITE EDUCATORS TO DO THINGS
THAT ARE VIOLATIONS OF CAL ACPA,
FOR EXAMPLE, TAKING A STUDENT'S
PHONE AND LOOKING THROUGH IT
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT, WHICH
WHICH TO SEE WHAT APPS ARE BEING
USED OR WHAT IS BEING SAID. I
DON'T KNOW A LOT OF EDUCATORS
WHO HAVE A STRONG UNDERSTANDING
OF CALIFORNIA'S PRIVACY LAWS,
AND WE FEAR, I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOOD FOR EDUCATORS OR FOR
STUDENTS FOR THERE TO BE A MORE
PERMISSIVE STATUTE THAT COULD
ALLOW THEM TO ACCIDENTALLY
VIOLATE PRIVACY LAWS DURING THIS
TIME. IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW,
OTHER MONITORING CONCERNS, WE
KNOW THAT SOCIAL MEDIA CAN BE
USED NOT JUST ON SMARTPHONES,
BUT ON TABLETS AND ON COMPUTERS.
AND SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO BE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE, THERE IS A POSSIBILITY
THAT SOME DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS
COULD INTERPRET, THAT LANGUAGE
TO EXPAND THE USE OF MONITORING
SOFTWARE ON SCHOOL ISSUED
DEVICES IN A WAY THAT COULD PICK
UP A LOT OF STUDENT SPEECH,
INCLUDING SPEECH THAT THEY
REASONABLY COULD CONSIDER TO BE
PRIVATE AND SO THERE'S A
CONCERN. I MEAN, THERE'S A
DISPARATE IMPACT CONCERN BECAUSE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
LIKELY TO BE USING SCHOOL ISSUED
DEVICES, REYES AT HOME FOR
PERSONAL ACTIVITIES ARE GOING TO
BE YOUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS,
YOUR BLACK AND BROWN STUDENTS
WHO MAYBE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
DEVICE IN THE HOME. AND WE'VE
SEEN IT'S NOT IT'S NOT JUST THE
MONITORING. IT'S WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT. IT'S THIS ISSUE WE'VE SEEN
IN STUDENTS. WE REPRESENTED
WHERE, FOR EXAMPLE, SPEECH THAT
WAS SET ON A VIDEO HEADSET WHILE
GAMING WAS PICKED UP AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS SENT TO THE HOME
THAT NIGHT AT 11 P.M. RIGHT.
THERE'S JUST ENOUGH, ENOUGH
INTAKES IN OUR INBOX THAT ACLU
OF WAYS THAT SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY
PROBABLY UNINTENTIONALLY
VIOLATING FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
OVER SURVEILLING, VIOLATING
PRIVACY LAWS, AND A LACK OF
TRAINING AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THESE ISSUES THAT WE WORRY THAT
WITHOUT GUARDRAILS, WITHOUT
REALLY THINKING THROUGH THE
APPROACH OF THIS BILL, THAT IT
COULD INVITE THOSE VIOLATIONS.
SO WE DO URGE YOUR NO VOTE AT
THIS TIME AND CONSIDERATION OF
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES TO THIS
ISSUE, BUT DO RESPECTFULLY AGREE
WITH THE PREMISE AND THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL AND APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. DOES
ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? SEEING
NONE, LET US COME BACK TO THE
DAIS. SO I'M BACK, SENATOR
GLAZER SENDS HIS REGARDS. HE'S
CHAIRING RABBIT TAX, BUT SENATOR
STERN, THE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
YOU WERE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT. YES. I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THIS
COMMITTEE. I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING EXPLICIT IN THAT REGARD,
COLLEAGUES. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SENATOR WILK COMMENT
IN QUESTION. SO I KNOW YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIND THE SWEET SPOT ON
THIS, AND THIS IS DEFINITELY I
KNOW FROM FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE,
YOU KNOW, TALKING TO MY
STUDENTS, YOU KNOW, HOW DAMAGING
THIS IS. ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS
THE OPPONENTS MADE, WHICH I
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH, IS THAT
THIS DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH. YOU
SHOULD JUST HAVE THE SCHOOLS
CONFISCATE EVERY STUDENT'S PHONE
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY COME IN, AND
THERE'S ACTUALLY BEEN STUDIES
DONE ON THAT. AND THE STUDENTS
HAVE PERFORMED MUCH BETTER. I
KNOW WE'D NEVER GET THAT OUT,
BUT I, I PERSONALLY BE WAS BE
SUPPORTIVE. I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
VERY RESPONSIBLE AUTHOR. YOU
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. SO I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO FIND THE RIGHT PLACE TO
LAND, AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT AND MOVE IT. THANK YOU, AND
SO FROM MY PART, I'M WITH YOU.
RIGHT. BUT I ACTUALLY I VISITED
WITH A SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MY
DISTRICT RECENTLY WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT. YOU KNOW,
OTHERWISE VERY PROACTIVE, VERY
PROGRESSIVE. AND I ASKED HER,
YOU KNOW, HOW HOW ARE YOU
THINKING ABOUT CELL PHONE USE
AND PROSPECTIVELY BANNING? AND
SO LOWER INCOME SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND HER REALLY QUICKLY SHE SAID,
I WOULDN'T DO IT. NOT BECAUSE
THERE AREN'T BENEFITS BUT BUT IT
CREATES AN ADVERSE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN STAFF. FACULTY AND
STUDENTS THAT THAT SHE THOUGHT
YOU KNOW, ON BALANCE, WOULD GET
IN THE WAY OF SORT OF THE
BROADER GOALS, WHICH, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T KNOW. I MEAN, IT'S WORTH
CONSIDERING, BUT, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS A THORNY, THORNY ISSUE. I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
BUT, YOU KNOW, CLEARLY THERE IS
MUCH LEFT TO DISCUSS, BOTH
BROADLY, BUT ALSO SPECIFICALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO, YOU KNOW, THE
ACTUAL POLICIES, DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? SENATOR WILK MADE THE
MOTION. MADAM PRESIDENT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL Ã. OH. I'M SORRY.
PLEASE CLOSE. JUST JUST A BRIEF
NOTE IN CLOSING, JUST TO FOCUS
ON THIS COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS,
AND IT MAY HELP WITH SOME OF
THOSE UNDERLYING CONCERNS IN THE
DEFINITION OF SOCIAL MEDIA. THE
COMMITTEE, ARTICULATED, IT DOES
NOT INCLUDE AN ELECTRONIC
SERVICE OR ACCOUNT USE
EXCLUSIVELY FOR EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES OR PRIMARILY TO
FACILITATE CREATION OF SCHOOL
SPONSORED PUBLICATIONS, SO THAT
SHOULD HOPEFULLY DEAL WITH THAT,
THE TAKE HOME DEVICE OR THOSE
SORT OF THAT, THAT DISPARATE
IMPACT. BUT I WANT TO JUST BE
CLEAR. WE WANT TO KEEP WORKING
ON THOSE ISSUES. MAYBE THE CLEAN
BREAK APPROACH. I MEAN, LOOK AT
A GUT LEVEL. THAT'S WHAT I, I
WANT TO DO, BUT I ALSO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS TO WRESTLE WITH THIS,
DEPENDING ON THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND I THINK THE
MODELS THAT I'VE SEEN THAT ARE
VERY INTERESTING ON AN
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE ARE
WHERE STUDENTS ARE PART OF, NOT
A FORMAL BUT AN INFORMAL SOCIAL
CONTRACT AT SCHOOL. AND THAT YOU
DON'T CREATE THE ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONSHIP WHERE, LIKE, WE'RE
WATCHING YOU AND YOU'RE IN
TROUBLE NOW, BUT IT'S THAT THEY
COLLECTIVELY AGREE WITH EACH
OTHER TO SAY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DO THIS. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SNAPCHAT WHILE WE'RE AT SCHOOL.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TREAT OUR
CLASSMATES LIKE THIS. AND
GETTING THAT, THAT KIND OF
AGENCY IN THE PROCESS FROM
STUDENTS, I THINK IS ACTUALLY
POWERFUL, BECAUSE I THINK ONCE
YOU GET STUDENTS MOVING
COLLECTIVELY TO SAY, NO, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE DEFINED BY HOW
MANY LIKES WE GET, AND WE'RE
GOING TO SORT OF TRY TO YOU GET
POWER IN IT. IT'S SO I'M HOPING
THAT SCHOOL BOARDS EXPLORE MORE,
NOT JUST THE SORT OF, YOU KNOW,
THAT THE INTERVENTIONIST MODEL,
BUT SOMETHING THAT'S THAT WICKS
HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE TAKE, TAKE
CONTROL OF THEIR OWN LIVES, TOO,
BECAUSE I HONESTLY THINK IT'S
BECOMING AN ADDICTION AND NOT
ACTUALLY SOMETHING ENJOYABLE.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT YOU
HAVE TO DO. AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
ALMOST INHERENTLY COMPELLED
THROUGH THE SOCIAL PRESSURE. SO
MAYBE WE CAN BURST THAT BUBBLE A
LITTLE BIT HERE, BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK. THANK
YOU FOR THE SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CALL. ITEM TEN SB 1283
STERN MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED. NEWMAN NEWMAN I OKOBOJI
I OKOBOJI. CORTEZ. BLAZER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK I WILK I AND I. THAT
MEASURE HAS THREE VOTES TO
LIMON. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN, BUT
IT WILL PASS. THANK YOU, SENATOR
STERN. YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL UP,
AND THAT IS SB FOUR TÍNH 21. YES
AT THE OUTSET, MISTER CHAIR, I
JUST WANT TO NOTE WE'RE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS, AND WE'LL BE WHICH
WILL WHICH WILL ALLOW SORT OF A
BROADENED SCOPE OR AT LEAST A, A
MORE ARTICULATED SCOPE TO
INCLUDE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION, INSTRUCTION AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS. WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME OUTSTANDING
ISSUES ALSO THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED AROUND THAT, BUT WE FEEL
LIKE IT'S IMPORTANT TO STILL
PRESENT THIS BILL AND MOVE IT
FORWARD AT THIS POINT, THE, THE
ESTABLISHMENT IN FORMAL TERMS OF
AN OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL HOPEFULLY ENABLE
SOME KIND OF ABILITY TO APPEAL
OR GO THROUGH A COMPLAINTS
PROCESS WHERE YOU'RE NOT GETTING
THE RECOURSE YOU NEED IN YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT. IF YOU'RE
FACING CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
WE KNOW THE RISE IN HATE IS VERY
REAL, YOU KNOW, WE'VE HAD
ATTACKS ON EVERYONE FROM KIDS,
YOU KNOW, GAY KIDS IN THE
DISTRICT WHO ARE COMING OUT AND
HAVING PEOPLE SCREAMING AT THEM
AS THEY TRY TO WALK ON TO
CAMPUS, ON A QUIET LITTLE STREET
IN NORTH HOLLYWOOD OR, YOU KNOW,
A KID IN WOODLAND HILLS WHO'S
BEEN CALLED A DIRTY JEW FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS IN HER SPECIAL
ED CLASS AND THEN IS, ATTACKED
AND THE CIVIL RIGHTS DIMENSION
TO THAT IS SORT OF SWEPT UNDER.
IT'S AN UNCOMFORTABLE ISSUE. AND
MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS REALLY
WISH IT WEREN'T HAPPENING, AND
IT BECOMES A SOURCE OF ANXIETY
AND EVEN POTENTIALLY LIABILITY.
AND WE KNOW THE STATE SORT OF
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH IT, TOO. NO
ONE REALLY WANTS TO BE IN THIS
POSITION. BUT THE FACT IS THAT
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION, IT'S ULTIMATELY
THEIR JOB TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
RIGHTS ARE UPHELD. JUST LIKE IN
OUR COLLEGE SYSTEMS. THE SAME.
AND SO WHILE THESE INCIDENTS OF
HATE AND DISCRIMINATION ARE
OCCURRING, WE WANT SOME BETTER
RECOURSE FOR PEOPLE FACING THIS
DISCRIMINATION. AND, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT JUST MY BACKYARD. IT'S
ALL OVER THE, THE STATE AND ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY, SO HOPEFULLY
THIS MOVES THE BALL FORWARD. AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. VERY GOOD. WE DO HAVE A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT, SO, PLEASE
PROCEED. I SEE YOU'RE AT TWO,
BUT I ONLY SEE ONE. SO, MORE
TIME FOR YOU. MORE TIME? IS THIS
WORKING? IT IS WORKING. WORKING?
WELL, THAT'S NOT WORKING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR STERN. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS NANCY APEL, AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE. WE THANK SENATOR STERN
AND SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND FOR
LEADING THIS EFFORT TO CLOSE
GAPS IN OUR LAWS AND PROTECT OUR
K THROUGH 12 STUDENTS FROM HATE
BASED HARASSMENT. FOUNDED IN
1913. IN RESPONSE TO AN
ESCALATING CLIMATE OF
ANTI-SEMITISM AND BIGOTRY, ADL
HAS NOW BECOME A LEADING
NATIONAL ANTI-HATE ORGANIZATION,
STRIVING TOWARD A WORLD IN WHICH
NO GROUP OR INDIVIDUAL SUFFERS
FROM BIAS, DISCRIMINATION, OR
HATE. IT'S HARDLY A SECRET THAT
HATE HAS BEEN ON THE RISE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TOO LONG,
REFLECTING A STEADY INCREASE IN
RECENT YEARS. CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL
REPORTED HATE CRIMES INCREASED
BY 20% IN 2022 OVER THE PRIOR
YEAR, AND IN JUST THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF ITS EXISTENCE, THE
CALIFORNIA VÆ HATE HOTLINE,
WHICH CAME OF A BILL. I'M PROUD
TO SAY THAT ADL CO-SPONSORED AND
THE CALIFORNIA VERSUS HATE
HOTLINE SUPPORT SERVICE RECEIVED
OVER 500 REPORTS OF TARGETED
HATE INCIDENTS, THE SCOURGE OF
HATE BASED HARASSMENT, AND
ESPECIALLY ANTI-SEMITIC
HARASSMENT HAS BECOME ACUTE IN
OUR K THROUGH 12 SCHOOLS. AFTER
OCTOBER 7TH, WE WITNESSED A
SHOCKING SPIKE IN THE NUMBER OF
K THROUGH 12 ANTI-SEMITIC
INCIDENTS. AND I'LL JUST ADD
THAT I'VE BEEN WITH ADL, FOR 20
YEARS, SINCE THE BUSH YEARS, I
HAVE JUST NEVER EXPERIENCED
ANYTHING LIKE THIS. I JUST DON'T
EVEN HAVE THE WORDS, THANK YOU,
ACCORDING TO PRELIMINARY ADL
DATA, THERE WAS A 55% INCREASE
IN SUCH INCIDENTS IN THE LAST
QUARTER OF 2023 COMPARED TO THE
SAME PERIOD IN 2022. AND THIS
COMES ON THE HEELS OF A 49%
YEARLY INCREASE IN 2022 OVER
2021 IN THE STATE, ACCORDING TO
OUR DATA. THE PROBLEM IS NOT
LIMITED TO ANTI-SEMITIC ISM. OF
COURSE, AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED
IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS, WE'VE
ALSO SEEN DISTURBING RISES IN
OTHER FORMS OF IDENTITY BASED
HATE, INCLUDING ANTI-AAPI, VÌ,
ANTI-LGBTQ, ANTI-BLACK AND
ANTI-MUSLIM BIAS, TO NAME JUST
SEVERAL OF THE TARGETED
COMMUNITIES. THE CD'S CURRENT
CAPACITY AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SERVE THE IMPACTED STUDENTS JUST
DOES NOT MEET THE CHALLENGE OF
THIS MOMENT. THE TIME IS NOW FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO ESTABLISH A
DEDICATED OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS
WITHIN THE CDE TO BETTER PROTECT
AND SERVE THE CALIFORNIA'S K
THROUGH 12 STUDENTS FOR THIS
REASON. FOR THESE REASONS, ADL
IS PROUD TO SUPPORT SB 1421 AND
I THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE HERE WITH US TODAY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? SEEING NONE IS DO
WE HAVE OPPOSITION, THEY WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE HERE. SEEING
NONE. LET'S COME BACK TO THE
VERY SMALL DAIS, SENATOR CHROBOG
, ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR? I DO, I'M CURIOUS.
SO I HAVE IN MY NOTES HERE THAT
THE. THERE WAS A STATE AUDITOR
REPORT THAT RECOMMENDED TO
CREATE A CENTRAL OFFICE, AND IT
WAS, CENTRAL OFFICE WAS MET BY
CREATING A CENTRALIZED DATABASE
TO TRACK ALL UCP COMPLAINTS AND
APPEALS. IN OCTOBER 2022, CDE
CONSIDER THE RECOMMENDATION TO
BE COMPLETED AND STATED THAT NO
FURTHER UPDATES WOULD BE
PROVIDED. BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS A
BACKLOG RIGHT NOW, WITH REGARDS
TO THESE, TO THESE COMPLAINTS,
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN ACTUAL DATA
THAT SHOWS THAT, THAT THERE IS A
BACKLOG AND, AND MY QUESTION
WOULD BE, WOULD IT NECESSITATE A
COMPLETELY NEW DEPARTMENT, OR DO
WE NEED TO FULLY FUND WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN PLACE IN ORDER
TO ACTUALLY FULLY SERVE THE
STUDENTS IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT,
IN OUR STATE? I THINK YOU RAISE
A GOOD POINT. AND I THINK
THERE'S A NUMBER OF WAYS TO
ARCHITECT THIS. I THINK EXISTING
LAW ACTUALLY, AND THE EXISTING
STRUCTURES DO I MEAN, IF THEY
WERE PROPERLY FUNDED AND
PRIORITIZED, WE COULD PROBABLY
HAVE GOT THIS DONE ANOTHER WAY.
AND PROBABLY SOONER THAN THIS.
BILL. SO YOU'RE NOT WRONG TO
LOOK AT SORT OF WHAT WE CAN DO
WITHIN THE EXISTING FRAMEWORK. I
THINK THE IDEA HERE IS SORT OF
LIKE HOW YOU SEE AND CSU HAVE
DONE IT, THAT ONCE YOU SORT OF
FORMALIZE A STRUCTURE AND PUT
SOMETHING IN PLACE THAT IN
THEORY, THEN YOU'RE GOING TO
BUILD A WHOLE ENVIRONMENT, A
CULTURE AROUND AN OFFICE, WHEN
YOU ACTUALLY HIRE UP THE STAFF,
THEY'RE NOT JUST SORT OF
INTERCHANGEABLE. OR OVER THE
YEARS THEY COULD, YOU KNOW, THIS
ASSIGNMENT, AND THEN YOU SHIFT
OVER TO THAT ASSIGNMENT THAT IT
WOULD PROVIDE SOME CONSISTENCY
AND SORT OF A FRAME. BUT THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE IS, IS EXACTLY
WHAT YOU ARTICULATED. AND IT'S
GOING TO NECESSITATE SOME
LIFTING FROM, FROM, YOU KNOW,
ALL PARTIES IF WE'RE REALLY
GOING TO DEAL WITH THIS BACKLOG,
AND TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY AT STATE LEVEL.
AND SO THE REASON I BRING THAT
UP IS BECAUSE I THINK ESPECIALLY
WITHIN THE BUDGET THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY FACING, I THINK IT
WOULD BE PROBABLY LEAST
EXPENSIVE. AND TO BE ABLE TO
FULLY FUND WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE, IF WE ALREADY HAVE
SOMETHING IN PLACE, THEN IT
WOULD BE TO CREATE A WHOLE NEW
DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY IN THE
PLACE I'M GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY, BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO DISCUSS. IF ALL
ELSE IF ALL ELSE, I THINK YOUR
BILL IS HIGHLIGHTING AN ISSUE
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE THAT HAS
NOT BEEN ADDRESSED. AND IT'S
GOING TO FACILITATE THE
CONVERSATIONS AT THE HIGHER UPS,
AT THE POWERS THAT BE, TO LOOK
AT THE SYSTEM THAT IS CURRENTLY
FAILING OUR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND EITHER WAY,
WHETHER IT'S, YOU KNOW, A
PROPOSAL COMING IN FROM ANOTHER
ANGLE IN SUPPORTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO FULLY FUND WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE, I BE IN COMPLETE
SUPPORT OF THAT IF YOUR BILL
MOVES FORWARD. AND, YOU KNOW, IS
PUT IN PLACE, I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF IT AS WELL. BUT I DO
THINK, ULTIMATELY THE GOAL WOULD
BE TO TRY TO DO SOMETHING THAT
IS BETTER NOT AS COSTLY, BUT
ACTUALLY MEET THE NEEDS THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY NOT MEETING. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU CONVERSATION.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN YOU APPRECIATE THAT. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS. SO
SENATOR BOGUSZ TOUCHED ON ON MY
CONCERNS. SENATOR STERN, YOU AND
I HAVE TALKED, YOU KNOW, I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO ASK. AND I THINK
SHE EFFECTIVELY HAS, YOU KNOW,
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE CURRENT
UNIVERSITY COMPLAINT PROCESS
THAT IS NOT WORKING, AND YOU
KNOW, DOES IT NECESSITATE THE
CREATION OF A NEW OFFICE?
BECAUSE CLEARLY IT'S NOT
WORKING. AND, I MEAN, I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE, APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM, BUT IT HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR A WHILE. IT'S AN
ESCALATING PROBLEM. SO
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
SOMEBODY HERE FROM CDE TO
ANSWER. I THINK SOME BASIC
QUESTIONS. RIGHT. IN THE ABSENCE
OF AN APPROPRIATION IN THIS
MEASURE, RIGHT, YOU'RE FACING
PRETTY MEANINGFUL COSTS. AND TO
SENATOR SCHOENBERG'S POINT, YOU
KNOW, IN A TOUGH BUDGET YEAR.
BUT BUT THERE'S PROBABLY A BUNCH
OF FULL TIME EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
PROBABLY NECESSARY TO STAFF AN
OFFICE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT HAS
THOUSANDS OF SCHOOLS AND
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS. AND SO
THAT THAT IS A CHALLENGE. I
THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL INCUR
AS IT MOVES FORWARD. BUT I'M
GRATEFUL FOR YOU HAVING ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS. THAT GIVES US, I
THINK, SOME CLARITY AND
ALIGNMENT WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
OFFICES THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED,
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. BUT I, YOU KNOW,
CAUTION, YOU'RE AWARE OF THIS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A KIND OF AN
UPHILL CLIMB FROM HERE. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FROM, I THINK,
SENATOR BORG. YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. ALL ACCURATE AND WELL
PLACED COMMENTS. AND WHAT I'M
HOPING IS, THAT SHOULD THIS BILL
KEEP MOVING TODAY AND GO ALL THE
WAY TO FISCAL COMMITTEE WHERE,
THERE ARE MOUNTAINS TO CLIMB.
LET'S JUST SAY THAT IN ANALYZING
THIS BILL AND SCORING IT AND
GETTING INTO THE DETAILS OF HOW
YOU WOULD STAFF UP EITHER A
STANDALONE OFFICE OR IN THEORY,
THEN WITHOUT THAT ARCHITECTURE,
JUST GETTING WHAT THE FTES ARE
GOING TO LOOK LIKE TO ACTUALLY
PROCESS THE BACKLOG. HOPEFULLY
THROUGH THAT PROCESS, WE GET A
LITTLE MORE INTO THOSE DETAILS
THAT THAT SORT OF HAVEN'T BEEN
FORTHCOMING SINCE THAT AUDIT
REPORT. SO I HOPE IT'S A HEALTHY
EXERCISE TO KIND OF GO THROUGH
THIS. AND I KNOW WE'RE IN
POLICY, BUT TO ALMOST FORCE THAT
THAT BUDGET CONVERSATION TO AND
SEE WHERE IT GOES. I KNOW THIS
IS A IT'S A CLIMB AND IT'S A
TOUGH YEAR, BUT I JUST I GOT TO
GO HOME AND TALK TO FAMILIES AND
SAY, YOU KNOW, WE'VE RUN OUT OF
RECOURSE. AND I APPRECIATE THE
KIND OF MOMENT OF PERSONAL
CANDOR FROM OUR LEAD WITNESS
HERE. IT IS VERY OVERWHELMING
AND DISPIRITING. WE'RE THROWING
THIS OUT THERE TO SAY LIKE, HEY,
MAYBE, MAYBE THIS WILL SHAKE
THINGS LOOSE OR SOMETHING'S GOT
TO CHANGE. IT'S A PROBLEM. SO
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME SOME
ROOM TO RUN HERE AND RAISE IT.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE ACUTE,
OBSERVATIONS. THEY'RE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHILE ITEM 11, SB
1421, STERN MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN I, NEWMAN I,
OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI. CORTESE
CORTESE, I, GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, WILK I, WILK I
. THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES.
IT WILL PASS. I WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR THE TIME BEING. WE'RE
GETTING TOWARD THE END, I THINK.
SENATOR CORTESE, YOU'VE GOT A
BILL FOR US. SB 1431. THANK YOU.
MR. BILL.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB 1431.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF FIRE
SAFETY AUTHORITY OVER A VERY
SPECIFIC PROJECT. THE SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY SPARTAN VILLAGE
ON THE PASEO PROJECT. CRUCIALLY,
THE OFFICE WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
PURSUE AND DIRECT ALL EFFORTS
ASSOCIATED WITH FIRE, PANIC OR
LIFE SAFETY PLAN CHECKS,
PERMITS, INSPECTIONS AND
CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY. JUST
IN THIS INSTANCE, FOR THIS VERY
SPECIFIC LOCAL PROJECT THROUGH
THE PROJECT, APPROXIMATELY 700
BEDS WILL BE SPREAD ACROSS 264
EXISTING ROOMS AND 11
RESIDENTIAL FLOORS OF A FORMER
HOTEL TOWER. SPARTAN VILLAGE ON
THE PASEO WILL BE AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT HOUSING
COMMUNITY FOR FIRST YEAR
RETURNING STUDENTS LOOKING FOR
DIFFERENT HOUSING OPTIONS OFF
CAMPUS. THIS HAS BEEN A FAST
MOVING PROJECT BECAUSE IT'S A
STUDENT HOUSING CONVERSION OF A
MAJOR HOTEL. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
STATE REGULATORY SYSTEM WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO MOVE QUICKLY ENOUGH
FOR THE PROJECT TO STAY ON
SCHEDULE FOR THE FALL SEMESTER.
JUST A FEW MONTHS FROM NOW, SAN
JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS
WILL NEED THESE ROOMS. GIVEN THE
CURRENT CRISIS IN STUDENT
HOUSING, WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
WAIT. CALIFORNIA STUDENTS, AS WE
KNOW, ARE INCREASINGLY UNABLE TO
ACCESS, LET ALONE AFFORD HOUSING
DURING THEIR ACADEMIC JOURNEYS.
THIS UNACCEPTABLE REALITY IS
THAT 1 IN 10 STUDENTS AT CSU
SYSTEMWIDE IS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS, ACCORDING TO
STUDIES AND DATA THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED. AND IN FACT, THE
NUMBER AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY, ACCORDING TO THE
SILICON VALLEY PAIN INDEX, IS
CURRENTLY AT 11. SO SAN JOSE
STATE IS NO EXCEPTION TO THE
CURRENT SITUATION. STUDENTS AT
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY FACE
AN EVEN GREATER CHALLENGE OF
GOING TO SCHOOL IN ONE OF THE
LEAST AFFORDABLE REGIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES. IF NOT THE MOST,
IF NOT THE LEAST AFFORDABLE
REGION. THE CSU OFFICE OF FIRE
SAFETY HAS EXPERTISE TO OVERSEE
ACTIVITIES DIRECTLY, AS
EVIDENCED BY THE EXISTING AND
ONGOING PLAN TRANSITION OF
OVERARCHING AUTHORITY FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
TO THE CSU OFFICE OF FIRE
SAFETY. THE CSU ALREADY HAS
AUTHORITY TO ACT AS ITS OWN
BUILDING ENFORCEMENT AGENCY,
WITH US TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
TRACY AND I SHOULD HAVE ASKED
HOW TO PRONOUNCE YOUR NAME
FERTILE. HODGE TRACY, FERTILE
LODGE, SENIOR ASSISTANT VICE
PRESIDENT OF FACILITIES
DEVELOPMENT AND OPERATIONS AT
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY. AND
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. YEAH. WELCOME. WELCOME,
MISTER VERLOC. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE, PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. MY NAME IS TRACY
FERLAZZO. I'M THE SENIOR
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
FACILITIES DEVELOPMENT AND
OPERATIONS AT SAN JOSE. MY NAME
IS TRACY FERTILE, AND I'M THE
SENIOR ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT
FOR FACILITIES DEVELOPMENT AND
OPERATIONS AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY. I WANT TO EXTEND OUR
DEEPEST THANKS TO SENATOR CORTEZ
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL AND IS
UNWAVERED SUPPORT FOR SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO URGE YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL 1431,
WHICH WOULD ENABLE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
OFFICE OF FIRE SAFETY TO PERFORM
FIRE AND PANIC SAFETY OVERSIGHT
FOR THE UNIVERSITY'S ADAPTIVE
REUSE OF A HOTEL TOWER INTO A
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECT KNOWN AS
SPARTAN VILLAGE ON THE PASEO.
THE PROJECT'S LOCATION IN
DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE OFFERS
CONVENIENT ACCESS TO CAMPUS AND
SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO FOSTER A
VIBRANT STUDENT COMMUNITY WHILE
ALSO HELPING TO REVITALIZE THE
DOWNTOWN THAT HAS BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE FACE
CHALLENGES LOCATING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS CHALLENGE IS
EXACERBATED FOR SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS WHO ARE MORE
WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO COME FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND BE A
FIRST GENERATION STUDENT THAN
WHEN COMPARED TO THOSE FROM
OTHER INSTITUTIONS, AND WHO ALSO
ENDEAVOR TO ACHIEVE THEIR
ACADEMIC GOALS IN ONE OF THE
LEAST AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKETS
IN THE COUNTRY, SPARTAN VILLAGE
ON THE PASEO OFFERS THE ABILITY
TO MEET STUDENT HOUSING NEEDS AT
A MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND
QUICKER PACE THAN COULD HAVE
BEEN ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH A
TRADITIONAL BUILT FROM THE
GROUND UP PROJECT, THROUGH
ADAPTIVE REUSE OF AN EXISTING
BUILDING AND FUNDING PROVIDED BY
THE STATE'S HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENT HOUSING PROGRAM. WE ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE 679 STUDENTS
WITH A HEALTHY RESIDENTIAL
EXPERIENCE, AS WELL AS WILL BE
WILL BEGIN TO OFFER A NEW AND
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTION.
SENATE BILL 1431 STREAMLINES AND
EFFICIENTLY USES STATE AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
RESOURCES DURING DESIGN REVIEW,
PERMITTING, INSPECTION AND OTHER
ASSOCIATED PROCESSES NECESSARY
TO SAFELY WELCOME STUDENTS. THIS
FALL, THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF FIRE SAFETY
IS QUALIFIED AND STAFFED TO
ALLOW SUCCESSFUL PERFORMANCE OF
THE DUTIES NECESSARY FOR THE
NECESSARY DUTIES REQUIRED FOR
TIMELY COMPLETION. IN CLOSING, I
URGE THE COMMITTEE'S SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL 1431, WHICH WILL
DIRECTLY HELP ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CHALLENGES FACING OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE AND FOR YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS MATTER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WITH US TODAY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE? SEEING NO ONE, IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? ALSO SEEING NO ONE.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION. SENATOR CORTEZ.
BASICALLY, I GUESS TWO
QUESTIONS. ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS? YES OKAY. THAT'S THE
FIRST QUESTION. THAT WAS EASY.
THE SECOND QUESTION. WELL, YOU
KNOW WHAT I UNDERSTANDING THERE
WAS AN MOU IN PLACE. WHAT? WHY
IS THAT NOT SUFFICIENT FOR YOUR
PURPOSES NOW? YEAH. THE I THINK
I'LL DEFER TO, TO THE WITNESS,
YOU KNOW, FOR A MORE SPECIFIC
ANSWER. BUT THE MOU THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THE BILL WOULD
BE ONE THAT'S PUT TOGETHER
SPECIFIC FOR THIS PROJECT. THIS
IS THIS IS THE FAIRMONT HOTEL IN
DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE, IT'S A VERY
SPECIFIC PROJECT IN THE HEART OF
THE CITY, A VERY MODERN
BUILDING. AND THE IDEA IS JUST
TO GET AN MOU IN PLACE THAT
ISN'T DEPENDENT ON ANY OTHER
MOU. THIS BILL HAS AN URGENCY ON
IT, AND IT'S JUST GOING TO NEED
TO MOVE VERY QUICKLY. OKAY MR.
FERTILIZER, IF YOU WOULD MIND,
CERTAINLY. YES. THERE IS AN
EXISTING MOU IN PLACE THAT
PROVIDES STEPPED TRANSITION FOR
AUTHORITY TO TRANSFER FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
TO THE OFFICE OF FIRE SAFETY
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. HOWEVER, THAT THAT
MOU HAS A NUMBER OF REQUIRED
STEPS THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR THE
WHOLE SYSTEM TO OVERTAKE THAT
PERMITTING, INSPECTION AND,
OTHER ACTIVITIES, RELATED TO THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. THE TIMING FOR THAT MOU
IS ADOPTION IS NOT ALIGNED WITH
WHAT THE PROJECT NEEDS ARE.
THUS, THE REQUEST FOR THE
SPECIAL DISPENSATION. ALL RIGHT.
UNDERSTOOD. APPRECIATE THAT,
MAKES SENSE TO ME, GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL, SENATOR
CORTEZ, IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE,
I THINK SENATOR WILK WAS ABOUT
TO MAKE A MOTION. WILK MOVES THE
BILL. MOVES THE BILL? GO AHEAD
AGAIN. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
TO YOUR COMMITTEE FOR, THE
ASSISTANCE WITH THE BILL. AND
AGAIN, WE ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AND APPRECIATED THE GREAT
QUESTION. I ACTUALLY HAD THE
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION HERE, BUT
I DIDN'T USE IT. NEXT TIME I'LL
LEARN TO DO THAT. WELL, YOU
WANTED TO GIVE YOUR WITNESS A
CHANCE TO SHINE. THAT WAS REALLY
THE IDEA. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU FOR MAKING ME LOOK
GOOD, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
AYE. VOTE VERY GOOD. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE. ITEM 17, SB 1431. CORTEZ
MOTION IS Dð. PASSES AMENDED TO
SENATE. GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. NEWMAN,
A, NEWMAN I, OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI I
CORTEZ I AGAIN. CORTEZ I GLASER.
BLAZER I GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK I WILK I. ALL RIGHT.
THE MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES. WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE TIME
BEING. AND I THINK WE'RE DOWN TO
OUR LAST TWO MEASURES, FROM OUR
FAVORITE MEMBER, SENATOR GLASER.
AND TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE. THIS IS LIKE STAYING
FOR EXTRA INNINGS IN BASEBALL.
YOU GET, EXTRA CREDIT. THAT'S,
THAT'S EVEN MORE OF A CLASSIC
ARGUMENT. SINCE WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT THE Þ CONTRACT IN MY
COMMITTEE, REVEREND TAX, MR.
CHAIR, IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU,
CAN I BEGIN WITH SB 1200?
CERTAINLY RIGHT. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN I'M READY. ALL RIGHT, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I WANT TO
FIRST THANK THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
THIS IS NOT A NEW ISSUE. THIS
MEASURE BEFORE YOU EXTENDS THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM,
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED BY SB 412
AND THAT I AUTHORED IN 2016, HOW
TIME FLIES, SB 1200 WILL DO A
NUMBER OF THINGS. IT ELIMINATES
THE SUNSET DATE THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE IN THAT ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION. NUMBER TWO, IT
REQUIRES THE TRUSTEES TO REPORT
ANNUALLY ON THE PARTICIPATION
RATE AND THE DEMOGRAPHICS AND
HOW IT'S AFFECTING THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE, PER
CAMPUS. AND FINALLY, IT RENAMES
THE PROGRAM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM, WHICH HAS
BECOME A VERY POPULAR FRAMING OF
OTHER EDUCATIONAL INITIATIVES IN
THE STATE. IT RENAMES IT TO THE
FINISH IN, FOR AND THROUGH IN
TWO PROGRAM, AND THAT'S TO
ELIMINATE SOME OF THE CONFUSION
THAT THE NAME HAS HAS CREATED
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED STUDENTS WITH THE
CRUCIAL SUPPORT NEEDED TO EARN
THEIR DEGREE IN 2 OR 4 YEARS,
PARTICIPATING STUDENTS ARE GIVEN
PRIORITY REGISTRATION AND
PROVIDED WITH, ACADEMIC
ADVISEMENT AND IN SOME CASES,
THEY'RE PLACED IN TWO AND FOUR
YEAR COHORTS. THE STUDENTS MUST
COMPLETE. THIS IS THE
REQUIREMENT ON THE STUDENTS.
THEY MUST COMPLETE 30 UNITS
WITHIN AN ACADEMIC YEAR AND
ADHERE TO ANY OTHER REQUIREMENTS
MANDATED BY THE PARTICIPATING
CAMPUS, AND SO FAR, IT'S BEEN
WORKING PRETTY WELL, ACCORDING
TO DATA FROM THE STATE
UNIVERSITY TRANSFER STUDENTS WHO
ENROLL IN THIS PROMISE PROGRAM
GRADUATE AT A RATE 64% HIGHER
THAN THE SYSTEMWIDE RATE. THANK
YOU TO THE ANALYSIS FOR POINTING
THAT OUT. AND OF COURSE, THE
HIGH GRADUATION RATE IS MADE ALL
THE MORE CAUSE FOR CELEBRATION
BY THE FACT THAT IT'S AIMED AT
STUDENTS WHO ARE UNDERREPRESENT
COUNTED IN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM. THE PROGRAM IS LIMITED
OR IT HAS A PRIORITY TO STUDENTS
WHO ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
OUR LOW INCOME, PELL ELIGIBLE OR
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS OR
FROM COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT THE VITAL SUPPORT
OF THIS PROGRAM CONTINUES TO
BENEFIT COHORTS OF STUDENTS INTO
THE FUTURE, AND OF COURSE, IT
EXTENDS OUR OUR GOAL, OUR
IMPORTANT GOAL OF ELIMINATING
THESE LONG STANDING OPPORTUNITY
GAPS THAT STILL EXIST TODAY, AS
MEMBERS MAY KNOW. AND THEY'VE
HEARD ME TALK ABOUT THIS IN
COMMITTEE BEFORE. IN 2016, THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE AT THE
CSU WAS 19. THAT'S WHEN WE 19%
IN 2016. TODAY I BELIEVE IT'S
ALMOST A LITTLE OVER 35, ALMOST
A DOUBLING IN THESE LAST SEVEN
YEARS. NOW, THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
RESOURCES THAT THE STATE HAS PUT
IN TO HELP THE PROGRAM, BUT IT
IS ONE OF THE REALLY GREAT
SUCCESS STORIES OF AN
INSTITUTION WITHOUT A LOT OF NEW
MONEY, BUT A REFOCUS ON GETTING
KIDS TO COMPLETION, HAS HAD THIS
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT IN
GRADUATION RATES. THAT MEANS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
THAT WOULD NORMALLY DROP OUT ARE
GETTING THEIR DEGREE AND GETTING
ON A PATH TO ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES. SO IT'S A REAL
POINT OF PRIDE FOR ME IN MY
SERVICE, BOTH AS A FORMER
TRUSTEE AND NOW AS A SENATOR
THAT LOVES THE MISSION OF THE
STATE UNIVERSITIES. IT'S REALLY
A POINT OF PRIDE TO SEE THIS
PROGRESS. IT HAS TO CONTINUE.
THERE'S A LOT MORE PROGRESS TO
BE MADE, AND THAT'S THE GOAL OF
THE BILL. BEFORE YOU. WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES OR DO YOU. NO WITNESS.
IT SAYS MY PAPER SAYS NO WITNESS
, ANY IS THERE ANYBODY HERE LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ROBERT MURRAY, CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, IN SUPPORT
FOR THE NECESSARY FOR OUR
WORKFORCES NEED RIGHT FOR THESE
DEGREES. SO SORRY TO TAKE THAT
ONE SENTENCE. SINCE THERE'S NO
WITNESS, I'D HAVE GIVEN YOU UP
TO THREE MINUTES. MR. MURRAY
SAID. THANK YOU FOR THAT
TESTIMONY, EVERYBODY. THANKS YOU
FOR YOUR BREVITY, GUYS. ANYBODY
HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE,
SEEING NONE, BACK TO THE DAIS, I
WILL SAY, SENATOR GLAZER, YOU
DESERVE, LOTS OF CREDIT FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE, IN
FOCUSING THE SYSTEM ON THIS
ISSUE AND THEN CATALYZING THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'VE SEEN,
GLAD TO SUPPORT IT, LOOKING FOR
A MOTION. IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND YOUR CONTINUED
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE BEYOND THIS
BILL IN TERMS OF STUDENT
COMPLETION AND SUCCESS. SO I GET
A MOTION FROM SENATOR BOGUE.
MADAM, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHILE. ITEM 15 SB 1200 GLAZER A
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
A NEWMAN I OKOBOJI I OKOBOJI I
CORTESE. CORTESE I GLAZER.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WILK. HI. WILK I. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE CURRENTLY
HAS FIVE VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR THE TIME BEING, AND
THIS BRINGS US TO THE LAST, BILL
OF THE DAY THAT IS ITEM NUMBER
16, SB 1287, PLEASE, AT YOUR
LEISURE. GREAT. AND I HAVE A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES. WE WANT TO
INVITE THE STUDENTS TO COME
FORWARD. MEMBER. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. SB 1287 AFFIRMS
THE ROLE THAT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES MUST
TAKE TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS CAN
EXERCISE THEIR FREE SPEECH
RIGHTS AND EXCHANGE VIEWS
RESPECTFULLY IN RECENT YEARS,
REALLY, IN RECENT MONTHS AND
WEEKS, WE'VE WITNESSED AN
ALARMING TREND OF ESCALATING
HARASSMENT AND INTIMIDATION AND
VIOLENCE TARGETED TOWARDS
MARGINALIZED GROUPS ON OUR
CAMPUSES. THIS OBVIOUSLY
THREATENS THE SAFETY AND
WELL-BEING OF OUR STUDENTS, OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF THREATENS THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS, AND IT
THREATENS THE FREE EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS AND VIEWPOINTS. AS AN
EXAMPLE, TWO STUDENTS AT UC
BERKELEY JUST A MONTH OR SO AGO
WERE FORCED TO SEEK MEDICAL
ATTENTION AFTER AN EVENT
FEATURED AN ISRAELI SPEAKER WAS
BOYCOTTED. PROTESTERS, HUNDREDS
OF THEM, ENGAGED TO TRY TO STOP
THIS EVENT. PROTESTERS CHOKED
ONE OF THE FIRST YEAR JEWISH
STUDENTS WHO WAS HOPING TO
ATTEND THE EVENT. THEY BROKE
INTO THE THEATER WHERE THE EVENT
WAS TAKING PLACE. STUDENTS WERE
SPAT ON, CALLED AND DIRTY JEWS.
MEANWHILE, CAMPUS SECURITY WAS
CLEARLY OVERWHELMED AND UNDER
AND UNPREPARED TO PROTECT THESE
JEWISH STUDENTS FROM THIS
OBVIOUS ANTI-SEMITISM, OUR
COLLEGES HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROMOTE FREE SPEECH WHILE
PREVENTING DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT. THIS BILL ALIGNS
WITH THAT RESPONSIBILITY BY
REQUIRING CAMPUSES TO INSTITUTE
POLICIES THAT EXPLICITLY
PROHIBIT VIOLENCE, HARASSMENT,
INTIMIDATION, AND
DISCRIMINATION, INCLUDING
INTERFERENCE WITH FREE SPEECH
AND OR SUPPORT FOR GENOCIDE. SB
1287 ALSO REQUIRES UNIVERSITIES
TO DEVELOP PROGRAMS TO EDUCATE
STUDENTS ON HOW TO EXCHANGE
VIEWS RESPECTFULLY. AND FINALLY,
THE BILL REQUIRES A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ANNUALLY ON
THEIR PROGRESS IN DOING THESE.
THESE THINGS BY FOSTERING
RESPECT, CIVILITY AND
INCLUSIVITY, WE CREATE A
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT WHERE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY CAN THRIVE. WITH ME
TODAY, I HAVE TWO STUDENTS TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY. GABRIEL
GAZINSKY AND CARLY KLINGER, AND
THEY'RE BOTH STUDENTS AT UC
DAVIS. AND IF THE DISCRETION OF
THE CHAIR, WE WELCOME THEIR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND WELCOME TO
THE WITNESSES. PLEASE PROCEED.
Þ. HELLO. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS GABRIEL
GAZINSKY, AND I'M A THIRD YEAR
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS. I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE AS A
JEWISH ISRAELI STUDENT ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS PAST WINTER, I WENT ON AN
EIGHT DAY TRIP TO ISRAEL WITH
OTHER STUDENT ACTIVISTS. WHILE
THERE, I SPOKE TO SURVIVORS OF
THE OCTOBER 7TH MASSACRES. THE
FAMILIES OF THOSE STILL HELD
HOSTAGE IN GAZA AND STOOD IN THE
VERY PLACES WHERE ISRAELIS WERE
RAPED, BUTCHERED AND KIDNAPED
DURING THAT WEEK, I WITNESSED AN
ENTIRE NATION IN MOURNING AND
TRAUMA. WHAT HAPPENED ON OCTOBER
7TH WAS, AND I CANNOT OVERSTATE
THIS, THE SINGLE MOST TRAUMATIC
EVENT IN RECENT JEWISH MEMORY.
NOW AT UC DAVIS, EVERY DAY I
HEAR STORIES FROM FRIENDS ABOUT
HOW THEY'VE BEEN PHYSICALLY OR
VERBALLY ATTACKED, EXCLUDED FROM
ACADEMIC SPACES, AND MADE TO
FEEL UNSAFE BECAUSE OF THEIR
JEWISH OR ISRAELI IDENTITY. I
PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY HARASSED IN PERSON
AND ON THE INTERNET EVEN PRIOR
TO OCTOBER 7TH, BUT MUCH MORE
AFTERWARD. I'VE BEEN CALLED
SLURS, INSULT, OUTED, AND
ACCUSED OF VARIOUS CRIMES SIMPLY
BECAUSE I AM AN OUTSPOKEN AND
PROUD JEWISH ISRAELI. EVERY TIME
I SPEAK UP, WHETHER IT IS BY
PUBLISHING AN OP ED OR VOICING
MY COMMUNITY STRUGGLES IN A
STUDENT GOVERNMENT MEETING, IT
PAINTS A TARGET ON MY BACK.
EVERYWHERE ON CAMPUS, I SEE
HATRED IN THE EYES OF MY PEERS
AND FORMER FRIENDS. NOW, I URGE
YOU TO UTILIZE YOUR POSITIONS OF
AUTHORITY AND INFLUENCE TO
PROTECT THE JEWISH AND ISRAELI
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
PASSAGE OF THIS PROPOSAL. NOT
ONLY WILL IT CURTAIL THE RAPID
SPREAD OF ANTI-SEMITISM ON OUR
CAMPUSES, BUT IT WILL HELP
COMBAT ALL OTHER FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AS WELL. A CLEAR
DISTINCTION MUST BE MADE BETWEEN
LEGITIMATE CRITICISM OF A
GOVERNMENT, A POLITICAL MOVEMENT
OR AN INSURGENT GROUP, AND THE
CALLS FOR VIOLENCE THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE AGAINST SOME OF THE
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. IF THIS IS PASSED,
THEN IT WILL BE THE FIRST STEP.
HOPEFULLY OF MANY, IN CREATING A
SAFE AND WELCOMING CALIFORNIA
FOR JEWS, ISRAELIS, PALESTINIANS
AND ALL THOSE AFFECTED BY THE
CURRENT CLIMATE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WELCOME, MISS MISHRA,
GOOD MORNING. IS IT ON? OH,
COOL. GOOD MORNING. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS KALI
KLINGER, AND I'M A THIRD YEAR AT
UC DAVIS, I'M HERE REPRESENTING
JEWISH STUDENTS ON OUR CAMPUS AS
AN OPENLY JEWISH STUDENT ON A UC
CAMPUS, I HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
MONUMENTAL AMOUNTS OF
ANTI-SEMITISM BEFORE, BUT
ESPECIALLY AFTER OCTOBER 7TH
LAST YEAR, AFTER WHITE
SUPREMACISTS PUT UP HOLOCAUST
DENIAL FLIERS NEAR OUR CAMPUS,
UC DAVIS DECIDED TO RESPOND BY
CONDEMNING JUST WHITE SUPREMACY
AND NOT ANTI-SEMITISM. ONLY
AFTER JEWISH STUDENTS CALLED
THEM OUT DID THEY REDO THE POST
CALLING ANTI-SEMITISM WHAT IT
WAS. ADDITIONALLY, WE HAD
SWASTIKAS ON DORM BUILDINGS, AND
AS I WALKED THROUGH THE QUAD
WHERE STUDENT GROUPS TABLE ONE
DAY, I WAS CALLED A ZIO FOR MY
JEWISH AND ISRAELI IDENTITY.
NOW, AFTER OCTOBER 7TH, I CAN NO
LONGER WALK THROUGH AREAS WHERE
STUDENTS GROUPS ARE TABLING
WITHOUT BEING YELLED AT OR
CALLED SLURS. I HAVE HAD TO MISS
CLASS OR WALK THROUGH CHANTS OF
WE DON'T WANT A JEWISH STATE IN
ORDER TO GET INTO THE BUILDING
WHERE I CAN STILL HEAR PEOPLE
CHANTING FOR THE FALL OF THE
JEWISH HOMELAND WHERE MY
GRANDPARENTS ESCAPED TO IN ORDER
TO AVOID BEING SLAUGHTERED IN
GERMANY, I HAVE SAT THROUGH
COUNTLESS MEETINGS WITH
ADMINISTRATORS, INCLUDING OUR
CHANCELLOR, TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN ADHERENCE TO POLICY BY
STUDENTS AND FACULTY OR FOR A
CHANGE IN POLICY TO PREVENT
BEHAVIOR, SUCH AS SEEN AT
BERKELEY IN WHICH JEWISH
STUDENTS WERE ASSAULTED BY AN
ANGRY MOB WHEN LEAVING AN EVENT
TO TAKE PROACTIVE MEASURES TO
ENSURE STUDENTS ARE BETTER
EDUCATED THAN TO PROHIBIT A
CERTAIN CLASS OF STUDENTS FROM
ENTERING A MULTICULTURAL CENTER.
AS OCCURRED AT UC SANTA BARBARA,
AND TO CREATE STUDENTS WHO ARE
MORE EDUCATED THAN TO SAY OPENLY
THAT THEY ARE PROUD
ANTI-SEMITES. NEXT TO A GROUP OF
JEWISH STUDENTS, WHICH HAPPENED
AT A STUDENT SENATE MEETING IN
DAVIS, AND TO ALLOW FACULTY TO
BE EDUCATED AS WELL TO PREVENT
PROFESSORS FROM POSTING
ANTI-SEMITISM, ANTI-SEMITIC
THREATS AND MESSAGES ON ACTS
SUCH AS WE ALSO SAW AT UC DAVIS.
THIS BILL AIDS IN THE PROMOTION
OF DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
WITHIN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS IN MANDATING THAT
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
REPORT PROGRESS OF IMPLEMENTING
THESE MEASURES. IT SENDS A
STRONG MESSAGE THAT ALL
STUDENTS, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
BACKGROUND OR BELIEFS, HAVE THE
RIGHT TO EXPRESS THEIR
IDENTITIES WITHOUT HINDRANCE AND
HOSTILITY. IT IS IMPERATIVE TO
THE EMPOWERMENT OF STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN HIDING THEIR
IDENTITIES OUT OF FEAR FOR THEIR
SAFETY TO BEGIN TO PARTICIPATE
AS THEIR FULL SELVES IN
UNIVERSITY. ACADEMICS AND
ACTIVITIES. THIS BILL ALLOWS
STUDENTS A VOICE THAT IS
ACTUALLY LISTENED TO AND
CONSIDERED IN THE ROOMS THAT
HOLD THE DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THEIR LIVED
EXPERIENCES. THESE POLICIES
IMPACT THE DAILY LIVES AND
WELL-BEING OF THESE STUDENTS,
WHO DESERVE ASSURANCE THAT THEY
ARE PART OF THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESSES. IN CONCLUSION, I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
PASSAGE OF THIS PROPOSAL IN
ORDER TO MOVE TOWARDS MORE
EQUITABLE HIGHER EDUCATION
ENVIRONMENTS FOR ALL STUDENTS TO
PREVENT DIVERSE GROUPS ON
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES FROM HAVING
TO FILE TITLE SIX, LIKE THE
JEWISH STUDENTS AT UC DAVIS DID,
BECAUSE WE FEEL SO UNHEARD AND
IRRELEVANT TO OUR ADMINISTRATION
AND SEE SO MUCH HATRED AND
TARGETING BY OUR PEERS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION, AND THANK YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY, IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE HERE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE? MR. BERG? WELCOME.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. CLIFF
BERG HERE ON BEHALF OF JPAC, THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE,
URGING YOUR SUPPORT. I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR GLAZER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS MEASURE.
JPAC, AS MANY OF YOU KNOW,
REPRESENTS OVER 30 SOMETHING
JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, MANY OF THEM
STATEWIDE, MANY OF THEM REGIONAL
, REGIONAL. IN ADDITION, OVER 40
JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SIGNED
OUR LETTER IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
GLAZER'S BILL, WE ARE FACING A
CRISIS ON OUR CAMPUSES. JEWISH
STUDENTS, THEIR FAMILIES SHOULD
NOT FEEL THREATENED AND UNSAFE,
WE NEED THIS LEGISLATION, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. SABRINA
MENES WITH THE CAPITAL ADVISORS
GROUP, ALSO ON BEHALF OF JPAC
AND A COALITION OF MORE THAN 40
JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1287. SEVERAL OF THOSE
INCLUDE THREE AJC CHAPTERS THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE, THREE
HILLEL CENTERS, THREE JEWISH
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COUNCILS FOR
JEWISH FEDERATION CHAPTERS, SIX
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES CHAPTERS,
SIX JEWISH DEMOCRATIC REGIONAL
AND NATIONAL GROUPS, AND 14
OTHER COALITION MEMBERS. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANY
ANYONE ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? DOES ANYBODY
HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, LET'S COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. QUESTIONS? COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES. SENATOR CORTESE
, YES. AS FOR THE AUTHOR, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP WITH THE BILL. AND
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF IT, AND I'D BE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT REGARDLESS OF
THE ANSWER TO THIS NEXT
QUESTION. BUT OBVIOUSLY, THE
TESTIMONY AND SO MUCH OF THE
SUPPORT, IS FOCUSED ON
ANTI-SEMITISM AND THAT'S
COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDABLE UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. AND GIVEN THE
TESTIMONY WE JUST HEARD, IT
SEEMS THAT THE BILL'S INTENT IS
BROADER THAN THAT IN A GOOD WAY.
I WOULD OPINE, TRYING TO GET TO
HATE SPEECH IN A MORE GENERAL
WAY, COULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT,
PLEASE? PLEASE? GOOD. THE CHAIR.
SENATOR CORTESE, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION. AND YES, INDEED,
THIS THIS BILL ISN'T, ISN'T
SPECIFIC TO JEWISH STUDENTS.
IT'S AGAINST HATE AND
INTIMIDATION AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST ALL STUDENTS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS. WE JUST SO HAPPENS
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING SOME
VERY ACUTE CRISES AS IT RELATES
TO THE JEWISH COMMUNITY ON
CAMPUSES, BUT THE BILL IS MEANT
TO TRY TO PROTECT ALL GROUPS,
AND THERE'S FREE SPEECH RIGHTS
FROM FROM THIS TYPE OF HATE,
HARASSMENT, INTIMIDATION AND
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
OKAY. SENATORS FROM QUEBEC. AND
I JUST WANTED TO SAY I'M HAPPY
TO BE A COAUTHOR ON THIS. ON
THIS BILL. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A THIS IS A HUMAN RIGHTS
ISSUE, THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING
OUR STUDENTS, PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE, AGAINST
HATE, CERTAINLY, I THINK ABOUT
GEORGE FLOYD AND THE WAYS IN
WHICH MANY, SO MANY BLACK
STUDENTS, HAD FACED VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE HANDS OF POLICE ON
CAMPUS AND EXPRESSING CONCERN
FOR THE WAYS IN WHICH THE RIGHTS
OF BLACK STUDENTS WERE ABUSED,
THAT WENT COMPLETELY UNANSWERED
AND UNADDRESSED. AND IT'S,
DEVASTATING THAT, WE ARE LOOKING
AT THIS BILL AT THIS TIME, WITH
SUCH TRAGEDY, BUT THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT OUR CAMPUSES
AND OUR STUDENTS ARE PROTECTED
AGAINST ANTI-BLACKNESS,
ANTI-SEMITISM, ANTI-ISLAM,
ISLAMOPHOBIA, THAT THAT EXISTS.
IN SO MANY WAYS. AND SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL, FROM
MY PART, GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL, CLEARLY, THERE'S A NEED,
RIGHT, FOR CLARITY AROUND CODES
OF CONDUCT AND WHAT IS
PERMISSIBLE AND WHAT'S NOT,
THERE'S ALSO CLEARLY, TO MY
MIND, A FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP
HERE. RIGHT? NOT BY STUDENTS.
RIGHT. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY, BUT BY, BY, BY
FACULTY AND OTHERS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE SHAPE THE ENVIRONMENT
IN WHICH LEARNING TAKES PLACE.
AND THAT'S A HARDER THING TO
LEGISLATE. THERE ARE, AS OUR
ANALYSIS NOTES, SOME ISSUES OF
LAW AROUND THIS, BUT THAT'S
THAT'S PROBABLY BEST TAKEN UP
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SO HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY, DON'T
KNOW IF WE HAVE A MOTION, BUT IF
SENATOR WILK, BUT, SENATOR, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE STUDENTS FOR
BEING HERE, THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL REMARKS. I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. YOU KNOW,
EVEN WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
DIVISIVE ISSUES, YOU KNOW, ALL
STUDENT VOICES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BE HEARD. NONE SHOULD BE
SILENCED. THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF STUDENTS AND
SAFEGUARDING THEIR FREE SPEECH
RIGHTS. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
RESTORE AN ENVIRONMENT, WE HOPE,
OF CIVIL DISCOURSE ON OUR
CAMPUSES. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT,
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE. ITEM 16 SB 1287.
GLASER. MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN A NEWMAN I OKOBOJI I
OKOBOJI I CORTESE. CORTESE I
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I WILK I. WILK I. THAT
MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS SIX VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE TIME
BEING. AND I THINK DID WE DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR? WE DID NOT.
DID WE? WE DID. ALL RIGHT. SO
LET'S REOPEN THE ROLL FOR THOSE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE NOW. BUT
WE'RE NOT HERE EARLIER, AND WORK
OUR WAY THROUGH IT. PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
CORTESE CORTESE. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS CONSENT. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THE MEASURE HAS SIX VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN. NEXT, PLEASE.
FILE ITEM TWO, SB 1056. RUBIO.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND ONE
NO. WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
THAT MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS FIVE
AYE VOTES. ONE. NO VOTE. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE TIME
BEING. FILE ITEM FOUR, SB 1063,
GROVE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED. CURRENT VOTE IS TWO
EYES AND NO NOS, WITH THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. CORTESE CORTESE.
AYE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. THEN
MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS SIX VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ITEM
FIVE, SB 1094 LIMÓN. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NOS. WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I HAD
MEASURE HAS SIX AYE VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN AT THE MOMENT.
FILE ITEM SIX SB 1166 DODD.
MOTION IS Dð PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NOS. WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTESE.
CORTESE. AYE. GLASER GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. THE
MEASURE HAS SIX VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR NOW. FILE ITEM
SEVEN SB 1222. ALVARADO GIL.
MOTION IS DUE. PASSED. THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND NO
NOS, WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
CORTESE CORTESE. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
THAT MEASURE HAS SIX VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE TIME
BEING. FILE ITEM EIGHT, SB 1241.
PADILLA MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS TWO
WISE AND NO. NOS WITH THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE CORTESE. CORTESE.
AYE. GLASER. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. THAT
MEASURE HAS SIX VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE TIME BEING
. FILE ITEM TEN, SB 1283, STERN
MOTION IS Dð. PASS AS AMENDED.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NOS WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. CORTESE
CORTESE. AYE. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
OKAY. THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
THE MOMENT. FOR ITEM 11, SB
1421. STERN MOTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED TO CHEN. SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR EYES AND NO NOS WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
LAZER GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE AND MEASURE HAS SIX
VOTES STILL LEFT OPEN FOR NOW.
FOR ITEM 12, SB 1378 MEN. MOTION
IS DO PASS, AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO EYES AND NO
NOS, WITH THE VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
CORTESE CORTESE. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
THAT MEASURE HAS SIX VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR NOW. FOR
ITEM 13, SB 1194. NEED A MOTION?
WE HAVE A MOTION ON SENATOR
WILKES 1194 FROM SENATOR GLASER,
FILE ITEM 13, SB 1194. WILK
MOTION IS DUE. PASSED A SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH 1194.
OTOBOKE. AYE. CORTESE. CORTESE.
AYE. GLASER GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. WILK
YEAH. WE'LL GET AHOLD OF HIM.
OKAY. MAYBE HE'S ABSTAINING. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
NOW. WE NEED A MOTION ON SB
1233, ALSO FROM SENATOR WILK. SO
MOVED. MOVED BY SENATOR GLASER,
FILE ITEM 14, SB 1233. WILK
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN.
AYE. OKOBOJI CHO. VÚI. CORTESE.
CORTESE. AYE GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WILK.
ALL RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
NOW. AND NEXT IS, SB 1287.
RIGHT. 1200. SORRY, FILE ITEM
15, SB 1200. GLASER. MOTION IS
Dð PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE AYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ
SMALLWOOD. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. ALL RIGHT THEN.
MEASURE HAS SEVEN VOTES AND
MOVES OUT. AND SB 1287. SENATOR
GLASER, FILE ITEM 16 SB 1287.
GLASER GLASER. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE VOTE IS SIX AYES AND
NO NO'S, WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. FILE ITEM 17, SB 1431.
CORTESE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE EYES AND NO NO'S
WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE SEVEN
ZERO. THAT MEASURE IS OUT SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO. AND LET'S GO BACK
THROUGH THE ROLL FOR. IT'S OKAY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. WELCOME. OKAY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE SEVEN
ZERO. THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO, FILE ITEM TWO, SB
1056. RUBIO GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SIX
VOTES TO ONE, FILE ITEM FOR SB
1063. GROVE GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO. ITEM FIVE SB 1094
LIMÓN GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES
TO ZERO. FILE ITEM SIX SB 1166
DODD GONZALES. GONZALEZ. AYE.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES
TO ZERO. FILE ITEM SEVEN SB
1222. ALVARADO. GIL GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. THAT MEASURE IS
OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO FOR
ITEM EIGHT 1241 PADILLA.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO, FILE ITEM TEN. SB 1283.
STERN GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SHE'S NOT
VOTING? NO. SHE DID. SHE
ABSTAINED. OKAY. THAT MEASURE
HAD SIX VOTES TO ZERO. FILE ITEM
11, 1421 STERN GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. AND THAT MEASURE
IS OUT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. FILE
ITEM 12, SB 1378. MEN. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. THAT MEASURE IS
OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. ITEM
13, SB 1194 WILK GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. WILK SHUSH! WILK.
AYE THAT MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO, FILE ITEM 14, SB
1233 WILK GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. WILK NØ. THAT MEASURE IS
OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. SEE
YOU, SENATOR, THAT IS THAT IS
THAT CORRECT? SO THAT ACTUALLY
CLOSES THE ROLL. SO, HAD ALMOST
EXACTLY 12. NOT QUITE, THANK
YOU. EVERYBODY WHO IS STILL HERE
WHO ACTUALLY WORKS HERE. SO
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HARD WORK,
AND WITH THAT, THE SENATE
COMMITTEE EDUCATION IS
ADJOURNED.